Pizza
good morning if I could ask everyone to
take their seats so we can get started
good morning welcome to day two of the
governor's budget hearing uh we'll get
started right away and then I would like
to invite the university system of New
Hampshire for their testimony
good morning
good morning nice to see you all I'm Jim
Dean I'm the president of the University
of New Hampshire and also the interim
Chancellor of the University system of
New Hampshire
I don't know if Kathy preventer needs
any introduction but if so she is the
chief financial and chief administrative
officer of the University system I also
have with me my colleagues Melinda
Treadwell president of Keene State
College and Don Burke's president of
Plymouth State University and we
appreciate the opportunity to speak with
you today so we have the handout which I
hope you have in front of you which has
our our logos on the front
good
all right so with that I'm going to go
to page two of that uh that handout
and the point that we'd like you to take
away from page two is that the
university system of New Hampshire and
I'll probably say usnh after this is a
really critical provider of New
Hampshire's Workforce this is a really
important role that we play we work with
over 2 000 different Employers in the
state of New Hampshire and by
coincidence we're also adding about same
number about 2 000 students graduates
into the workforce in New Hampshire
every year
uh we also bring people from out of
state out of New Hampshire into the
workforce people who simply would not be
here otherwise and many of them decide
to stay in the state and become part of
our Workforce and as it says here with
the 2x on the lower right hand side that
if we can find a way to provide
internships for these students who are
coming from out of state they're twice
as likely to stay in New Hampshire and
become part of the workforce that we
desperately need and so anticipating
what we will be saying this is part of
what we're trying to get some funding
for is to help provide those kinds of
internships
on moving to page three really the point
here is is in green without additional
funding our ability to continue doing
this and helping the economy and the
workforce is going to be compromised we
do a lot of Aid a lot of financial aid
to attract students here and to support
them once they're here and to help them
to complete their degree
we without additional State funding will
have fewer resources to partner with
employers to work with them closely work
with them on internships and so on and
the thing that we're really trying to
avoid here is hire in-state tuition and
we'll give you some additional details
about tuition and how we've managed that
over the next few slides
thank you
moving to page four uh as we've already
said we work pretty closely with the
business Community within New Hampshire
and we work particularly closely with
the business and industry Association
I've joined the board of the Bia to try
and enhance the links between the
university system and the business
community of New Hampshire and that
that's really been a great relationship
and I'm happy to say that the Bia has
expressed their very strong support for
enhanced funding for for usnh because
they understand how important the role
it is that we play in being able to
bring more people into the workforce in
New Hampshire either from in-state or
from out of state so we're very happy to
have have their support
and some of the details are are down
there about increased Aid to retain high
school graduates in the state train and
retain UNH CR usnh graduates and address
the health and well-being challenges of
our residents and we'll give a lot more
detail about those in just a couple of
minutes
excuse me moving to page five uh the
chart that we have on there the first of
the chart I imagine this is familiar but
we wanted to just remind everyone that
New Hampshire provides less support to
students than any other state so you can
see whether it's by per capita on the
left side in blue or per income per one
thousand dollars in income on the right
side in green we are 50th out of 50
states and
the reason that that's not just an
abstraction or a talking point is that
well by definition the other New England
states are providing more help to their
students and therefore to their
universities than we are and that makes
it easier for them to compete with us
even for students from within New
Hampshire so the states will put up
Billboards that says you can come to our
state and pay the same tuition that you
pay in New Hampshire which makes it very
difficult for us to retain people in New
Hampshire
moving on then to the the next slide
uh any and again uh Mr Jerry I know
you're new so I don't know how much of
this history you know but we did receive
and this was before my time as well I
will say uh the system usnh received a
very significant funding cut in 2012.
um I can't imagine many University
Systems in the country have ever
experienced a 50 budget cut in one year
and we've not recovered from that budget
cut that took place now 10 years ago
and our request that you see there in
the the blue bars on the right side is
simply to restore the funding from 2011.
from now 12 years ago and that's uh
these are in uh current dollars not
Clemson dollars so this is ignoring the
impact of inflation over that period of
time so we're trying to get back on a
constant dollar basis to the funding
that we had uh more than 10 years ago
okay moving then to the next slide I'm
going to turn to my colleague Kathy
preventer
thanks Jim
um again good morning for the record
Kathy Province your uh chief
administrative officer
for our state's University system so on
slide seven this is a mirror of what you
find on page 4084 of your budget book
we have requested
um a three percent increase in fiscal 24
and flat and fiscal 25 as the efficiency
request
our funding has been flat I believe for
four years now we have held two in-state
tuition flat for the last five years and
our board just voted in October that it
will remain flat in the next academic
year our additional prioritized requests
are targeted specifically to Plymouth
keen and Cooperative Extension
and the it's not sustainability dollars
for Plymouth and Keene it's primarily to
increase internship opportunities and
increase problem solving work that's
done at Plymouth and I'll talk about
that in a minute excuse me the regional
campuses across New England just not not
just in New Hampshire our regional Camp
higher education
campuses across New England are entering
a period of severe headwinds and we are
doing everything we can rethinking all
our work restructuring preparing for
those headwinds and they will
become more Strong by 2025
so these dollars targeted at Plymouth
Keenan Cooperative Extension
will bolster the economic engines that
Plymouth and Keene provide to the Lakes
Region North Country and the Monadnock
region relative to Partnerships with
business nonprofits community-based
organizations
so if you so we're again the additional
prioritized requests recognizing its
significant investment but four million
dollars in 2024 and 13 million dollars
in 2025
and if you flip to the next slide I want
to just cover with Plymouth and Keen
what we intend to Target those
Investments toward also starting on page
4087 of your budget book you'll find all
of the outcomes that we've identified
what these dollars
um
will will do what what the goals are
that we intend to achieve with the
additional prioritized requests
the intent on the funding for Keene
State is to increase excuse me the
number of businesses that Keene State
engages with by 15 percent
from 80 to 105 by the end of the
biennium and internship opportunities
that Kian would double from 100 to 200
students
Columbus State
um has an under Don bursts leadership
has reimagined how the delivery of
higher education on a cluster model
multi-disciplinary
projects are worked on but students from
different majors and they go out and and
help businesses again businesses
non-profits Community organizations
solve problems
every student at Plymouth does one of
those projects during their their four
years
um at the University
Plymouth would like to double that to
get more more projects more engagement
in the North Country in The Lakes Region
and around the state we also have
examples I'll give those to Michelle
before we leave of the types of projects
that have been undertaken by students at
Plymouth State and those additional
dollars would fund those um those
projects the other
um you know we offer the granite
guarantee which provides free and state
tuition to Pell eligible students and it
is um a significant cost especially at
Plymouth and Keene and we'll be able to
sustain the granite guarantee with these
additional prioritized needs funded
and on slide nine the other ask we have
is for Cooperative Extension three
million dollars in 2025. Cooperative
Extension has very very wide reach
across our state
and they they don't just work on Farming
and Forestry they have significant
educational
programs across the state and with
additional funding
um we we can
expand the the education that we provide
to older adults relative to chronic
disease and pain self-management from
250 to 750. these are just examples we
can increase the number of um schools
that we participate with teaching about
nutritional value
um
helping parents with food insecurity
again educational pro programs and also
last year Cooperative Extension
delivered education to 600 people across
the state relative to mental health
programming and with additional funding
they believe they can ramp that up to 3
000 people and I can we can provide more
details those are just examples of what
Cooperative Extension could do with
additional funding I'm going to turn it
back to you Jim okay thanks Kathy so now
we're on excuse me on page 10 of the
handout and the next couple slides are
really about what we've tried to do to
survive and flourish in the environment
that we're in and what this slide shows
what we've been able to do for net
tuition and fees and I know sometimes
tuition the way people talk about it is
somewhat complicated and so we've
already mentioned that we've kept the
nominal tuition flat for five years but
what we've actually done through the use
of financial aid is to actually reduce
what's known as net tuition and so net
tuition is simply the amount that
students actually pay not the so-called
list price so we've kept nominal tuition
flat but actually reduce the cost for
students even at in this time of of
higher inflation so our priority across
the the university system is really
about students and really trying to help
them be successful and to flourish many
of you are aware of that debt challenge
that many students across the country
have and this is one way that we try to
address that by trying to keep tuition
as low as possible even under difficult
circumstances for our students
how have we been able to do that
basically by reducing our costs so what
I want to emphasize here is that we
didn't just run into problems and come
to you saying you know we need more
money we've been working really really
hard to reduce our costs to be able to
keep tuition down for for quite a number
of years now and so the big number in
green there is the 50 million dollars
reduction in operating expenses
and Kathy for context that's against a
budget of 800 million dollars ish okay
something like just for context I
thought that would be helpful and you
can see that that reduction comes both
from employee compensation as well as
other operating uh expenses and if you
think of universities as something like
running a city we have all of the things
that are associated with that so as as
you listen to the other president
presentations we'll be doing many of
those same kinds of things so we have
really tried to get our house in order I
know that there's a stereotype about
higher education that costs just go up
and that's not true for us our costs
have been going down there's a
stereotype that tuition goes up that's
not true for us our tuition has been has
been going down and we've done a lot of
work before we would come to you and say
we think we really need to have some
additional funding in order to to
fulfill our mission
uh the next slide is probably I don't
know A variation on a slide you're going
to see from a lot of people coming in so
we're subject to the same inflationary
pressures uh as everyone else for the
cost of heating and so on but we were
able to reduce expenses whole tuition
flat and increase financial aid despite
the pressures of inflation that we've
been facing especially over uh over the
last year or two and that's really a
reflection of a lot of hard work by a
lot of people across the university
again there may be a stereotype that
people who work for universities are not
cost conscious or are not trying to
reduce expenses or are not concerned so
in the case of the University system of
New Hampshire really none of that's true
we have a lot of people making really
hard decisions to try and and manage
costs and reduce costs in the face of
the challenges that we're facing and
it's something that I know that Don and
Melinda and I and Kathy and all the
leadership team we're really proud of
that is it's not easy to do that so
I'm happy to have the opportunity to
talk about that a little and and now
going back to Kathy to talk about this
being recognized by a really important
Outside Agency
oh thanks and we just found out a week
and a half ago that um Moody's has
improved our Outlook from negative to
stable
um and they usually a press release I
think it was the Friday before
Thanksgiving
recognizing that the work that the
university system has been doing in Cost
Containment cost cutting we do
um you know five-year financial planning
assuming that the student had count the
incoming class is going to drop two
percent per year because that's what the
demographics tell us
we assume that if financial aid is going
to continue to increase and we plan
accordingly and independent credible
Source recognize that work uh last week
we are we are as as Jim mentioned we are
in a tough environment doing tough work
the we are rethinking and restructuring
just about everything we can get our
hands on again to prepare ourselves for
2025 and
which is why it's critically important
for us to continue to expand the reach
in the Monadnock region and lakes in
North Country with businesses relative
to Workforce and again with Cooperative
Extension with that web across the state
on how we can impact the health and
wellness of our residents
where we want to focus those additional
prioritized needs
nuts
our Workforce needs in the state and our
quality of life a few years ago we
engaged a number of government leaders
elected officials Business Leaders and
ask about what are the biggest
challenges facing New Hampshire and
there were not really any surprises
there but I'll mention that what came
back to us was Workforce
uh Education Health Care and the
environment and energy and the
university system is actually working on
all of those uh trying to help students
to be able to to graduate and succeed to
become part of the workforce especially
through Cooperative Extension but also
through our growth of programs in
nursing where we're really trying to
address some of the health care issues
and many of the health issues across the
state
so we're trying to keep tuition low
we're trying to support the workforce
and the economy and trying to address
the challenges for health and well-being
of our own citizens and in summary I
would just say that I believe that that
the leadership of the University system
and our our colleagues throughout the
state have really done everything we can
to try and manage our costs and to try
and fulfill our mission in a difficult
environment and at this point we
respectfully ask for additional help
from you in order to be able to continue
serving the needs of the citizens of New
Hampshire thank you
hey thank you very much uh I have a
couple of questions uh one of the things
that's not only affecting the university
system of New Hampshire but but
universities
across the country is increasing
competition for fewer students and as
we've seen I mean you look at the
demographics in New Hampshire I know
you've you spoke about this briefly but
I mean enrollment's been going down
since I believe 2003 and so all that's
heading your way in addition to that
with declining enrollment you've had
increased competition because it seems
from you know now you don't even have to
go to a university or a college anymore
you can sit in your living room and take
courses which I know is is becoming
increasingly popular how are you
positioned and how are you dealing with
that competition and how is it affected
your uh budgetary needs
thank you for the the question of James
as I mentioned earlier that's part of
our financial that's just the reality of
of the environment and that's what we're
planning for that's part of the
the whole cost cutting measures that we
undertook back in 2019 2020 preparing
for this
um
I will say that
this fall
UNH had one of its largest incoming
classes
in a number of years
so it's um
it's really about marketing
um again and it's been I'll add another
layer of complication to what you added
covid right people are just thinking
about opportunities in higher education
differently so
um you know we're also when we when when
leadership in our board thinks about
Investments that we're going to make
it's Roi has to be calculated so what
are the revenue opportunities what are
the Returns on investments that we're
going to make so it's top of Mind
understanding that it's the reality of
the environment that we're in
if I could maybe it's a really excellent
question if I could add just one more
point that as soon as I say it you'll go
yes of course that happens so in a
competitive environment people cut
prices right so the way people cut
prices in higher education is by
providing additional Aid and so what
we're seeing now
effectively a little bit of a price War
if you want to get students to come in
then you so you have to provide more
scholarship dollars and so on so that's
happening as well and at the extremes
there are institutions fortunately not
ours that are
teetering on the verge of not being
successful and you've probably read some
of those stories as well and for them
they will do massive reductions in
tuition in order to just get students in
to get the discretionary dollar and that
makes for a really odd environment to
operate in
okay if you know speaking of that though
if keen and Plymouth can use as a
marketing tool they're going to be able
to double internship opportunities
increase the number of businesses they
interact with double the number of these
real world problems that they can help
solve that could also be a marketing
tool with the additional prioritized
needs for requesting
okay
Switching gears a little bit on your
additional prioritized needs
um
there's four million in 2024 13 million
in 2025. otherwise you could give us a
little more detail on if we fund this
what
if the legislature fund this what uh
specifically what will we get for that
money what would that mean lower tuition
will it mean you know better physical
plants will it mean you know
no we this is not these additional
prioritized needs
are not aimed at tuition
well they're aimed at retaining the
tuition that we have now not lowering it
for correct it'll enable you to keep the
tuition where it is now correct but
um again beginning on page we have an
opportunity beginning on page fourth
4086.
we have some fairly specific targets
um in numbers of the number of employers
we'll engage with the number of students
who will participate in internships it's
and specific to Cooperative Extension
the number of people we will reach in
the variety of educational programs that
Cooperative Extension
um offers as well as that granted
guarantee that Granite guarantee is very
impactful on needy New Hampshire
students
and it's a
a significant weight on on Plymouth and
Keene and maintaining that Granite
guarantee
in financial aid
okay
thank you
hi
um
thanks for coming
um I have fun feelings toward uh UNH in
particular sorry
um because that's where in grad school I
met my wife and uh and that's on your
campus that I proposed so that's the New
Hampshire advantage to me
um whatever you want to think about it
um I have a couple of questions more
broadly you're I think you said you're
operating budget is about 800 million
I'm sorry your operating budget is about
800 million 800 it's growing because
grants are growing but I would say 8.50
in that range
um what what rough and on these aren't
exact numbers I'm sure some of this is
in the system's annual report
um
Oh yay thank you
what uh what percentages is personnel
Place salaries and benefits I should
know that right off the top of my head
Charlie half-ish
of operating
so two two uh related questions you
don't need to answer them today one is
one is what portion of your spend is is
people about half
and what portion of the people spend is
if you divide that world into
um
academic and non-academic if you will
um I I don't want to use this word is
poison on a campus I'm sure but teachers
Professor faculty faculty thank you I
should know that my wife was a professor
at unh
um faculty and then and then non-faculty
and I and I don't say that to disparage
no either group
but
um it's something that I'm always
curious about in terms of in terms of
operating so I remember uh there's a a
guy in a retired uh UNH Professor I
asked him once he taught there for
something like 40 years and I said so
what's the big difference between when
you started in the and he started in the
60s so you know when I was born because
I'm not that old
um
I'm not that young either but um
I said what's the big difference and he
said when I started the the Dean's
office was the dean and a secretary
and he said when I left the Dean's
office was like 25 people and I don't
know what any of them do
very cynical attitude I'm I'm sure but
there's a I think we all have this
notion a little bit of uh the
non-academic staff for for very good
reasons I mean the way you compete for
students is very different and it you
only have to go into the cafeteria it's
also a word you probably don't use
anymore to understand that but the way
you have to compete for sins is very
different today now you're quite right
sir
um when when covet happened it gave us
an opportunity to try and and think
through that issue and see what we could
do and so we offered uh some retirement
incentives and Kathy May know the
numbers for the whole system but I I
know that just at UNH alone we had about
258 people leave something like that uh
most of them were staff and so it gave
us a chance to sort of resize the
university and and that is one of the
reasons why our costs are so much less
than they were today uh one of the
reasons for the growth of staff and by
the way I don't think we have any Dean's
office that's anywhere near 25 people
that's good gross exaggeration
um but are they bigger than they used to
be yeah because we're asked to do more
um for just as one example of an
unfunded mandate you probably are
following or have followed Title IX and
the responsibilities that universities
have in Title IX to try and address
issues with anything that influences you
women different than young men that
started out in athletics but now it's
more about sexual assault
all of us have had to add a tremendous
number of Staff in order to to address
that unfunded mandate
and you don't really get any choice I
mean if you get in the wrong side of the
federal government You'll wish you
didn't so that would be an example but
there's others as well I mean I'll also
say that we have across the country a
mental health crisis among college
students and we've had to staff up to
try and address that we literally can't
find enough counselors but we keep
trying to do that so it's it's easy to
be cynical and say administrative blow
blah blah blah but there's two examples
where you really don't have any choice
to do that despite all that we did make
some very significant cuts to try and
make sure that we were not
any bigger than we had to be in most
areas and and what that required us to
do is to think differently about how we
do the work and to tell you about all
that would take longer than you'd have
time to hear from today but we're aware
of the problem and I think we've
responded pretty responsibly to it I
thought slides 10 and 11 in particular
were
um a wonderful narrative for you
to tell you to tell your story
um the only thing I would end with is do
you have are there State mandates that
are placed upon you I by the way we
hired somebody from UNH Food Service in
my department who was uh
uh must have done a great job for you
because she's doing a hell of a job for
us and so I appreciate you getting her
ready for us you're welcome I think yes
I'm not gonna have the areas in which
we're just getting killed trying to get
and keep people as you know so normally
I don't I'm not able to poach from other
people but every now and again and I
take advantage of it but are we is a
state imposing mandate most of them are
federal I'm sure but it's the state and
doing anything that
there's some minor things I wouldn't say
there's some major ones but Kathy May
know better than I yeah yes there are
there are State mandates
um some of them are combined with
Federal right land Grand land grant
universities must provide you know
Cooperative Extension
um
agricultural experiment station
there are a few others we also provide
free tuition to National Guards men and
women
um and all through state law which you
know we're not going to take exception
to that for sure but but yes there are
State mandates in statute for various
programs that that we're required to to
provide I think people would be
intrigued to learn what some of those
were at some point
oh absolutely because they total about
13 million dollars of the state and that
doesn't include the free tuition the
experiment the AG experiment station
Cooperative Extension
there's a anyway that that total is
about 13 million of the 88.5 million
that the university system receives from
the state
there's also there's a survey on sexual
assault that's in statute that we need
to do every year across the university
system
oops great thank you sorry I I agree
that that would be a really good story
to uh we will um
and Charlie I will leave this for you
thank you there's a chart
there's a chart on page 10 of the report
that will show you the breakdown of all
of our
types of expense expenses instruction
auxiliary
thank you if I could have 15 more
seconds I'll just say one thing that
sometimes it's important to explain is
that many of our faculty are involved in
funded research and they're bringing in
literally millions of dollars from the
federal government and that brings some
costs along with it too but that's
really an economic engine we have some
strengths in in many areas so that's
probably in there as well okay one last
quick question uh sort of the theme of
this to these hearings uh your your
vacancy rate how how difficult has it
been to attract faculty and staff and
retain faculty and staff at the
University system
yeah it's it's been difficult
um probably at least speaking for UNH
probably more for staff and for faculty
um faculty's always been competitive
it's a competitive market especially for
the really strong faculty who you want
um
but I mean honestly it's easier to hire
an English Professor than it is for
someone to work in the dining hall
the issue at Plymouth and Keene honestly
is housing
we can bring faculty and they can't find
housing anywhere so we've been we have
some faculty that are living on campus
and some don't come because they can't
find housing it's
another theme I'm sure if you're hearing
he's yeah
this is just a I think to take off of
what uh what James asked about Workforce
you know we hear from all our agencies
about Workforce shortages but what your
students coming in where do you see them
leading towards in terms of where they
want to head career-wise I mean I know
that they may not know where they're
heading when they're coming in the door
um but the you know on the outside of it
you know we're struggling across the
board agencies coming in with Workforce
issues so how are those you know
students coming in where are they
navigating you know towards in terms of
fields or things like that
it's a really good question and it's
hard to give a simple answer to it I
would say from from Decades of dealing
with undergraduates that there's
sort of two groups and there's the one
group that has their life planned out to
25 or 30 and they're going to go to med
school and they're going to major in
biology and they're going to do this and
that
um uh some of the business school
students are in the same category I'm
going to go be a private Equity manager
or something along those lines uh or I'm
going to go to law school so there's
some that are they're pretty focused and
then there's another group that honestly
have no idea and I will say that the
first group often changes their mind
right and you know I wouldn't
necessarily want to be 18 today going
into this kind of an economy trying to
figure out where's your place it feels
like it's just a lot hazier than it was
I mean you read the statistics that say
people are going to have seven different
jobs for four different organizations
and some of the industries are working
going to work in haven't been invented
yet
so we're again trying to do our best to
support our students in that environment
uh the ones who think they know what
they want and the ones who are sure that
they don't
yeah I
The Internship opportunity
and the partnership with businesses
non-profits and community members makes
all the difference UNH probably four or
five years ago
invested in its own they call it caps
they're career advising and placement
service
it's remarkable the work that's been
done and the success that they've had
Keenan and Plymouth don't have all the
resources to stand that up so we want to
partner with the state to impact the
workforce in those regions of the state
the other thing is it's hard especially
for small business to have the
infrastructure to support the intern you
want it to be a meaningful internship so
we want to build those supports to help
those small businesses in those regions
of the state
to to have the experience meaningful not
only for the business but also for the
student
foreign
thank you thank you thank you very much
always any follow-up questions never
hesitate our contact information is in
the back of the deck we will be having
discussions thank you
I'd like to invite the community college
system of New Hampshire to give their
testimony next
good morning
good morning director Jerry commissioner
arlinghaus assistant commissioner
Rockburn supervisor Caraway and Mr
landrigan good to see all of you and
thank you for allowing us some time this
morning to speak if you don't mind I'd
like to actually start by trying to
respond to the question that director
Jerry asked earlier regarding
competition and demographics in some
ways that's the most common story about
post-secondary education particularly in
the Northeast and in Northern New
England demographics have been driving
that but it's predicated on an
assumption that higher education only
serves one purpose and a high school
students coming out of high school going
to college and in some ways for me and
in particularly for the Community
College systems role our analysis is
that post-secondary education actually
is going to be growing dramatically over
time but it's going to grow differently
it's not going to be 18 year old
full-time students going to college
whether in a residential setting or
Community College it's going to be
reflected in the changes in people's
lives adults who need to reinvent
themselves when the economy changes when
technology changes when their lives
change they require education in
different forms it's also the case that
the population that even the traditional
population if you will that
post-secondary education is going to
serve is going to be different over the
next 10 years than it's been for the
last 10 or 20 years and one of the most
persistent
observations that I can share comes from
data that the part of Education provides
each year
and I don't have the current Year's data
but last year 21 of the students in New
Hampshire's K-12 enrollment were
eligible for free and reduced lunch
that's actually down from a couple of
years earlier it's a reflection of their
circumstances and their parents
circumstances but you can look at school
districts like Manchester Berlin Laconia
Littleton All Above 40 percent eligible
here in the state capitol Concord 33
percent eligible we're talking about
students for whom affordability and
access to post-secondary education is
going to be a real challenge for them
and their families
so a significant part of our thinking
over the last several years and I've
only been with community college system
for about 15 months so I'm I'm I'm
learning as I go but a significant part
of the of the analysis points to the
fact that we've got to reinvent how we
do the work we do who we serve and how
we engage those populations so you'll
see that our key themes are about
affordability and access and also about
restructuring the way in which we
deliver the programs and services that
we have we've identified three sets of
priorities that involve removing
barriers and creating bridges for
students supporting New Hampshire's
Workforce through lifelong learning and
then as a bit of a sidebar we're
increasingly cognizant of the pressure
that energy costs are placed on each of
our campuses operationally so we're
trying to push down on that by shifting
to renewable where we can and we think
there's an opportunity to make a
significant impact on our operating
expenses
so I I think I've gone over what's on
slide two and if you don't mind I'll
I'll move to slide four and uh or slide
three rather just talk a little bit
about the reinvention process and
Community College system has faced some
of the enrollment challenges that that
you've described and have been typical
for community colleges across the
country uh post 2011 and 2008 2009 was
the was was the Golden Era refill was
for community colleges when the housing
bubble burst and when the Great
Recession or at least the last raker
session hit adults were pushed out of
the workforce and many of them ended up
in community colleges high water mark
for Community College enrollment at that
point that wave began to dissipate by
2011 and from 2011 on you can see an
exodus of about 2 million adult Learners
25 and older from public well from
post-secondary education no longer
feeling the need to get the education
complete the degree if they hadn't gone
yet because employers were anxious for
the talent that's increasingly the case
today we've been sub
um prior to the pandemic New Hampshire
sub four percent a sub three percent
unemployment for four years and now back
back to that that level again so
employers desperate for talent and the
competition that that's created do I
want to spend the additional time and
effort and money with pursuing a degree
or do I want to go to work and get well
paid for my time right now and part of
what we're trying to do is reorient that
thinking that instead of competing for
students time we're trying to align our
interests with those of students and
employers so that when everyone everyone
wins it's not a a competition but it
really is a collaboration to succeed and
to prepare people to be successful over
time as those Cycles persist so over the
last eight or nine years the community
college system has actually reduced the
size of its Workforce by about 30
percent has done a lot to reorient the
way that our programs are delivered and
currently about 30 percent of our
instructional engagement with students
that is online giving students more
access to asynchronous learning
we see more opportunity to to grow that
area but we also see more opportunity to
spread chronologically if you will and
one of the most well
engaged programs that we offer is
running start a form of dual enrollment
where students have access to college
level learning in high school we're
trying to expand students access to that
in large part to create more
opportunities it helps with
affordability but also helps to bond
students to the state of New Hampshire
and when when President Dean was
speaking earlier about the effort to
both keep students here in New Hampshire
and then also to bring bring out of
state students in
for students who are pursuing four-year
degrees New Hampshire has the
unfortunate record of being the highest
net export on a percentage basis of
students pursuing four-year degrees
nearly 60 percent of students going out
of state for those degrees the
opportunity to use running start as a
framework to attract students to bond
them to New Hampshire give them
opportunities whether they go directly
to the university system whether they
come to the community college system and
take advantage of last year's House Bill
1530 which will establish stronger
Pathways either way we can do a better
job collectively of helping students to
find their way in New Hampshire and for
those students who are less likely to go
to post-secondary education because cost
is a barrier the work that we think we
can do by expanding access to running
start and other forms of dual enrollment
again strengthening the opportunity to
pursue post-secondary not necessarily
for a four-year degree but for the
education whether Technical Training and
career oriented but something that gives
people a leg up and a leg into the
workforce here in New Hampshire
I've shifted to pay page four at this
point uh with with uh with that and I've
jumped ahead of myself a little bit but
let me then just walk back to the top of
that list there
tuition freeze president Dean again on
behalf of the University system was
describing tuition held flat for five
years the community college system has
raised tuition five dollars over the
last 12 years and that's a when it
controlled for inflation instead of the
215 and two in 2010 is equivalent of
about a hundred and fifty eight dollars
so we've effectively removed 25 percent
of the cost of Education by holding
tuition flat we'd like to continue to do
that we think it's a significant part of
that the access mission that we have but
it costs money to do that the ability to
absorb the expense of delivering
programs uh will will be increasingly
challenged if we don't have some relief
there
expanding Workforce credential programs
most of what we do is in classrooms and
online but it's credit bearing it leads
to degrees as I was describing earlier
the change in in the needs for
post-secondary education increasingly
are going to be about short-term
programs very tactical and specific
training programs and credentials that
allow people who may already have a
post-secondary degree to move laterally
vertically diagonally some other
direction that doesn't require sitting
in a classroom needs a shorter duration
shorter impact or a quicker impact to
get back in the workforce and to keep
moving forward and those programs have a
different Financial structure to them
generally speaking not eligible for
federal financial aids our ability to
deliver those programs is going to be
affected by our ability to make them
affordable and accessible to people
expanding Child Care currently DHHS
provides a grant funding comes to the
community college system about two
hundred thousand dollars a year our
observation of the data is that students
tend to participate in that program it
allows for 100 coverage of a handful of
courses fifty percent for another set of
courses no coverage for courses outside
the certificate
what we observe is that students benefit
from the free courses and begin to step
back from those where they've got to put
money on the table and then tend to
disappear not necessarily finish full
degrees in this area the problem that
that creates is that for a lot of a lot
of individuals who go into the workforce
for child care very quickly they find
themselves without the credential the
education really to grow in that field
they tend to be
drawn away to other fields where you
know wages are higher without the
additional education what we're
proposing is an initiative that would
allow us to expand access to child care
education prepare the child care
Workforce but alleviate the barrier of
cost and debt and help people who care
about that work want to be in that field
avoid the the pressure that finances
will either keep them out or pull them
away and we think that that opens up
opportunities for almost every sector of
the state's economy by creating more
capacity see for high quality child care
across New Hampshire
as I started earlier about the Dual and
concurrent enrollment currently we
benefit from a
extensive collaboration with more than
100 high schools in New Hampshire to
deliver those courses that in the
running Start program the legislature
has also grant us a million and a half
dollars in scholarship for stem and CTE
courses to alleviate the fifty dollar
per credit cost for students in this
instance we're not simply looking for
more scholarship dollars what we're
actually looking for some additional
dollars to allow us to be a little bit
more creative can we in fact help
overcome some of the barriers to dual
enrollment in some cases it's because
high schools don't have academically
qualified teachers to deliver those
courses can we have our faculty teaching
those courses on site can we find
different ways to partner with school
districts to to assist in expanding
access to these courses again with the
idea that we're giving students a
stronger foundation for their education
creating more affordability alleviating
the risk of loan and debt over time and
bonding those students to New Hampshire
more effectively
those are the core pieces of what we do
today that we think we can build on
you'll see the next item there is a
tuition reset this is a little bit more
out of the box but what we're interested
in testing is a theory that if we make
post-secondary education more affordable
for New Hampshire we can actually expand
participation Health students and
families engage about 12 years ago
former Chancellor Ross cattell had
initiated this effort and the approach
was intended to lower tuition gradually
with the expectation that enrollment
would grow and service apply and demand
and the way an economist might think
about that
um it did not work out the way anyone
would have anticipated part of it was
the downdraft in in enrollment
particularly among adult Learners at
that point but some of it may also been
that five dollars on a 215 tuition is
not enough to move the needle what we're
proposing is to actually reduce tuition
to a hundred and seventy dollars a
credit that may seem a little bit
arbitrary but what that would allow us
to do would be at least on a test basis
for most of our programs offer what
amounts to free community college for
students who are pale eligible allows us
to put something on the table next to
what Maine and Vermont are doing to to
neighboring states who are are
approaching free community college and
make sure that we don't become at a
disadvantage
in competing for Employers in the area
um yeah but before I go to the last
initiative which is the solar piece
um I would like to just step back for a
second and talk a little bit about what
all of all of the uh changes that we've
been doing with dual and concurrent
enrollment uh mean for us in some ways
by making more of what we offer
available through high schools we've
shifted the portfolio of programs that
we offer we we've concentrated the ones
that we're offering on site with the
most important most expensive programs
that we offer whether it's radiation
therapy nursing dental hygiene
automotive technology electronic
engineering technology if you roll back
the clock five years what you would have
found is with more liberal arts courses
more business courses we were
effectively generating that Revenue that
it was offsetting the costly's more
expensive programs over time as we have
worked hard to make these courses more
accessible through running start we've
shifted that portfolio we've left
ourselves with a more offensive set of
programs but they're also programs that
are absolutely critical to the state so
it's changed our business model it's
something that we've got to navigate and
we've been able to do that largely with
with support from the state so again
didn't want to lose sight of the fact
that underneath the the relatively even
Keel of of what you might see we've got
a shift in the gears that we've got to
to navigate
I mean the last piece is the Solar
projects and again just uh a simple
version of this we recognize that with
energy costs growing rapidly for
everybody some of this is opportunity
can serve resource for the community
college system and some of this is also
because of the scale uh that that we use
the opportunity to alleviate some of the
pressure on utility companies for the
electricity that has to be generated we
see that we've got uh the opportunity
with with moderate investment of capital
to make an impact in both directions
so if I can stop there and perhaps
answer any questions okay excellent
thank you uh you you just touched on my
first question which is you know the the
shift between a liberal arts education
more towards the towards why we call a
more skilled based education and
certainly we hear from employers all the
time and what no one ever comes to us
and says is we need someone with a
liberal arts education they say we need
skills and could you I don't know if you
have even just rough numbers as far as
enrollments in what you know the liberal
arts education versus the those going
skills like like the dental hygienist
nursing uh computer high-tech things
like that yeah our our single largest
program and let me just say full
disclosure liberal arts graduate history
in English and and proud of it political
science policy studies economics and
what we find I I think that most
employers say what I need right now is
the skills over time to grow into
supervisory roles and having the liberal
arts skills critical thinking effective
communication those things pay off in
the long run in terms of value to the
employer uh to have that but right now
what I need is that burning you know set
of skills
um our single largest degree program is
nursing last year we we conferred 243
degrees to our ends another 37 to LPNs
over the last 12 years over 3 200
nursing degrees awarded that is twice as
many degrees as any other program which
by the way the number two in that list
is liberal arts
um but again roughly a thousand a
thousand certificates in welding over
the last decade 600 automotive
technology certifications
um in 400 dental hygienists and
radiologic technicians about 400 as well
you can go down the list and we've got
this broad mix of programs that balance
you know include both a particularly
High concentration in health care but
also a range of Technology programs to
some degree the the throughput if you
will is a product of student interest
we're seeing
relatively stable interest in health
care related programs particularly
nursing
liberal arts is the area where there's
been less interest even though it's
still the second largest number of
conferrals just because a lot of
students and families recognize that
that's a building block for transfer to
a four-year institution or other things
they want to do in life okay
another question on when for your online
component for students who take courses
online obviously that would at least
would appear to me that that would
increase your technology technology
budget and
um
obviously increase that as more and more
students come online are you set in that
area or are you looking for upgrades in
any of your technology areas I I think
the technology is always going to be a
pressure point for us we partnered with
the university system and with
Department of Education in fact within
the last two years for a common license
or at least a shared vendor or a
relationship with canvas for our LMS
their continued opportunities there but
we'll we'll see see upward pressure you
know if I think long term the potential
for technology to enhance particular
particularly virtual reality as an
element again I think they're going to
be growing expenses not just for online
but things that that we'll want to do on
campuses
okay thank you
Hi how are you nice to see you again
pleasure um
I have a couple questions
um I want to start with um how big is
your question I asked um the system as
well the other system as well
um how big is your total budget
operating budget ballpark about 115
million dollars about 115.
and that's across all the campuses
correct okay
um thank you I I appreciate that I I in
the back of my head I always try to
remember this that
the state appropriation is
well it's critical for both
systems that's critical in slightly
different ways we're on smaller portion
of the of Kathy's budget and we're
quite a larger portion of yours
um
which is both good and bad for you
it's one of those things that's a
double-edged sword right it is but it it
makes clear the critical relationship we
have for the state and you know again my
vantage point we're uh we're also a
resource for the state having heard the
governor yesterday describing the
challenges that the state as an employer
will face for delivering critical
services for New Hampshire citizens and
the opportunity for uh in community
college system and the university system
to be into in-house partner for
delivering that kind of training and
it's probably an underutilized uh
resource right now but something that we
could deliver
you know and frankly the the you know
some of us have a more direct
relationship with the community system
the college system than others but
um
it's a critical component and the
nursing piece speaks to that I wanted to
talk a little bit about child care
because that's a you know nursing is a
very very much a headline issue that
people and critical and you know we
you know the veteran system is the
Veterans Home is able to offer fewer
places because they have
staff issues not because they couldn't
take care of them if they had the staff
and that happens everywhere it's very
true in child care and it has a
cascading effect right where where if
you can't get
you know I deal with and and we only
have about 450 employees in my
department but it's something that comes
up
um continually is the the notion of
child care issues and
um you know people who people who take
time off from work to
um become well typically mothers
um and um uh they don't always come back
in a large component of that as child
care
and I mean sometimes it's not child care
which is okay too but if if you're able
to go through with us do you anticipate
will we be able to see results fairly
quickly will we be able to evaluate
results fairly quickly
you know in terms of the duration of the
program I would think that by the time
we sat down next time for a conversation
like this we'd be able to see some
measurable impact
I think this is going to require like so
much of what we do partnership because
part of it is the ability to deliver
these programs part of this is actually
identifying the participants in these
programs and so again thinking about
this as an ecosystem with child care
providers as partners
whether there's an apprenticeship
element to this model something that
helps to engage people directly so that
they don't have even the wait time of
completing the degree but can they begin
to learn while they're earning or while
they're learning and you're partnering
already with with HHS on this
well HHS provides grant funding that we
benefit from I think there's an
opportunity for more extensive
relationship to figure out how to treat
this as a systemic problem rather than
just a funding problem
okay I just it's a it's an area where
where I sat through a
probably a year ago at this point a big
presentation at one other Council
breakfasts on on the challenges in in
this area and uh and I think you know
like I say nursing is a very much a
headline thing but this is just as
critical and he's very interested in
hearing more about you have larger
employers that provide on-site child
care and that's one potential partner
you have a lot of small businesses New
Hampshire that don't necessarily have
the resources to create on-site care but
through some sort of collaborative you
know Consortium agreement in partnership
with DHS that there's a way to build
structures around this to make it more
sustainable and I think that it's partly
the funding and partly it's getting
people to the right tables to to develop
those structures
do you do you have a sense on and I know
this is not on a deep dive your
particular area of expertise but do you
have a sense like let's say we were you
were a particularly large employer and
had maybe 10 000 people working for you
and you wanted to create
um child care
leaving aside the fact that there's
Child Care player
um
do you think we could get the staff
or is that a particular issue right now
um I I think that part of the challenge
has been that this is an area where
there's a fair amount of turnover that
in people's persistence in the field is
is shorter than in other fields and some
of that I think is wage in discussing
that with the faculty than community
college system faculty who work in early
childhood education they identify wages
as one of the primary
impediments to longevity in the field
but education that allows for
professional growth and allows for
increased wages is potentially
sustaining so if you can lessen the
revolving door of people entering and
leaving at about the same pace and
actually build capacity by keeping
people longer growing them in this field
you can expand capacity
okay um thank you I I could go on I
don't want to belabor this though thank
you very much thank you
[Music]
good morning good morning um I
um have done a lot of adjunct teaching
over the years primarily for uh for you
guys and a few others but
um do you offer any and this is really
kind of stemmed from what Charlie was
just speaking about but any Partnerships
directly with employers for
um Workforce training uh so not
necessarily degree programs but
um you know as an example I did a
project once for granite College where
they had a large employer that wanted
some
um Advanced skill set for their
employers you know for their employees
you know and so they offered a course
and they had enough of uh interest that
they could offer a course that was you
know dedicated just for that that
employer really is scalable to others
but and I just I think about that
thinking just in Concord here you know
the large State employer that's right
here and looking for
um more training opportunities you know
that building blocks whether it's the
accounting field or child care or other
areas I didn't know if the school does
any of those types of Partnerships we we
do each of our colleges has a business
training center that specifically does
that type of work or coordinates that
type of work Nashville Community College
has relationship delivering training for
Fidelity
Manchester Community College as an
example is doing some work with both CMC
and the Elliott or Mas and other health
care roles so again we have those kinds
of relationships and from my vantage
point in the State as an employer would
be a critical partner for for us and and
I think a sensible one in part because
we have locations across New Hampshire
whether it's in Berlin or or Nashua
whether it's in Pisa or or or in Keene
so the opportunity to be accessible
where the state's Workforce is
okay and you said you do have programs
so you said Fidelity and CMC as examples
yeah okay thank you
thank you very much thank you greatly
appreciate it
yeah
I'd like to invite the Department of
Education up next
good morning good morning Tammy
valencourt I'm the Chief Financial
Officer for the Department of Education
and with me today is
Caitlin Davis I'm a director of the
Department of Education
so commissioner edelblue sends his
regrets he wasn't able to attend today
he's actually doing college tours with
his daughter
so you have Caitlin and I
um before you is our presentation for
the Department
um if you'll go to the next page you
will see this is a history of our
Appropriations goes back to 2018. the we
have our 24 25 this is our proposed
budget this is what we have submitted in
our agency phase
the top portion is our funding sources
we have General funds of about 25
million federal funds vote about 266
million 1.1 million billion in education
trust fund and five to six million
dollars in other funds
um of note the 266 million dollars of
federal funds does not include our
coveted money right now we have we will
be going to fiscal with about 350
million dollars for our Esser funds and
that will be in July of 24.
moving down we have our general fund
state aid you will see there are many
blank
um cells that's not because those
programs have been unfunded they have
simply been moved down to the education
trust fund and we'll discuss that a
little bit later
um we do have our special ed
Statewide special ed at 50 000 that's
level funded as is our careertech
student orgs fifty thousand
our next category is
um are other programs that these are
general fund pass-through Aid we have
two million dollars for court ordered
placements ten thousand for our
scholarships of Orphans of veterans
147 000 for our New England Board of
higher education scholarships
the 1.2 million is our matching dollars
to our school nutrition federal funds
2.1 million is for state required
assessments
the next four are all federal programs
these are a matching dollars for to
those Federal programs we have a hundred
thousand for our CTE folk Ed
4.4 million for our adult education
program
3.4 million for our VR program
vocational rehabilitation
about 49 000 this is for our independent
blind services
and then we have 700 000 for our
robotics program
the next category is our operating
budget these are our general funds
you'll see an increase in our salary and
benefit lines The Many Factors involved
there are when we reclass positions we
have an increase
we have when we hire staff that are
external to the state we may have to
bring them in at a higher step than what
we've budgeted as well as the yearly
increments for our existing staff
additionally we've moved three positions
into our general funds those are two
auditor positions as well as a contracts
position those three positions will
become part of our indirect cost plan so
that we can recoup the federal funds
associated with those activities and
whatever we recoup will be part of our
department lapse at year end
um finally we did requests for new
positions for the 7D process we were
able to include these in our efficiency
requests the dollar amount given to us
by the governor's office so they will
not be prioritized needs for those four
positions
our next category is the education trust
fund Caitlyn will talk about that as
well as the next slide
for the education trust fund these are
primarily grants that flow to school
districts for various different
grants that are in law the first one
that you see here is building Aid the
building Aid that I'm out is in our
operating budget is the building Aid
tail paying for projects that were
approved prior to 2008 the Department of
Education additionally has a prioritized
need of up to 50 million dollars per
year which is the cap that is in law for
building Aid projects the Department of
Education and State Board of Education
just provided the ranked list of school
district projects for the 24 and 25
budget last State Board of Education
meeting few weeks ago and it was there
are 227 million dollars worth of
requests that the state could
potentially fund for building Aid
next you have school district adequacy
the adequacy that you see presented here
is 956 million dollars that is the
amount that is in our biennium budget
request that we had prepared prior to
our November 15th estimate however our
November 15th estimate has come in a
little bit higher than that at 962
million dollars
tuition and transportation is funding
that is provided to school districts for
the tuition and transportation relative
related to State Career and Tech
education programs
um charter school adequacy is State
funding that is provided to charter
schools in the same manner that District
education Aid is funded plus an
additional Charter School differential
the next down on your line is special
education Aid previously known as
catastrophic Aid that money goes to high
cost special education students or two
districts that have high cost special
education students in a formula that's
prescribed in law that amount has
typically been capped in the past or
prorated in the past last biennium
budget this is the first time it wasn't
prorated however we are anticipating a
proration again this year relative to
increasing costs
um the next thing down on your side is
building a lease that building a lease
is lease Aid that is available for
charter schools so provide lease
payments that amount has previously been
in the general fund and we suggested
moving it to the education trust fund
just as a other building Aid costs are
associated with the education trust fund
and we thought that it made more sense
to move it there
and additionally we have presented a
slight increase because of the number uh
the amount of the proration that we are
currently providing
education Freedom accounts we are
estimating to be about 30 million
dollars next year there are 15 million
dollars this year
um and that includes an amount that is
for an expansion which we'll discuss on
the next page
education Freedom accounts phase out
grants is a separate line item but it's
associated with the education Freedom
accounts it's funding that goes to
school districts when a child leaves a
school district and then takes an EFA
that money then goes to the school
district to replace a portion of the
child's adequacy for a number of years
and then the last two more lines Public
School infrastructure fund so we've
received a million dollars last year we
have requested five million dollars in
our prioritized needs for the public
school infrastructure fund these funds
go to school districts to pay largely
for safety type of projects we just
awarded about 15 million dollars in
across the state and safety projects and
we have ongoing needs of another 20-ish
million dollars just of our regular open
applications we have told the
legislature at fiscal as well as the
executive Council that the department is
committed to continuing to seek funds to
fund those projects so this is how we
are doing that in addition to seeking
additional federal funds for these
projects and lastly you have the ETF
Administration student information
account that account has there are new
student information system that this
it's a Statewide student information
system that the seat has purchased to
replace its uh Antiquated system that
we've had from 2001 you'll see that we
received three million dollars in a
fiscal year
22-23 it wasn't obligated in a specific
year so we those are the ongoing costs
we were able to receive or apply and
receive a Federal grant they covered the
first year of our ongoing operating
costs for implementation cost of that
system so those are the ongoing
operating costs that you see in our
budget going forward
the next slide that you have here is the
Department's proposal for the expansion
of the education Freedom accounts
program the education Freedom accounts
program was passed in hb2 for the fiscal
year 22 23 biennium budget in the first
year of operation there were 1600 kids
that took advantage of efas in fiscal
year 23 we have about 3 000 kids that
are taking advantage and right now the
students in order to be eligible they
must be 300 percent or less of the
federal poverty limit this expansion
proposed by the department will include
additional categories that are are
detailed out in front of you on this
slide
foreign
page four is our prioritized needs so
the first two categories are numbers
that we received the rent from admin
Services they give us a number and we
plug it into our budget as to what they
say their prioritized needs are for the
the renting of those buildings and the
same applies to Department of
Information Technology they give us
numbers that we plug into our budget
the next one is court order placements
we're requesting to an additional 2.5
million dollars
the trend currently is that there's an
increase of about 500 000 year over year
last year we paid out 4.2 million
dollars
the RSA 186-c requires that we pay the
actual cost no matter what our
appropriation is and so we are
requesting we expect that this year will
be about 4.5 million dollars based on
the trend
the next category Caitlyn touched on
building Aid this 22 and 26 million
dollars is the difference between the
tail and the bond for those years in the
50 million dollar cap
so we're requesting
um that as part of the education trust
fund additional request
school security Caitlyn also touched on
the five million dollar
education trust fund request for the
security portion of the edu Public
School infrastructure grants so those
are our prioritized needs
Slide Five talks about our positions we
currently have 291 positions at the
department we've submitted a requests
for 13 new positions of those 13
positions four of them are generally
funded one's to support the division of
edge educator analytics and resources
one for our adult education program and
two for the new office of Early
Childhood Program
the next
um eight we are requesting eight
federally funded positions five of them
are for our special education one for a
vocational rehabilitation to work in the
Nashua office and two for the Bureau of
assessment and accountability
and then finally we are requesting one
position to be funded with the education
trust fund and that's for an
administrator of that one billion dollar
program
the next slide slide six these are
additional general fund requests that
came about after we've submitted our
agency budget
for fy25 we're requesting an additional
000 in general funds this is to close
out our Essa grants like I said that's
350 million dollars we've discussed with
the feds um the possibility of using
federal funds to do those activities
which has been denied so once that Grant
closes in September of 24 we need to do
about 18 months worth of closeout
activities monitoring and Reporting on
those rpasser funds
the next is an increase to our I
previously discussed that we have a
hundred and forty seven thousand dollars
for New England Board of higher ed
that's in our efficiency we have since
received a request from that
um entity of four thousand four hundred
dollars so we need additional four
thousand four hundred dollars to pay
that membership fee now that membership
fee allows students in New Hampshire who
want to take a degree program that's not
offered in New Hampshire to attend any
of the other five New England states at
in-state tuition cost
and finally um under we're requesting a
new position this would be the
administrator of facilities at 425 Hall
Street so we've submitted a capital
budget request to purchase that building
the Granite State Building
um originally I was under the impression
that if we did that that the building
would actually be owned by Das and that
we would continue to pay rent to them
but apparently since we submitted the
request we may actually own the building
and if we do own the building then we
need an administrator of that building
to do all the contracts for plumbing and
heating and HVAC Charlie if you want to
own the building you are welcome
[Laughter]
um so we did an analysis of the rent for
land again Hall and Walker building the
staff that we have at Walker that we
could potentially move over to 25 Hall
that's 467 thousand dollars
um based on Granite State costs they've
given us an estimate of 355 that 355 000
does include the ninety thousand dollars
for that new administrator
moving to page seven if we actually do
own 25 Hall Street we would need
language added to House Bill one
um RSA 9 colon 16 does not allow us to
transfer any of the funds that we have
in our class 28 which is transfers to
General Services basically our rent line
so if we do end up purchasing the
building we need to have the authority
to do those transfers into either a
class 48 or a 103 so that we can enter
into contracts to be able to manage that
building
uh slide eight this is a new Federal
grant that was just received this month
it was accepted by fiso approved by
fiscal and governor and Council it's
called the stronger connections Grant
and it's about 4.8 million dollars that
Grant goes through September 30th of 25
and so we're requesting to be able to
submit a budget to include that Grant in
our agency phase or the budget
and our last request is for additional
capital budget funds
um since those budgets were submitted
last April both of the CTE centers have
seen an increase in the construction
cost
um 1.5 million dollars is being
requested for the Newport CTE Center
that Center has been approved by the
budget uh by the voters and then when a
Squam is requesting another 970 thousand
dollars for their Center and they expect
that they will have approval of that
Center at this Springs vote last the
last vote that they did they missed it
by six votes so they're expecting
approval this time around
peace thank you
I have a few questions I will I'll keep
the 25 hall question for the
commissioner
um going back to the first page the the
spreadsheet uh looking at it it looks as
if local education spending uh has gone
from 3.1 billion up to 3.4 billion
roughly a 10 increase
uh per capita spending has gone from
fifteen thousand eight hundred to over
19 022.
uh my questions are is is spending per
capita to you a meaningful statistic
what does that tell you and how does
that do you know how that ranks either
regionally or nationally
as far as what New Hampshire is spending
per capita
a couple of different things so when
we're looking at the spending per capita
for student the state local communities
and the federal government have all
invested in education in the last
several years so that's part of the
reason why we've seen continued
increases your office has increased
adequate education funding included home
hold harmlesses relative to decreasing
adequacy funds and populations for free
and reduced lunch in the pandemic as
well as adding additional grants
specifically the relief Aid Grant and
the extraordinary needs Grant so that is
part of the increase additionally in
that local spending you're also seeing
increase in federal funding so in a
normal year pre-pandemic we received
around 200 million dollars of federal
funding at the Department of Education
we are up to at one point over 700
million dollars of extra money so that
is part of what you're seeing we
typically if you look at the cost per
pupil we are New England itself self
does typically be as high nationally
however we are usually in the top 10 if
not the top five as far as spending per
pupil
okay is do you manage that number is
there is there a number per capita do
you think that's the perfect number or
it is just what it happens to be
we don't manage it no okay
uh look at the education Freedom
accounts
um it looks like it's basically going to
double next year uh is
how confident are you that that's going
to happen all at once I mean
with the with the numbers that that you
have being equal from 24 and 25
uh is it all going to happen in you know
the first year where it jumps up
dramatically like that um so two
um two kind of no two things to keep in
um keep in mind here so we expand we
doubled from the first year to the
second year which is what we would
expect
any time you know you have a new program
so there's obviously a quite a bit of
ramp up so we would continue an
increased ramp up relative to the new
program however that that 30 million
dollars does include the expansion that
we've proposed to the number additional
number of students the department of
education does have some data with some
of these numbers of the students but
some of these categories we don't have
data so we uh kind of just looked at our
projections and what we have now and
that was our best guess that we could
come up with with these numbers okay uh
if the nation does go into a recession
which
um where we are I mean the governor's
office is predicting
that will obviously mean that far more
many far more people are now eligible
for the program under the original
guidance which is what the 300 level is
that taking into account here we did not
take that into account no okay if it did
that would obviously be higher that
would include additional children that
it could be eligible yes okay thank you
thanks I have a handful of questions
um
the efas are they statutorily capped
the number that we're allowed to give
out yeah no no okay I didn't think so I
just wanted to check on that
um it's just an income cap per student
or per family rather
so the budgeted number would be
fundamentally an estimate correct yeah
um
and does it carry forward year to year
it doesn't carry forward but it's uh we
have a warrant Authority
so no matter what the appropriation is
we have a want to draw on that okay oh
that makes sense um secondly for special
education Aid I think you said that um
the 33 9 is a cap
um it's yes it counts and and prorated
it's prorated prorated if it weren't
prorated and it were just uh given out
according to the formula do you have an
estimate for how much that would be
um
um I believe it's right around 34 35
million so it's not capped by very much
this year
um one thing to keep in a um keep in
mind that we don't know what is going to
affect yet is that the law change to
include students up through the age of
22 but so that will include some
additional kids that not may have not
been eligible in the past but we're not
sure what that is
um
an additional factor is is that any
appropriation that's left over in this
line at the end of the year so if we did
have excess appropriation it goes to
fund our court ordered placements
oh yeah okay
I've forgotten that entirely
um but generally speaking even with the
even with the 22 and the in the mix
you'd be looking at
if we didn't put a proration on it it
would be more like uh 36.37
it would likely not be a substantial
increase okay
um
again another thing um who told you that
if we if the state buys the building
that you need to set up a property
Bureau
that's I don't understand what who told
you you have to manage your own
facilities
um one of your staff said that he told
me that we put in the capital budget so
he did not expect that it would be a Das
building
okay he's rolled
I would be happy for you to manage that
building
there are statutes that would have to be
changed amended and will be written
and it would be weird for
every agency to manage its own buildings
nope
I just had a court order placement
because I was just thinking about that
when Charlie mentioned it um is that
currently um funded from funds on others
appropriated if it exceeds that amount
that's where that comes from it's
generally funded it's generally yes we
request a warrant for additional sites
okay and the education Freedom accounts
because that's also a similar thing only
education funded is that done usually
just once a year or do you make payments
throughout the year on that
we have three four payments throughout
the year September 1st November 1st
January 1st and April 1st I was thinking
something was more front loaded so
September November it follows the same
schedule as Traditional School District
adequacy okay
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you
foreign
from the executive Council
up to give their testimony
[Music]
we'll see my name
foreign
we have invited the executive Council up
to give their testimony
three more minutes we just want to
zeroed it out but
good morning
hey could you put your microphone in the
red button that's probably better watch
all the times I've given people a hard
time on not turning their mic on
glorious okay so again for the record my
name is Megan Rose I'm the executive
assistant to the executive Council our
office is made up of myself a part-time
position and the five executive
counselors
um what you see before you in my budget
request or at least what I'm hoping that
you noticed is that I met the targets I
was asked to meet
and then um did the best that I could
for the efficiency budget and then the
additional prioritized needs addressed
two of the important things that we need
for our office and to help us kind of
keep things running smoothly the first
is
increasing what exists in our budget so
we can have an adequate
amount to pay a part-time staff member I
currently have a part-time staff member
who is asking to be done sadly for me
and as I'm sure everybody knows it's not
exactly easy to
recruit people especially for a position
that does not offer any benefits of any
sort there's no time off there's no
um
health benefits for vacation benefits
and so it really is going to be a unique
challenge to fill the position and I
would like to be able to make sure that
I can offer somebody a wage that will
help entice them to come fill in and be
there as an assistant to help me assist
the counselors and then to make sure
that we maintain office coverage when
um if I'm not available or if I'm on
vacation or if I'm Ill
the other thing that we're addressing in
the budget is
the stipend increase for the council so
the counselor the council unlike
um
the legislature they get a step a
stipend and that basically covers their
travel so back in the days of
the early days of Ray Burton
um the base basically how it was handled
is the counselors had some kind of a
phone at some point that was issued by
the state and they had travel
reimbursement and
um that eventually changed over to just
a stipend that they would a fixed
stipend that they would get every month
that would cover like mail or postage
from their home it would cover all of
their travel it would cover like
the use of their own home phones or cell
phones
um that has not increased in the last 14
years
and we the increase that we have asked
for to kind of catch them up a little
bit is basically the equivalent of the
last
over the last 14-ish years or 12-ish
years uh like a two percent increase
the amount would be the amount is a
little bit different so district one has
always historically because it's a
larger District received a little bit
larger of a stipend
as opposed to the other four districts
but with the recent redistricting and
the size of District 2 now being very
close to District One both of those
districts would be receiving a slightly
larger stipend for their travel needs um
as opposed to the latter three
excellent uh question on that sure when
when I when I first saw this I thought
well that doesn't make a lot of sense
and then I looked at the map and I saw
with the redrawn map we're like oh that
makes a lot of sense but other than just
eyeballing looking at it uh do you have
any or could you get any numbers behind
it such as if your district is over so
many square miles you get this if it's
under you get that so there's not just
you know me looking at a map saying okay
that makes sense well it's funny you say
that so yesterday the 11th hour I
decided I wanted to know how like the
square mileage we're talking about
so I I looked that up for district one
in District Two I haven't done the
latter three yet but district one covers
we'll say approximately because I mean I
did check my math but you know and this
is specifically just land
um because when you look up the square
miles it will include it will give you a
total and then it will break that total
down to land and water
so Council district one covers
3639.87 square miles
approximately
and Council District 2 is
3081.53 square miles
how about the others don't know yet I
didn't get that far but they they're
significantly less yes significantly
less yes
okay that was that was Mike would you
like me to come back like provide the
other three
at another time I I think it would be it
would be helpful during the legislative
phase because you may get asked that
question okay
I would just say having having
researched this myself
um
yeah historically
you know and I only went back about 35
40 years but um
the uh
you know going back to the late 80s uh
love was Ray Burton's sister then too
wasn't it
um that District was more and everybody
else's class and it was you know I think
it started out he got nine thousand they
got six thousand and historically you
look at the redistrictings of the of
1980 1990 2000 2010
and there was always this anomaly
there's one giant District in the north
and four Rel moderately compact
districts in the South and
um
and that dramatically changed in the
last three districting and and
um I think you could do a stipend based
on number of towns you could do a
stipend because in theory an executive
counselor is going to visit each of his
or her towns frequently
you could do it based on some sort of
DOT road mileage thing well that that
becomes a whole different kettle of fish
or you could do it based on eyeballing
and I think at the end of the day it's
very hard not to look at the map and go
two of these things are the same way and
three of them are a different way and uh
and to do it that way and I think it
makes sense but I think I think it would
not make sense or be defensible to do
just district one or just District Two
correct yes I did you have to do
district one and two otherwise you end
up in a weirdness
um entire mic agreed
question the do the counselors
themselves
are they aware
of the budget presentation yes okay
I mean I they never come and I sort of
get that they're
you know co-equal whatever so that's a
thing
and you unanimous support for this yes
okay great thank you any question great
thank you very much for your testimony
great appreciate it thank you
I would now like to invite the board of
tax and land appeals up for their
testimony
good morning it's great to see you again
I'm used to testifying before you but it
has my old job so
uh if you could just hit the the button
to turn it on there we go I think I did
turn it on didn't I you perfectly now
pardon me ready
red is hot I it was red
thank you for the opportunity
um for the board to provide an overview
of the fifth skill 24 and 25 youth
budget requests as you both know my name
is Michelle LeBron
I am the chair of the board and with me
is Ann stillmack the boards Clerk
um
as I'm sure you both are aware also the
boardster jurisdiction is hearing and
deciding property tax
appeals and we also hear and process
eminent domain
condemnations who hold hearings we go
out
to the Views and the properties where
the where the takings are located
the matters that are appealable to the
board are on pages 11 and 12 of the
budget
it's a long list
um luckily we don't hear them all
but they are available by Statute should
they be necessary
uh budget is a maintenance budget our
only priority that ties needs for rent
and doit
and we have no control as you're aware
over those two classes
uh the board's been very frugal with its
needs and we
have only increased
some classes to reflect the increased
cost and inflation so we've decreased
some areas and increased sellers but our
budget is the maintenance budget
and with that that's all we have to say
unless Miss silmack has anything
you have any questions we'd be glad to
answer them yeah I I have a couple
questions uh I I know in their last
legislative session that uh you like
like many towns and the dra itself had
problems finding an assessor to to work
for you and you had to go in to the
legislature to basically contract that
out we did could you give us an update
on that and how that's working actually
we haven't used contracts yet we've got
quite a few
towns that their mid-process that we may
in fact have to use them the
that contract is only until the end of
this fiscal year though so
coming up for the 24-25 fiscal year
we'll be back to having the position of
tax review appraiser and hopefully we'll
be able to find someone that's been a
difficult position to find right
[Music]
um
they they just
you know
the the municipalities pay much more
than the board could pay for such a
position so we were struggling to figure
out what we're going to do but it is in
the budget for
it's it's at the base rate again because
of the change and um which is another
reason why our budget is a maintenance
budget
do you have an estimate given you've had
the difficulty on what it would take
to hire someone
what it would take to hire someone right
an additional resources from what you
have here
money yeah
let's see if the dollar figure yeah I
think it is yeah and just said six
figures and I think she is the right
um
and
I talked to
[Music]
um
the commissioner's office
when we
I'm sorry I'm losing it to them having a
little bit of pain today so I'm trying
to struggle through
um
I talked to the commissioner's office
when we did go into the contract phase
and went to fiscal committee and GNC and
he had also mentioned that we could also
seek additional funds over and above
even with the board members of making to
try and and do that the problem is we
don't
that position isn't totally full time
we we found that when we have a a person
in that position it isn't
it isn't something that we need
seven and a half hours a day 37 and a
half hours a week it it's an ebb and
flow type of position
so we have struggled and we and we're
looking for advice from anyone on how we
would process that and
do you have any suggestions
no I think that um I think that what
we've heard we've talked to you like
your like dra was we've talked to many
in the field and money is the chief
complaint um the contractors are we've
had a lot of interesting contracts going
forward
um again they are Town dependent on
certain cases so we have two that are
nearing completion with revalves
um one of them
um one of the municipalities I mean that
that could be months and months of work
to do a ratio study and and see how the
balancing comes out
um but certainly it's um as Michelle
said you could have one municipality
that could take months and months to
complete that study whereas a smaller
municipality may take quicker time so it
does evident flow I mean I don't think
we're advocating to make it a part-time
position by any means the research that
I did in preparing was to show that
Statewide our appraiser is one of the
higher paid and even that's a struggle
but when you're competing with a
municipality like Rochester who's paying
109 000 and we're barely able to offer
high 80s
you know we can't recruit it it I was
spinning my wheels ad after ad after ad
um and frankly no one wakes up in this
day and age and says geez I want to be
an assessor they're not coming into the
field it is a I hate to say it's a dying
heart but it is one that's phasing it's
very hard to compete and let alone find
people that are coming up in the ranks
to do this kind of work so it's kind of
hitting us as everyone is understanding
it's twofold I wish personally that the
state would have a group of appraisers
that all agencies could kind of pull
from
we're not the only ones that have
appraisers
um the trick with our job is we need one
that knows assessing and knows
appraising those are two different
um sometimes two different skill sets
um so getting a strict appraiser
doesn't necessarily cover because if
they don't have mass appraisal
experience that's not that's the what
we're looking for so ours is kind of a
complex position and unique in that way
as opposed to someone at dot that might
be just doing straight appraisals all
day we're we need the education in Mass
appraisal so it's a little challenging I
don't have an answer if I did we might
do things differently but we've done
everything we can think of Joe Bouchard
was was wonderful with his information
on this old statute that we were able to
do the cuts to ship the money into the
contract and I do have a line of
candidates waiting for rfps when those
municipalities are done is it possible
we come back to GNC in the next biennium
and say hey can we move it one more time
and then if if that does prove we have
to prove that that's going to work that
may be the ultimate goal after this next
biennium if we could leave it in 10 for
now
funded where it is and then perhaps in
that biennium we make the decision to
once again just shift it and then maybe
keep in a contract basis permanently
that might be the solution
um because I think contracts would work
for sure
um because you have a greater pool of
people that don't have you know when you
have conflicts
um that that might be the answer long
term so okay
um yeah I'd like to sit down with you
sometime between now and February and I
have some ideas that maybe we can
craft together something to alleviate
your problem I mean hopefully yeah that
would be helpful
I think a contract is a long term as
might be exactly the way to go and I
think there are multiple people who have
experienced a need for does anybody have
contracts with appraisers other than Dot
um
because they use all theirs
um looking at pill but I think it could
I mean you know a lot of positions we
can't hire because the state doesn't pay
and you don't necessarily need someone
um on call Mike ready to go in the next
10 minutes and that might be a thing
um I have a question
for Michelle yes how long have you
worked for the state
50 years
I just wanted that I wanted to say that
because I we were talking on the phone
the other day and I looked up longevity
payments yes you did and there was and
there and there was one
so I uh I can't say for certain but I
think that it is in all likelihood you
are the longest currently longest
serving state employee
I just I I hope I'm not the oldest I did
not I I did not say that
I didn't go anywhere near that
you started when you were 12 is my
understanding
actually I said it pretty young
anyway that's all I want to say and
thank you thank you very much great
thank you and congratulations on your 50
years thank you
I would like to invite the insurance
department up for their testimony now
foreign
ER of Insurance I'm joined here by
Deputy Commissioner DJ Bettencourt
assistant commissioner Christy rice
and Ted Perkins our this operations guy
behind me and they're here in case I
don't know the answer and I can tag out
um insurance company had a great year I
think we had a record for premium tax
collected at about 136 million uh and
another record for fees uh let primarily
license fees uh between adjusters and
agents of nearly 25 million
uh so the Department's doing well there
we currently have 86 full-time positions
in the department of which 72 of those
are filled or 71 of those are filled
leaving 15 open positions
when you look at those 15 open positions
one of them will be filled on Friday
we're so excited about that uh four of
them were currently have postings and
looking for candidates leaving
um 10 10 other 10 other positions one of
those we've not been able to fill since
2018 and we're not actively looking to
fill that
um but the other nine we are uh we're
we're looking at filling them when it's
appropriate on average those positions
have been open about nine months
um
uh I think it's important to understand
that our insurance public staff are
generally uh highly trained insurance
industry experts that typically come to
the department after years of service in
the industry uh when they come to the
department they tend to stay to
retirement unfortunately we look at our
uh our colleagues more than half of them
are eligible to to retire already and so
as an executive team we're spending a
lot of time ensuring that we've trained
the next generation of folks to step up
and to to serve these critical roles
you'll see in our budget request for
24.25 that we're asking for three Junior
examiner positions uh nearly 20 of our
staff members are insurance company
examiners of some sort and what we've
what we've learned is there's not really
an opportunity to bring somebody on that
has a little bit of the experience that
we need to transition them into that
full career insurance company examiner
position uh and ultimately we think this
is the way to ensure that we can
continue to deliver all the services uh
as a regulator uh internally in the
house without having to go outside and
hire Consultants
uh we had uh we had an opportunity this
year with one of our actuaries who
retired
um we were required to hire a consultant
Actuarial firm they build the regulated
entities directly and it's like eight
times more expensive to have that person
on hand and so we have that position
posted and we're looking to find a life
and health actuary
I think it's important to understand uh
what the kind of primary consumer
contact for our department is and that's
nearly 5 000 consumer inquiries that
come in every year through our consumer
division we have seven people on our
staff that are there to manage New
Hampshire uh residents who don't
understand something about their
insurance relationship and it may be as
simple as what does actual cash value
mean or why is something on my policy
excluded and then endorsed back on
something that our people can handle
easily
uh but 15 of those uh inquiries are
consumer potential consumer complaints
and those all uh for 15 turn into
consumer uh investigations uh which
means that our uh our CSO team will
request certain information from the
company we'll investigate whether or not
uh national law has been complied with
um in many of those cases nearly half of
them we were able to get a positive
recovery for our New Hampshire consumer
but most importantly what we end up with
is 5 000 touches to New Hampshire
consumers each year who prior to the
call didn't know we existed and we do a
lot of follow-up of those folks to find
out how they're getting to us and how
happy they are with the results a DJ and
I take those calls uh very seriously in
fact our team meets every week to go
through every one of those consumer
complaints before we close them to make
sure we get the right result and he and
I will sit in and go through each and
every one of them so that we both want
to understand what's happening in the
field understand you know trends as
they're coming and also make sure we're
getting the right result
through covet we saw something unique
and the thing we saw is unique is that
the number of New Hampshire producer
licensees and the number of adjuster
licensees kept growing record after
record and what we've determined is
these National Insurance companies uh
during a time where their staffs and
remote work have just licensed everybody
everywhere I don't think that's
sustainable we we currently have 200 000
producers or adjusters licensed here in
New Hampshire we don't need one for
every seven people that won't survive
but that's where we are today
I think when you look at our budget for
24 and 25 you'll see a five percent
increase for 24 and a two percent
increase for 25.
um
you'll see some of that that is made up
of increases to both of our uh
contractor lines in last year's budget
because of the uncertainty we cut some
of our
um some of our contractor potential uh
spending uh those funds are used for uh
requires for our annual hearing uh the
Consultants uh and the data that we need
necessary to advise the marketplace on
uh the stability of our health insurance
Marketplace and most importantly uh the
the creation and maintenance of our New
Hampshire Health cost website and that's
something we do in conjunction with DHHS
I was a first in the nation a
transparency tool and it is safe New
Hampshire consumers Untold tens of
Millions
happy to answer any questions
thank you uh just a real quick question
uh in in the budget you have uh lines
for overtime and temporary employees if
you were to get the additional uh
employees that you you want brought
online would that eliminate the need for
the overtime and additional employees or
is that in addition to I great questions
um I think the overtime is a product of
our flexibility during covet when we
were asked to support
services across the state we didn't have
an overtime budget and so we had to we
had to go to uh get permission to put it
there so this overtime is literally just
a belt and suspenders in case we're
asked to support someone again and we
have that ability to pay typically we
don't pay overtime in our office
the temporary part-time position is we
we lost our director of Health uh our
life in health this year uh with uh with
some luck we were able to bring on our
former Deputy Commissioner back to help
train the new team and so these funds
are to transition through 24 the team
and bring them up to speed with that so
these would stay here even with those
Junior positions okay and with with the
the 14 and 15 or so unfilled positions
that you have uh how difficult has it
been for you to recruit for those
positions and do you expect to be able
to fill them
very difficult I I think you probably
heard that from everybody so yeah
um you know we're fortunate the
department that we have because they're
professional positions some of them pay
appropriate for that but still it's been
difficult uh our department uh
or get more final we have a position
that's been open for six months we have
an interview for this week we're super
excited about
um and I think with the downturn the
economy I'm hoping that it's a little
easier to
recruit some people on okay thank you
thank you very much for your testimony
we'd like to invite the Department of
Transportation up now for their
testimony
thank you
moments
good morning
good morning hello
uh I'm uh William Katz assistant
commissioner for the dot with me today
is Deputy Commissioner Andre Briere
um I also have with us
um uh Danielle chandranae who is the uh
Bureau administrator for the Bureau of
Finance soon to be our Director of
Finance and Dave rodrigue who is the
current director of operations as well
too so they're here to help me answer
any questions that that um that I can't
answer
so um I would uh kind of in the front of
the handout that we have is a uh it's
kind of a budget letter and I'm gonna
I'm not gonna read the letter but I'll
paraphrase some of the points that and
kind of walk through but that's how
we've kind of structured our
introduction to the state's budget here
um and and really this is to provide a
high level uh summary of The Dot budget
um and clarify some clarify and explain
some of the complexities of how the dot
is um
is funded
um and at the very end as time permits
would also just kind of summarize some
of the challenges our agency is facing
over the next several years so the
handout you have
[Music]
um
provide a comprehensive overview of the
department we we I know Charlie had made
a con and we we do like this comic
because it puts people to the to the to
the to the organization and helps
explain better some of the
accomplishments and and what they did
and you know and what what they do when
um so we find it educational as well
hopefully uh
um engaging as well too but um
um
we the very front part of the um of the
handout what we call Citizens uh
advisory guide we have the dot
organizational structure
um but then we talk about how we break
up our budget so even though we have one
big budget we we tend to think of our
budget in two two parts the operating
budget which really is what we're here
to talk about this time
um for the budget process but also the
municipal Aid and construction budget
um the municipal Aid and the
construction program we have a lot of
discussion with that through the 10-year
plan which was a house bill uh last time
and stuff and all of that effort and our
Federal Highway program
um and the levels of funding and stuff
we have a lot of discussion through the
10-year plan process and that's all
Incorporated
um in the budget but in those levels of
expenditures uh usually dictated by
those discussions and program
Investments that go on as part of the
10-year plan
um and about two-thirds of all of our
expenditures in the states in our dots
budget end up um you know either going
you know the pass-through to the
municipalities or the construction
industry or things things like that so
the operating budget that um is really a
big focus of of our budget hearings is
is primarily Highway funded so I just
wanted to walk through a couple of
um
points of interest about the about the
highway fund so the highway fund is is
where
um unrestricted State of New Hampshire
Revenue that's collected by the
department of safety we don't collect it
it's collected by Department of Safety
and it's primarily the road toll I.E the
gas tax and uh vehicle registration
registration fees they flow into the
highway fund and they're made available
five corporations to various agencies
primarily Dot and dos draw off the
highway Fund in 2022 uh about 60 percent
of the high OA fund uh came to the dot
about 27 percent came to the Department
of Safety the remaining 13 went to other
agencies and municipalities so that's a
broad structure the highway fund is also
where
um all of our federal funds flow into
that's where we collect the
reimbursements from the Federal Highway
program
um and it's also the fund which Bond and
load proceeds flow into in the past
we've had Garvey bonds and other debt
financing to help with the highway to
help with the construction program and
those are collected in the highway fund
as well
um I we we always want to point this out
because you know one thing the highway
fund is not the dot we get associated
with it but uh it is not necessarily
under our our full control and that's
been a misconception in the past it's
not exclusively
um New Hampshire taxes and fees a lot of
federal funds also come through the
highway fund one of the things we always
have to explain about with uh it's it's
uh you know a weekly kind of explanation
is how the highway fund and the Turnpike
fund are a different so the turnpike
fund
um is even though the turnpike system is
managed by the um by the dot the
turnpike system is a separate Enterprise
fund funded solely by the toll revenues
that are collected there so
um that specific 90 miles of road that
uh make up the turnpike system are
separate and apart from the highway Fund
in the turnpike fund and the Turnpike
funds can only be used on that but that
is all Incorporated uh in our budget
um
so on on page two a little bit of a
summary of the of of the dot budget and
and some art of the the complexity so we
have you know four primary funding
sources within the the dot budget first
of all we have the general funding we
have a pretty small draw on the general
fund about 1.6 million dollars in FY
um in in the proposed budget for um FY
24.
um primarily that's our Aeronautics Rail
and Transit group that's funded with the
highway fund uh funded with the general
fund the bulk of our budget as I said
here's the uh is the highway fund and
the federal funds that go into the
highway fund
um with that
um
I had mentioned the turnpike fund the
turnpike fund is about 125 million
dollars in FY uh 24 and that funds the
operations maintenance Debt Service and
capital construction projects
exclusively on that on those 90 miles of
of Turnpike roads
um I make mention uh in the final bullet
about the capital fund primarily because
uh uh in in our budget there's uh
Federal Transit funds that go to some of
the transit programs the capital budget
funds helps fund some of the state match
to those programs so there's there's a
there's a link there
um one of the things I didn't want to
just kind of point out as we look to
compare this bid budget to previous
budgets has been the impact of of
um
of covid-19 pandemic and some of the
emergency relief funding that has come
to the department
during the pandemic uh there were
reductions in in all forms of of Revenue
and uh recognizing this you know
Congress had passed a number of
um coveted relief measures from the
cares act chrisa ARP
um and those funds were used to
um reduce the need for State funds and
offset some of the operational losses
um
so that was supplemental for example uh
there were a number of funds that went
to uh Transit agencies and supplemented
or or supplanted some of those
um funds there
um over the past biennium we had 41
million dollars that was provided to
supplant Lost Highway fund revenues
um and reduced and reduce that at the
end of the last
um
at the end of last year at the end of FY
at the end of calendar year 2021
Congress had passed the investment in
jobs act and that was a surface
um
Transportation reauthorization bill
so the funding levels that were passed
in that in New Hampshire it means about
an additional 20 to 25 percent higher
level of core formula funding
um those funding levels are are
reflected in in this budget over and
above
um
previous years uh funding levels
so the upshot of all this and why I'm
bringing this up is that you know while
the iija provided uh increased formula
funding the foi 2425 budget in in this
budget the use of federal funds due to
both completion of some of the major
projects as well as uh the depletion of
covert relief funds
um
there will be a reduction in federal
funds when you do that comparison
so
um that's all kind of lead in some of
the major components of the budget
summarized on page three and I'll just
hit some of those real quick you know
our combined total efficiency budget is
uh
752.7 million dollars for foi 24. that's
comprised of about
338 339 million dollars about 45 percent
of that overall budget is what we would
classify as our operating budget about
414 million dollars or uh about 55 of
our overall budget is toward that
Municipal Aid and construction
um
projects within our budget so overall
this is a three percent decrease over uh
over our total adjusted authorized
budget from fy23
um
the fy25 budget is about 770
774 million dollars
um that's about a point three percent
decrease from adjusted authorized and FY
23 and an increase of 2.8 percent and
the total budget request from from 24.
uh that total the federal funds
decreased as I had mentioned too because
of the impact of the covert relief
funding our overall Federal fund
expenditures decreased by about 3
percent in FY
2024 and 1.6 in fy25 that's as compared
to the FY 23 adjusted authorized
um
and I just wanted to you know note again
that even though when you do that
comparison it's showing a reduction
uh this budget does reflect the funding
levels from the recently passed
investment jobs act
um and those
um Federal funding levels
um
I had already mentioned about
um how
um code relief funds
um
have been used to supplement loss
Highway funds so you know while our
operating spending has been maintained
at FY 23 levels our actual draw on the
highway fund is an increase of about 3.1
million a 3.1 percent
um due to some of the supplanting of uh
of some of those Highway funds
if you if you're looking fund by fund
the last bullet there talks about the
turnpike funds which were reduced by
about 21 in FY 20 and FY 24 and 8.7 in
foi 25 is compared to Total authorized
as a adjusted authorized foi 23 and this
the the reduction in the turnpike funds
is
um due to a reduction in Revenue
um as as we continue to adjust to the
post pandemic uh traffic patterns it's
also it also has to do with some of the
cash flow and some of the major
construction projects that that um with
that cash flow and the revenue situation
some of those are being delayed and
spread out a little bit longer so that
is reflected in the budget as well
um
I want to be respectful of where we are
for time so
[Music]
um
this budget represents you know Dot's
priorities given the target levels that
were established which was level funding
um there are a number of challenges that
I just want to talk about
um and highlight here one of the biggest
ones we've been facing has been the
inflation particularly in the cost of
Commodities and Manufacturing goods and
they've had a big impact on on the
department so I've got a couple of
examples there price of diesel has
increased by about a more than 150
percent
price of salt has increased by upwards
of 54 percent
[Music]
um
so
a number of those inflationary impacts
we have reflected in our budget in the
um additional needs and in Prime and
primarily in the operations part of the
of the budget so we have
um we show about 13.4 million dollars of
additional uh needs in the operations
budget in fy24 an additional 15 million
additional needs in foi 25. the bulk of
that is in Winter maintenance where we
see you know those fuel increases and
those commodity and salt increases as
well there
we've also been impacted by supply chain
issues
[Music]
throughout and in past years
um you know we've had a lot of focus on
on our Fleet and and sufficient funding
to maintain the the fleet both in the
operating budget as well as capital
budget Appropriations
um one of the issues we've been finding
this year and one of the challenges is
even though we have the budget Authority
and we have encumbrances and purchase
orders out there we can't get them we
can't get them filled just with uh just
with um the way things are in in in the
manufacturing industry
um so while we've had budget Authority
we've taken delivery of very few
vehicles and pieces of equipment
um and we've also been seeing some cost
increases for the purchase orders that
aren't that aren't filled when we go to
the be better you know we're seeing
um you know 35 36 percent increases in
in the secondary in the second um
um
company to fulfill those purchase orders
so
one of the areas that we didn't want to
just emphasize we continue to be
concerned about the fleet and maintain
an investment in in the fleet
um again for the level spending in the
budget we have set set some of the fleet
levels but in the additional needs for
the Mechanical Services budget we have
identified uh 4.1 million dollars of
needs in FY 24 and 6.7 and FY 25 you
know primarily to keep up with our uh
the level of investment that that's
needed to uh maintain maintain the fleet
I know there's been interest in the
vacancy rates in the last bullet we
could just pick on I want to just
emphasize some of those numbers so
um it has been an ongoing issue with the
department and I think across and across
the state and and elsewhere too as far
as trying to meet Workforce needs so we
currently have a vacancy rate of about
22.7 percent
um
that's compared to you know in in March
of 2020 we would historically had run
you know between uh between an eight
nine ten percent vacancy rate just with
the churn of things but we've been
seeing a historic high of about 22.7 uh
percent and that's currently as of the
end of um as of the end of last week
um but that means about 375
373 through the exact uh vacant
positions out of our total positions of
about 16 150.
um
it's it's it's it's a it's a it's a
concern this past um this past session
this past uh um August and September
there was um
a winter maintenance retention policy
and and bonus that was passed uh that
seems to have been successful in
retaining people
um
uh but you know exit interviews threw up
people confirmed that you know the
primary reason of of these uh
separations and retirements have been
the comparatively low wages so
we're optimistic that through the
bargaining that there will be a
meaningful settlement that it will help
stem some that time but the vacancy rate
is is a continued concern and with that
vacancy rate we have had some
productivity
um
uh challenges as well keeping up in with
meeting our our Target needs and that's
been exasperated a little bit as we've
tried to cover life life safety needs so
um certainly the winter maintenance we
are pressing people from other bureaus
uh into
um into uh helping volunteer and
maintain uh winter maintenance this year
over the summer striping the lines we
were pressing people from other
districts into the line striping Crews
to help keep up with those needs
but while they're doing that
um they're not getting to other work
that needs to be done
um we have some facts and figures there
you know Bridge maintenance for example
where we had targeted to have
um
uh you know 12 bridges that they were
going to be working on to remove from
the Red List they were only able to get
to uh
or an account the 22 that Target to
remove Four Bridges they haven't been
able to get to um any of them yet this
year uh keeping up with uh some of the
other just overall maintenance needs
with a um with a lower Workforce
um
so those are some of the challenges that
that we're dealing with and um you know
in the overall uh budget we've
identified
um you know 20 million dollars of
additional priority ties needs for 2024
and 28.7 additional prioritized needs
for fy25 primarily those are
inflationary driven
um driven needs in the FY 24 budget we
did look to have some efficiencies and
um look to address some needs with some
positions added positions but kept the
head count the Same by eliminating other
positions in the additional needs uh
with some of those efficiencies we have
identified
um I think about seven additional
positions to help address some of those
program areas that that need it
so probably about at the end of my 15
minutes I will stop there to answer
questions being respectful of time there
are some other
um
initiatives to improve efficiency at the
end of our letter that that we uh that
we emphasize but uh we'll take any
questions that you may have okay thank
you very much
as we head into the winter probably
uh there's not too much more importance
in in the state than being able to
adequately plow the roads uh I know
that's been an emphasis of yours and you
you did enact this program over the
summer to to try and find more more
drivers and you've had some success with
that at least in retaining the drivers
you have
but do you is it just a matter of money
or does
a simple way to ask the question is does
New Hampshire have enough people with
commercial driver's licenses to meet
your needs
if that's a challenging question I think
across the country uh CDL drivers are in
short supply we see it in the trucking
industry and we see that in other
Industries it's uh
you know some of the uh auspices with
with the
drug testing and things like that that
go along with the CDL certainly when
they're comparing against uh Amazon and
other uh trucking companies that that
may not have the same level of of
requirements and stuff and probably
higher pay it becomes it becomes a
challenge keeping keeping up with that
um
for numbers uh with the winter attention
bonus and some of the other Outreach
that we have done and we have about a
hundred and roughly 180 uh vacant winter
maintenance positions we've been able to
fill about 85 to 90 of those through
through volunteers from other
um other parts of the department and
from other agencies
um so um and that's up so that's that's
been successful
um that's probably a little more than
double than it was in previous years
and uh you know a lot of that is
attributed to the five thousand dollar
retention bonus
um we've also seen in the
um as we track uh the vacancy rate
um it had continued to climb the uh
enaction of the retention bonus seems to
have stem tied seem to have have have
leveled off
um
where um where where you know kind of
stem the bleeding so
um
I I I I I I take that as an indication
that uh yes compensation
um
could be a big help in in filling those
positions uh and and maintaining that we
certainly are con competing with other
um municipalities primarily and and that
type of work
um
but I'm optimistic that that would help
fill out those I I
but with the caveat that that CDL
drivers are in short supply and it is
that it is a nationwide issue
you mentioned the fleet and if you could
just maybe enlighten me on a little bit
how difficult it is to actually acquire
Vehicles now what's sort of the backlog
we've heard from uh Transportation uh
not from from safety about their
vehicles and how long they take
for your department
what's the backlog now in some of the
vehicles that you use
um most of our purchases most of the
purchases in FY 22
um I could I could pull out some some
numbers I have but we've had very very
few of the purchase orders fulfilled the
number of them have been canceled
because the um because the um
because the manufacturing industry can't
can't keep up
um Andre I say you have some of the
numbers there do you wanna
also so
um
uh just for an example
um as part of our capital budget
appropriation and FY 2223 we had
identified a quantity of about 42
six-wheelers trucks um to to purchase
um to date we've had 15 delivered
um 27 are are outstanding
um
of the um of the and and
the numbers are are pretty poor looking
down down the line
um you know we had uh identified two 10
wheelers for um per purchase we've had
one delivered one is outstanding we've
had 38 three-quarter ton pickup trucks
which are our
Highway Patrol form and and um
construction form in the winter
Maintenance Night Riders they go out
there and uh you know we had 38
identified for purchase and 38 of them
are still out outstanding I did see an
email that had come by uh recently that
um
you know reported that uh I know
Department of Safety and they had they
did have uh through the state contract
they were able to get a delivery of of
um
a number of the Dodge charges the number
of the police vehicles but uh some of
these uh trucks and um
heavy trucks and other other vehicles
are are delayed in the purchasing
and from what I saw it was it was a very
indeterminate
um
report of
when or if
they would be able to uh fill those
purchase orders
and for your estimates for costs for
such as fuel and salt that you mentioned
do you assume that they stay at current
levels or go down a little bit or go up
what were your assumptions for for your
costs our assumptions were based on uh
what we were seeing for bids
um most recently so when we're comparing
those costs we're talking about the 54
increase of the of the diesel uh cost
increase
um we're using looking at what we are
seeing for uh the current bids as
composed as as compared to what the bids
were in the in the last um pre-progenic
pre-budget yeah
thank you
hi I had a couple of questions
um
trucks vehicles
are any of your vehicles would they be
eligible to use VW settlement money and
is any of that money being used for DOT
it has in the past
um you were one of the first and I
forget the numbers but we were we were
when when the VW settlement
um monies first came up I know we were
um
probably a little pushy and trying to
get
um get some of those those funds so uh
we're very successful in the first part
of that
um
the requirements associated with that
um in terms of the age and the um
type of motors and and the air quality
benefits that come from taking those off
the off the road
um we have taken we have addressed most
of those older
um vehicles in the fleet so that one of
the things is we've looked at the
remaining VW funds are Vehicles
currently in the fleet
don't you know they're they're
relatively newer they're within 10 11
years so they don't necessarily have the
same
um
impact uh in in terms of qualifying for
the air quality benefits and qualifying
for the remaining VW funds
and that's a sounds like a poorly
written settlement to me I've seen some
of your trucks and they ought to be
eligible
um
my next question Red List Bridges
um we talked about how many we did or
didn't get to this year what from a
status standpoint how many uh
what's been happening to the Red List
over the last couple years
my company are on it only I wanted two
years ago yep
um and they went on it how many came off
so on the positive side on the
construction program there has been an
influx of federal funds um there's been
a lot of attention on on bridge funds
we've we have um through the iija had
received
um I think it was uh you know an
additional 45 million dollars
um a year for five years which we've put
towards uh Bridge preservation and
redless bridges so while uh you know but
so the numbers I quoted were
particularly Bridge maintenance and
those are the smaller Bridges typically
the bridges that aren't federal aid
eligible
um and we rely on bridge maintenance to
you know work on those
um you know and keep them either take
them off the red list or keep or or keep
them from coming on is that a size issue
or a kind of Road issue it's generally a
size issue
um there wouldn't be you know the bridge
maintenance the ones that we do with our
own forces are not the larger Interstate
Bridges they will do they will do joints
or um
um
are are approach rail
um patches and repairs things like that
one of the bigger projects that bridge
maintenance had done this year was a
bridge on Route 2029 they did a deck
replacement over the isenglass river in
um I think it's Barnstead but it's that
section of 2029 between
um like Northwood and Rochester so
um and that was that was probably the
the you know full deck replacement is
um you know probably a larger size
project for them primarily because of
the time that it takes so you know uh
these these crews are are going about
doing a lot of little repairs on a on a
lot of bridges and washing them and
keeping them up to take a crew and in
particularly with the vacancy rate it's
probably in a a conglomeration of of
several Crews and putting them on a
project that takes
um six eight weeks there's a lot of
other little Bridge work that they won't
get to to do that I didn't I I strayed a
little from here from your from your
first question the overall red list
because of the federal funds and because
of I think the success of our program is
is down currently it's a mop-off
membership
I'm not sure if it's in here I I know
last year when we were out talking about
the 10-year plan I had those numbers
right on the tip of my python but I
think the current Red List is about 118
and it is and it is and it is down
um it is down from
um a hundred and some odd and is that
that state and Municipal combined no
that is just State red list and is
Municipal keeping up or going Municipal
has historically been
um running a little higher uh typical
well quite a bit higher I I think and
I'm and I can get you the actual numbers
but I think it was in the 200 uh some
odd range but again with the um
with the iija and some of the additional
federal funds through the 10-year plan
last time we had flexed a lot of federal
funds
um 15 of that 45 million dollars we had
flexed or or targeted for what we call
off system Bridges which are essentially
the municipal Bridges
um it's close to doubling the
um the state funded state aid bridge
program
um
so doing a lot of effort to bring those
um Municipal red list is down in the
10-year plan last time just for instance
we had
um
fully programmed 10-year plan so the
municipal Bridges at you know seven and
a half million dollars per year which
did about three or four per year was
programmed out
um for for 10 years with the additional
federal funds we were able to accelerate
all of those and get done what had been
previously programmed over 10 years in
about five years leaving room
to program more more bridges and we'll
be going through that for the next
10-year Plan update so
um well um that's great and the
am I right in terms of what we send to
cities and towns there's apportionment
Aid and municip Bridge Aid I think are
the two biggest selling programs right
right and how big are they they're both
flattish but they're both flattest
typically uh one of them 30 million
dollars maybe it's around 30 wow and
with the sp3 fortune of SB 367 also goes
toward that so it's roughly I think
around 34 million dollars a long Grant
date that goes to city and towns
and annually
um
the state aid bridge program is about
[Music]
um
it's about it's about seven and a half
million dollars
um and as I said with the federal funds
we're looking at kind of doubling that
in the ensuing use my last question is
about Paving I have interest in Paving
um I don't know why but I do
um it feels like something that gets
left behind and it seems like we ought
to take care of the roads we have I know
there are National statistics on that um
presumably provide on
you know good bad medium or whatever
whatever the standards are and I want to
say to keep up we should be Paving
something like 500 miles a year right do
we what do we have about 5 000 miles of
Road yes ish yep about 4 600 miles okay
State maintain garage let's call that
close close Okay
um do we keep up or are we following
behind
what about overall quality yep overall
quality we have been we have been
keeping up um in 2014
particularly with the passage of SB 367
and the 4.2 gas tax that was
um kind of pledged towards um rural
um Paving and bridges
um we have been able to uh really meet
all of our Paving targets and meet all
of our condition targets for for the
paving system I think in the past years
we you know I think we are we've kept
the paving industry very very very busy
um it's been a priority to keep up with
that
and and overcome some of the past
deferred maintenance so
currently it's good and this is probably
again more of a 10-year plan discussion
we're fast approaching just for
um your edification
in 2025 the
um that additional 4.2 cents of the gas
tax goes to paying paying The Debt
Service on the Tiffy alone that
completed 93. so about 20 million
dollars a year
that since 2014 has gone to Paving roads
and addressing some of the
um again those auth system or rural
loitier roads
um at the 2025 that 20 million dollars
is is is
it's not going away it's going toward
paying the debt surface on the tippy
alone so it will be it you know our
predictions are that we won't be keeping
up to the level that we have since 2014
because of that that's one of the
reasons I ask is I know I knew that
Tiffy and I on the tip of my tongue I
couldn't remember the word tiffia yeah
um but um I knew that eventually we ran
out in 2025 right and so
um
that just immediately places a hole in
what so the level of Paving we're doing
today keeps up
that is to say we we keep the condition
current it doesn't get
it doesn't get worse we repair and 20
million is going to go away so it will
start getting it's not getting worse
without declining if with with the
caveat that if there isn't you know
through the tenure plan process or other
things some
um some way to address that
so I'll watch that with interest okay
and I know that we're a little bit over
time so I'll try to ask a question yeah
I'm apologizing yeah
um I know in recent budget Cycles in
House Bill 2 House Bill 4 there's been
an infusion of some general funds
directly to Highway fund yes and I is in
this budget um do you have any proposals
or requests for a draw against the
general fund either towards the highway
fund or Turnpike funds
can you repeat the question do we have
any assumptions or yeah is there
anything that's that you're proposing
that you there's a need for General
funds to be infused directly to the
highway fund or the turnpike fund
um in this 24-25 budget cycle
no no there isn't but you you made
reference to
um in the past there's been fire
infusion so at the end of the last
budget cycle
um there was 50 million dollars of
General funds put into the highway
funding which is kind of carrying us
through this this biennium so very
appreciative of that that was very it
was a lot of foresight in in in in doing
that
um
one of the issues I didn't I didn't
touch on but it is a long-term con
concern is the um
incremental slow erosion of the highway
fund as as electric vehicles you know
become more prevalent as
[Music]
um
fuel efficiency goes up
some of the lasting impacts from
commutative patterns from from the
pandemic all of those do do impact
revenues into both both the turnpike
system and the highway fund
um
so but so it is a long-term issue to
watch and be aware of but as of now no
proposals
um for for example a house platoon
proposal for any
five million 50 million General funds or
anything like that for us not in this
budget all right thank you so far yeah
thank you very much
good really appreciate it thank you
like to invite the treasury Department
for their testimony
foreign
thank you
[Music]
good morning
okay
just
if you could just turn on the mic
perfect
good morning um Monica say treasure
um so I'm here to provide an overview of
treasurer's budget and
I will follow that
um
that handout it just was provided to you
and so I will start with um
our budget includes several components
of state government so the core treasury
operations included abandoned properties
about two percent of our total budget so
we we have other
um pieces that we are responsible for as
part of our operations
um so um one of the um
so I would like to highlight some of the
um
components of this budget so I'll start
with
um in the beginning of this uh this year
we made a three-year strategic plan and
as part of that
um the work that we did we test
ourselves with review and certain areas
of a certain functions of the treasury
and from that work we um we recognized
that we wanted to make a focus on on
making a couple of changes uh we're
including in this budget
so when we were doing that work we were
focusing on the tissue subjectives and
treasures Mission
um
but keeping succession planning in mind
so one of the um so I'll start with the
structure of the the treasury we
currently have uh 23
um authorized positions and what we are
proposing as part of this but it is also
to uh create and this budget the office
of investment and debt management so
previously
um this function of investment that
management was included in the treasury
operations accounting unit and now we uh
with this work that we did we are
recognizing there are some areas that um
just require a little more of alignment
with what the law was describing and so
we are also
um redefining the roles and
responsibilities of this position and
the positions in charge of this function
and so they're now included in this this
new office
another
um another
um
change or or VISA we want to include in
this budget that was a result of this
work that we did early this year is that
we would like to
um migrate to
um it RIT function to the office to the
Department of Information Technology we
currently have one it employee providing
the I.T support for us we started with a
three employee function we lost one
position years ago and so right now we
have a vacant position it has been
practically impossible to fill that
position so we
again recognizing
um you know the situation that we're in
having one employee supporting uh the
active function of the treasury and and
how we support the state
um we spoke with commissioner Goulet
about our interests and transition and
that function to doit uh commissioner
Goulet was
very helpful and provided on the process
of how we can how we can do that and so
he's staff and myself were to put the
budget together and so we're including
additional costs what it will take for
the treasury to transition essential
active functions to to be supported by
by doit
um those additional costs are being
included under the prior to prioritize
additional prioritized needs uh column
just because it's a new a new cost
um so what that's going to do is it's
going to increase the cost and fiscal
year 23 as we transition to that
department we also going to have to
incur certain costs internally in order
to continue the operations as that
transition occurs
um but then if it's clear 25 those costs
will will remain more constant and and
again going forward that's that's what
it will continue to be
so um
so that's those are the really
highlights and changes of um the
treasury operations accounting unit uh
again that will impact also
um the additional I.T cost will impact
the accounting units where we have
employees on the abandoned property
operations
um the new office that will create an
investment in that management and
there's another
um
we have another employee and the
governor scholarship program that I'll
I'll describe a little more further in
the presentation
so moving on to the next um
change that we're proposing is in the
accounting unit relative to the return
of general fund deposits this is where
we record
um the activity and the payments uh
relative to abandoned property claims
that are for property that has Venice
cheated to the counties and the general
fund
so we would like to Budget on a month
for the first time and these payments
have been made without being budgeted
before since 1985 and so the current
process is that we attend the government
council meeting every time they need to
request that the controller issue a
warrant to pay this make these payments
um so over the last few years we have
implemented
um we haven't
um improve our technology and we
introduce efficiencies in the event of
property program and now we're able to
pay claims
um quicker you know we have an ability
to submit claims electronically we have
introduced a fast track uh component
that
um once the if if there's a claimant
that requests um
it initiates the claim online and if you
meet certain characteristics the system
will automatically approve the claim so
that works well for the regular claims
meaning for property that has not been
as cheated before property has been as
cheetah we have to go through that
process I just describe so um so by
budgeting for the first time it will
allow us to make those payments
immediately as soon as those claims are
validated so this will require that
change and and an amendment to the law
and on page two that that language is
being included and what this will do is
um
so by having a budget an amount that we
can use
anytime we need the payments
um this language really
um
clarifies that but also if there is a
need to to have to request more funds
because we really don't know how many
clients we're going to receive he makes
us go to to the regular process of going
to the fiscal committee and the governor
Council for additional funds
so uh moving on to the distribution to
municipalities the
activity for
the activity call relative to
distribution to municipalities so we
have the county unit that um
that includes the meals and runs and tax
distribution so during the last biennium
the funding and the formula for this
payments changed and so um we have an
increase
um
in those payments for this time around
based on that new formula
um
so the the payment says 30 of the gross
meals and room Stacks Revenue net of the
education trust fund portion and also
net of the DRS cost to administer this
this program so um this this this these
amounts are including uh two percent
revenue and expenditure growth and those
those assumptions were provided by the
um by dra the permanent Revenue
Administration
uh so that so so this this um
this famous to municipalities uh the
meal syndrome stack distribution for the
first time is being funded by a
dedicated fund and not uh General funds
uh so also in our budget we're including
the state of Revenue share this this um
this is
um this item remains on the book so we
have to include it in our budget but the
law has been suspended during the last
biennia so um
we included
um the funding and the prioritize needs
column
so I will move on to
um
the office of investment in the
management page 689 and so again this
includes activity for the annual office
and and and the expenses that
um we we project that we're going to
incur in that in in this in this
accounting unit but also as part of the
housekeeping that we did we're including
that service uh in this new accounting
um our activities our code
and so um on page
690 we have the debt service for that is
paid with General funds
and for this um
so that service has been has been
reaching over over time has been
decreasing and we have um
there's a large
variance or a decrease and between the
fiscal year 23 adjuster authorized and
the upcoming biennium and the reason for
that is we've had
um we had a refunding and first gear 21
and we achieved significant significant
savings then and those um those savings
were applied in fiscal year 21 and
fiscal year 22. and so with that our
debt structure also changed
um the other
um reason for the change is we also been
because Capital spending has been has
decreased we also been more or less so
with that our projections on the
previous and the prior biennium were
higher than
um
really what we ended up boring in issue
for once so for new access for so that's
for existing the efforts so for new um
for new uh debt uh for new bonds whereas
we are projecting that we send the
assumption that we will you that they
will issue about 16 million Indian
obligation bonds uh that will be paid
with General funds and another 10
million uh for the uh to fund the
projects of the University system of New
Hampshire
so the the reality of uh Eastern bonds
is the cost of borrowing is going to
increase so
um it is
when we put these assumptions together
um
I actually changed my assumptions a
couple of times but I went back to the
initial
um what we prepare in in the summer and
we feel comfortable these numbers are
going to be good numbers for that
service
um what's going to happen in the future
is unclear whether we have to obviously
we're going to pay higher blur on cost
um but one of the factors again what I
just mentioned is because of the
spending and we we issue bonds based on
spending
um you know perhaps we're gonna not
gonna see a large increase in our debt
service
another item that I just want to
highlight that is
um begin with fiscal year 22 a portion
of the debt service is going to be paid
with a dedicated fund
um that this is for the project this is
for the Rams project the
um for the Department of Revenue
Administration and again for fiscal year
20 to begin with fiscal year 22 that
principle and answers of those bonds
that were initially issued with General
funds are not going to be repaid with
the dedicated fund that was created for
that purpose so that's the revenue
information management system account
pursuant to 21j
and so our budget also includes that
service for school building Aid and that
service for the community college system
of New Hampshire
um the the Community College pays uh
their Debt Service and
um this could be building a on that
service is funded from the meals and
room stacks
so the last
um
the next so abandon the the next one is
the abandoned property uh division again
no significant changes in this project
except for the additional cost required
to move transition to the doit supported
and we also um
our plan is to abolish the I.T position
that is currently sitting in this
accounting unit
with regard to the college savings
commission we did a little bit of a
cleanup let's just renaming
um those on that activity code and this
activity code uh for the college savings
says the
um the work
um related to the college tuition
Savings Plan advisor commission they
oversee two um two different programs
the unique scholarship programs and the
governor scholarship program the unique
scholarship program is we use this
accounting unit to make those payments
for for the scholarships related to this
program and the funding comes from the
New Hampshire Excellency higher
education endowment trust fund
for the um for the governor scholarship
program
um
we are including the cost of this
this program and the prioritize needs
because during the last biennium
um there was no funding and and the
operating budget however House Bill 2
authorized uh six million dollars for a
six million appropriation for fiscal
year 21 and
um
but the commission as part of when they
approved these budgets
um they are they decided to request
additional 3 million for each fiscal
year the same way they did it during the
last biennium
and I just want to mention that we do
have a full-time position in this
accounting unit
so we also have the payments for the van
Thompson trust fund and those are
quarterly payments that we sent to the
university system we have the FI also
have the funding for the L2 program and
the Community Development Finance
Authority those are past programs housed
in our budget
and um
just quickly I'll I'll touch on the
restrictive Revenue we also prepared our
district the abandoned property
um is treatment revenue and so that
estimate is
um based on a 10-year average and we
included 19 million for secure 24 and 22
million fifth year 25. and the last item
I have is the interest on Surplus so we
did not include anything in this in this
line and the
and similar to Prior years we we did not
budget anything in the agency budget
um the interest on Surplus has been
relatively smaller the last couple of
years due to the interest rate
environment that's clearly changing and
um
we are expecting
good earnings in this current fiscal
year and upcoming biennium so we can
work on preparing an estimate that could
be included in the governor's budget
um so that should be uh right now we're
in a better position to provide that
estimate that we did in the summer
so that concludes my presentation I'll
be happy to answer any questions you may
have thank you
one question from me and that is in our
along or in our debt uh do we have well
what percentage of any do we have there
are variable rate component or uh
synthetic products like interest rate
swaps
we do not have any of that we don't have
variable rates we've been issuing
um debt with a fixed rate we pay
interest
we typically offer a five percent coupon
and that has produced a large premium of
the last few years so with the interest
rates changing we anticipate as
close to no premium
um end up coming biennium so that those
are the things that we need to see how
how they change but thinking thinking
about
um
um so we're going back to um you know a
situation we have prior to 2008 with the
ball run costs were higher so but we do
not ish we do not have any variables we
do not have variable rate that's a great
answer thank you
hi hi
um if I understand the way we do debt
and I don't so let me see if this is
right
um
we passed the capital budget
agencies are authorized to spend
theoretically that money
that money is theoretically is typically
spent over the course of the next two to
four years
you don't issue debt that corresponds to
that project let's just say for the sake
of argument we build a building for 10
million dollars
not a very big one
um
you issued that when the project is
closed
we issued debt based on spending because
of our the Arbitrage rules that we have
to we have to follow and we have to make
sure that we don't keep the proceeds for
too long and so what we do at what we do
is typically we borrow based on you know
we're about to issue Bonds in March so
we look at the spending for the fiscal
year and we see how much has been spent
and then we try to project for the rest
of the you know what we may see for
spend then and over the next six to
eight months or nine months so and
that's what we issue and so
um just to give an example in fiscal
year 21 we issued a very small amount of
numeric bonds it was about
39 million and I'm fiscal year and
that's all of it including so funded
that and fiscal year 22 we issued a
total about 59 million and again total
land that includes self-funded so about
70 of that is General pay with General
funds in and that's really how we how we
borrow how that's based on our product
that's how we borrow so if we
um I guess what I'm getting at is so you
would look at you know total Capital
spending on a company
30. thank you
um and um
but theoretically for example though you
know we passed 125 million dollar
whatever was capital budget and there's
a Slowdown on it during covid
it's not canceled it's just every
project is put on hold
and so
in normal times as if any time is normal
um
you know the the spending just kind of
rolls right and it and it's you know
there's a little bit of like this up and
down but with covet there's a and
there's a whole bunch of authorized
expenditures out there that haven't been
spent so they haven't been borrowed
that's correct so there's a so in theory
on some level there's a lag in debt
service and uh you know let's say for
the sake of argument that this year we
decided not to have a capital budget
this is not something I'm suggesting
um but I didn't write it down thank you
I appreciate that but let's say we you
know we skip a biennium where you know
we did 125 125 zero
we don't see the effect of we wouldn't
see the effect of the zero for a couple
years probably that's correct so there's
a lag so in normal times we will be
probably more consistent you know we
just borrow because the spending is
occurring so we just keep borrowing and
it's it's a pretty good um
um it just it's just organic it works
really well it is this very unusual
times that we're living that we're
saying
um we're seeing the impact so
um if I recall correctly during the
covet times the capital expenses were
Capital expenditures was this
um request to not spend
um
including Capital expenditures so that
that you know even though the budget was
authorized for 120 million 130 million
for the biennium the spending did not
occur so that's when things started and
then with the problems now with
inflation and Workforce so now that
spending is not happening so yes so
right now there is about 300 million in
authorized Indonesian bonds
oh okay and that's an and that's that
that's the I can see that number in the
bond statement every
it should be there but it will also be
in the ACT Fair okay oh that's right of
course of one
um
so the only other question I have is our
total General obligation debt as a state
peaked in
what six seven eight years ago
we've been in Decline for a while we
have been yes is it eight years sound
right
um we'll have to look at my chart but
probably yes so it's been it's been
trending down for some time now and you
know in in total too just because
Turnpike is not issuing anything they
just refunded some bonds so they're and
they don't have plans to to reach any
new debt
um again the general fund has a specific
Trend because of what we just discussed
um and again in general is just
stranding down
great okay thank you
this is a smaller in dollars in
comparison to some of the discussion but
I was just looking at your comment about
the rims project and I believe that the
the way that this the law the statute
had read was that there's
um the funding is coming from sort of
savings from the rims project and I feel
like there's a cap I don't maybe three
million I don't remember if that's
annually or over its life but once if
there are no savings does the general
fund sort of pay that that Debt Service
the capital budget says that it needs to
be paid with that dedicated fund so I
think the language and the dedicated
fund talks about that cap the 4 million
but the capital budget is very specific
that beginning with fiscal year 22 that
those bonds need to be paid from that
dedicated account so there isn't
language currently that um
for that funding to come from elsewhere
so that's very specific to that room
very specific in the Corporal budget and
so for our purposes we will so before it
was General funded now we need to really
remove it from that bucket and put in
that self-funded bucket okay
um and then this is more uh just a
different question is on the
scholarship fund you said it was a house
bill 2 that was passed that included 6
million I guess retro to 21 and then
that's been sort of carrying over do you
know what the balance is in that right
now
we have about 10 million in that okay
balance but it's also because of the way
the scholarships and this is the
government scholarship program so this
is because of the way how those how
those how that program works it issues
grants
um
the schools issue grants
um each year but they have four years to
spend the money and so this program
started in 2018 and so we have a large
available balance because of that reason
I don't have the um the numbers in front
of me what was your prioritized needs
request
three million for each fiscal year for
that program okay and that has that's
what was requested in the past okay
and so with all of that if we don't
include um excluding the uh Revenue
sharing we were way under that you know
fun targets okay
okay thank you
thank you very much thank you
Landing Community Heritage investment
program elkship is up next for your
testimony please
good morning thanks Bert I feel a little
bit like a palette cleanser we're a nice
small little program we use no General
funds
um but I am very happy to be here to
speak with you today my name is Paula
Belmore I'm the executive director of
The Landing Community Heritage
investment program known to locals as
l-chip we are an independent state
Authority that was created in 2000 and
charged with ensuring that the state's
most important natural cultural and
historic resources forever contribute to
our economy and quality of life
when l-chip was first conceived and
designed it was considered to operate in
the New Hampshire way meaning we are
Community Based we are a voluntary
initiative and we support public private
Partnerships we do this by awarding
matching grants to communities or
non-profit organizations who are seeking
to advance their local projects in land
conservation and historic rehabilitation
the grants we provide help these groups
protect forests and Farms wildlife and
water they help reintegrate historic
buildings into community life they help
preserve covered bridges and iconic view
sheds and they help to protect Clean
safe drinking water
El chip has supported projects in 195
communities across the state and we're
working hard to hit every single one
we're almost there we've invested 58
million dollars since 2001 protecting
236 000 Acres directly
324 buildings have been rehabilitated
and as I said 195 towns so it's roughly
350 Community groups have benefited from
a nail chip Grant
um for the purposes of today's meeting
out of respect for your time I could go
on and tell you all about different
projects but I will um focus mostly on
our budget request l-chips funding for
Grants
um is
generated by a 25 surcharge that is
assessed at the county Registries of
Deeds when documents are recorded of the
25 surcharge one dollar is retained by
the county and the other 24 is deposited
into an account held and maintained by
the Department of Treasury
I am enormously proud that nearly 96 of
the funding that is generated by that
surcharge goes directly back to
communities in the form of Grants or is
invested in our community conservation
endowment which supports annual
monitoring right now of close to 400
properties that received LG funding in
the past
the small remainder is allocated to
program Administration
l-chip is an impressively lean and
efficient machine that's something I'm
very very proud of we have only four
full-time employees and two seasonal
part-time employees
in order to maintain that low Staffing
level in fiscal year 22 we did something
I think you're hearing a lot about in
these hearings which is we launched a
new Grant management system which allows
online
processing of applications evaluation
and management of funded projects this
has been received with rave reviews but
more importantly has dramatically
increased staff productivity eliminating
the need for us to add a position we
thought we were going to need to add in
the next fiscal year we're hopeful as we
move out of the implementation phase
with this project that that only will
continue
so to summarize if I have one takeaway
I'd like you to have for my presentation
it is that each investment l-chip makes
in a town or community group supports
local jobs enhances the local tax base
promotes tourism preserves traditional
craftsmanship and help those jobs to
maintained and improves the quality of
life for the folks who live and visit
here all without the use of General
funds
for the reason we are requesting the
l-chip appropriation be set at 5 million
as it has for the past two biennia and I
thank you for your time and happy to
answer any questions about the program
okay thank you
um I want to commend you for the job you
do and uh I grew up in Massachusetts but
every two weeks of every August would go
up to New Hampshire for vacation with
the family and I think it's for lack of
a better word where it's really cool
that I can now take my son and give him
the same experience I had as a kid
because that's not true for many parts
of this country so so thank you
um my only question really is what what
challenges do you face is it is it the
need for development or or maybe even
your own words what what are your
challenges as a program the biggest
challenge we face is one that many
resource agencies face which is that we
on behalf of the state do take a
protective interest in properties that
we fund which means we have an ongoing
and often Perpetual obligation to
oversee those annual monitoring and
enforcement of conservation of
preservation restrictions is complicated
and it can be expensive so that's that's
what I'm looking at in next five years
is the biggest challenge El Chapo faced
and we're working with doj with cord
with the conservation land stewardship
program in division of historical
resources to find a way to very
effectively but also efficiently and
consistently Implement those types of
restrictions across not just l-chip but
the other agencies that are also doing
similar work like Des or dncr fishing
game so that's I would say that is our
our number one challenge in terms of our
grant recipients they are extremely
challenged by Staffing it is difficult
to to find the people to run the
projects so towns are working with
volunteers a lot of the community groups
we work with are all volunteers so we're
finding we need to offer more technical
assistance these can be very complicated
real estate transactions or you know
rehabilitating the Colonial Theater in
Laconia for example some of these
projects are quite complicated and so
the um the professional capacity issues
can be challenging thank you
my only question is about the five
million appropriation if that
and that's based on how much how many
Deeds we expect to be filed right where
Deeds plans mortgage mortgage surcharges
and yeah yeah
um if it if they don't come in right
there's a general fund make up the
difference or do you get less so I from
a technical perspective I can't answer
that what I can tell you is we have
never we have never exceeded we only
award the funds based on receipts that
come in
um and so we typically we we don't give
you
more than comes in right okay if you go
way back to when the surcharge was first
created in 2009
um The Chipettes warding funds in
December there was some forecasting of
future Revenue so we're rewarding a
little ahead as the market grew we're
tied to number of transactions so as the
market grew over the past few years
um we cut that amount that we had
already awarded that hadn't returned so
now we've gotten ourselves to zero so
now because we're in a falling Market we
certainly don't want to be
right so now we're at zero so now we
award cash in hand
great thank you
thank you very much
uh the community develop Finance
Authority
I would invite representatives from them
to come up and give the testimony thank
you
[Music]
good morning good morning thank you for
having me I'm Katie easterly Marte and
I'm with the Community Development
Finance Authority cdfa somewhat similar
to l-chip is a unique entity we work in
partnership with state and federal
initiatives to strengthen New
Hampshire's communities through the
distribution of resources to
municipalities non-profits and
businesses I'm here to request continued
match funding from the state of New
Hampshire the request of 260 000 in
state fiscal year 2024 and 280 000 in
state fiscal year 2025. this represents
the federal match requirement of State
funds towards program administration of
New Hampshire's annual allocation of the
federal block grant resources which is
the Community Development block grant
cdbg
is critical that the state Economic
Development strategies including the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs economic recovery and expansion
strategy and the Council on housing
stabilities three-year strategic plan
cdbg Investments focus on four
significant areas that impact businesses
and people that includes housing child
care support for small businesses and
local infrastructure
we are focused on administering a
program that creates the greatest
possible Community Driven impacts and
adapts to the needs of New Hampshire's
communities between January 1st 2020 and
January June 30th 2022 New Hampshire
cdbg program assisted nearly 15 500
people through Public Services
public facility and public facility
improvements
created or retained 76 jobs
rehabilitated to preserve 605 housing
units and provided technical assistance
to nearly 900 small businesses I'd love
to provide just a couple of examples of
how that touches down in communities
Public Service funds were provided to
the sunshine soup kitchen they were
awarded sixty thousand dollars and that
was during the pandemic particularly
because they lost the volunteers that
were so critical for their food
distribution
they to date with these funds have sort
of served
9811 seniors adults and children 908 and
812 meals they've also given out
blizzard bags and breakfast bags which
are essential to people in storms and
other disasters
they said to us recently that receiving
this grant helped their organization get
through the last two years and keep
their doors open allowing them to really
adapt their programs and and continue to
serve people in their community
you'll also see in the materials that I
handed an example which is the 100 night
shelter in Keene this shelter previously
had a very inadequate number of
transitional and and
um
evening housing units so it's a both
emergency shelter as well as
transitional housing they needed to
rebuild their facility because it was
not safe and cdb Gene funds were
invested to help with that rebuilding
in addition you'll see Mid-State Health
Mid-State Health Center had previously
had a child care center which helped
them to retain employees and also
provide really necessary community-based
child care to people that they serve
they served about 16 families in their
child care facility which is in the
basement of a church the church needed
that space and so they came to the block
grant program to provide the grant
funding that allowed them to leverage
other resources and build a 60 student
Child Care Center that's in a former
Sears building in Plymouth this not only
allows them to retain employees but it's
also provided a much greater need to
families across the region
and then finally The Business technical
assistance so those nearly 700
businesses that were served over the
last year when they come for Business
technical assistance which is supported
by the cdbg program they have to be low
income so the business owner themselves
has to have very low income after three
years of assistance which is the maximum
amount available we did a survey and
nearly 95 percent of those businesses
that were receiving that technical
assistance were no longer low income so
they had with this technical assistance
actually grown uh the wages that they
could receive from their business and
been able to in many cases employ others
in their community
so we really see that these Investments
over the last 20 years
um
help communities cdfa provides this
Administration into exceptionally cost
efficient system for the State of New
Hampshire all eligible New Hampshire
municipalities and Counties have the
opportunity to access the total of 1.5
million dollars annually
they can use those resources to support
affordable housing public facility
improvements and economic development
projects in addition there's emergency
resources and planning resources to help
communities to meet those needs the
projects that are awarded are Community
Driven they're driven by local leaders
and community members that say they're
necessary in their municipality
we administer a competitive grant
program that's how the the awards are
made our staff conducts extensive
programmatic and the financial review of
each application in addition projects
that meet all necessary criteria are
invoted on by an independent 11-member
Community Development advisory committee
and finally then brought to our board of
directors our board of directors is
appointed by the governor and approved
by the governor and Council
federal funds come with significant
requirements to ensure these projects
are successful cdfa's professional staff
provide technical assistance and
training to grantees throughout each
phase of the project we also provide
assistance through implementation both
through direct technical assistance
training and access to significant
resources on our grants management
system we work closely with Partners to
find Creative Solutions and offer
guidance to project development as well
as to ease the burden of compliance
protect the investment of these taxpayer
funds as you can imagine these
communities range from communities that
have professional staff that help them
to apply for and Advance these projects
along with the project Administration
that's provided by cdfa funds and then
also communities that have a part-time
person who's taking on many roles they
can often be the welfare director as
well as putting in these Community
Development blocker and applications and
we really want to assist all communities
with these resources and ensure that
their distributed attributed across the
state
it's no it's worth noting that the
carries act as state of New Hampshire
was allocated an additional 14.3 million
dollars to be deployed by cdsa to
respond to the covid-19 pandemic These
funds were used specifically for the
prevention of the preparation for and
the response to coven 19. these
additional resources we did a few things
we developed that public service program
which the Sunshine Food Pantry was a
part of and we also made it necessary
public facility improvements to air
quality in things like Child Care
Facilities community centers food
pantries and homeless shelters
cares act resources were administered by
cdfa
and we have expended them in a very
efficient way maybe that's actually one
of the the first states in the country
to meet Our obligation deadline
cdfa's request is an increase from prior
budget years and will enable cdfa to
best meet the needs of New Hampshire's
communities meeting those increased
needs for technical assistance and
training and providing leverage
resources to this Federal program and
covering the cost of the project
Administration meeting that minimum
State match requirement the requested
support will ensure New Hampshire has
continued access to millions of federal
dollars that are meeting the needs of
critical Economic Development projects
across the state the U.S Department of
Housing and Urban Development also known
as HUD uses a formula to allocate its
resources we anticipate that New
Hampshire's total cdbg allocation will
be nearly 21 million dollars over the
next biennium
cdfa respectfully requests the state of
New Hampshire continue to provide the
federally required match funding
totaling 540 thousand dollars for the
2024-2025 state fiscal years your
support ensures the continued deployment
of nearly 20 million one million dollars
of resources thank you for considering
our request and I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you
between
being responsible for help providing
housing and child care you probably uh
don't have much else to do do you
uh my question really goes around the
federal reporting
um I realize that is very burdensome and
for other agencies that have or
departments that have had to that have
to do that
um you know they've run into problems
and need additional staff and it takes
long hours in overtime are you properly
situated to be able to to continue to
meet the federal reporting requirements
yes yep so we've made continued
investment in our staff and our systems
to be sure that we're sort of catching
up with staying
um
staying up to the requirements we do
have some additional requirements this
year a specific HUD requirement called
section three which is quite
unapplicable to New Hampshire but it's
something we actually have to have our
grantees understand for Port toss and we
have to report but we're constantly
really
staying on top of what will be upcoming
in terms of additional reporting and
ensuring that we're building that into
our training and our systems and that we
have staff capacity to do so okay do you
have any unfront not on front but have
any vacant funded positions currently we
have a planned position that our
director of Economic Development who's
retiring who are planning to hire and
we're hiring another position but
they're but they're both anticipated
okay great thank you yeah
uh the only thing I want to say is that
less people think that we um
give half a million dollars uh by the
way half a million dollars which is
matched 42-1 or something like that
which isn't bad
um unless anybody think we just pass out
and hope for the best from from uncdbg I
would just note for people watching at
home
um
like you're more disappointed by the
government Council uh and the advisory
committee I think has at least a handful
of State officials or gubernatorial
appointees on it so that there's a lot
of oversight yeah it has both Municipal
and state officials
um and they are all also appointed by
the governor and Council
um thank you for that question and we
also provided today and is available on
our website an annual report which
specifically speaks to each of the
Investments that are made each each year
with the cdbg funds and other resources
each of the cdbg
allocations the recommendations actually
from the cdac and then the board of
directors also have to go to the
governor and Council for approval so
there to to your question there's
significant oversight to these resources
so we want to ensure that they can be
widely access access by communities who
really need them and then that we really
are meeting those obligations on the
federal side and there is a great level
of uh input and oversight to the funding
I I have a vague recollection and it's
vague so
um at one point cdfa employees or state
employees then they transitioned and
probably and so there are probably
people a little bit like at peas who
were in a transition period you don't
have anybody left like that do you we do
so our longest tenured employee 17 years
with the organization is is retiring in
the next number of years that's the
position that we are recruiting for
currently because we'll have a nice
training overlap there he's the last
person that was previously a state
employee so we're almost there yeah
great thank you very much thank you
appreciate your testimony
Department of Information Technology
invite you to come up and give your
testimony
it is still morning good morning
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee
um
my name is Dennis Goulet I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Information Technology also known as
doit
ing me today is Ken Dunn Deputy
Commissioner of doit Rose Curry Director
of Finance and Megan Weber business
administrator in our finance Bureau
the department of Information Technology
in New Hampshire is a centralized
organization that's responsible for the
I.T function of the executive branch of
government in New Hampshire we're
somewhat unique in the country and in
the states and territories in that we've
been centralized fully centralized for
over a decade
uh my peers around the country many of
them are still focused on that
centralization effort in their states
and their territories so it's it's a
real Advantage for New Hampshire for us
to be in this position
our responsibilities are outlined in RSA
21r
um this budget is a collaborative effort
between the folks in doit both in our
centralized organization as well as in
the agencies as well as agency agency
personnel and of course the governor's
budget director giving advice along the
way
I'm going to go through I've you've got
a pretty lengthy presentation here don't
worry I'm not gonna I'm not going to
take you through every detail here but
we thought we have a reasonably complex
budget we thought it important to supply
this amount of transparency so for your
analysis
uh moving to page two uh we feel it's
important to have a strategic plan
um the uh the Strategic themes in our
plan are there in that graphic
um and uh the uh all of them are very
important all of those themes are
important we don't weigh one more
importantly than the other but recently
the effective Resource Management
category has really risen to the top for
us in that you know with the challenges
we're seeing on the workforce side using
technology to make these the folks that
we can recruit and retain more effective
is really important so a lot of focus
and you'll see that reflected in our
APNs today
moving on to page three in the major
program change space
um without going through those first
three paragraphs the the net of that
there is expectations for us to improve
uh productivity and access to data
um that came about during covet have not
diminished they've increased and so
we're we're focused on
um you know delivering what's expected
of us in that area
moving on to cyber security
criminals and foreign actors continue to
increase their capabilities
that puts us in a position of adapting
almost on a weekly basis to new things
that we're learning in the market and
that has implications on the budget
which which we we continue to adapt to
moving on to page four there's a lot of
detail in this in the cyberspace but
what I want to want you to to know is
that we're focused on external self-eval
external independent evaluation of our
capabilities so that we don't miss
things and continually adapting
why is that so important that over the
past five years or so the uh cyber
threat landscape has
um transitioned from a a theoretical
threat
um you know to uh existential threats so
with the Advent of ransomware where you
see in organizations completely taken
out of business and you've seen uh the
impact of disinformation on the
operation of government both in the
state and the federal level so that that
focus is really important for us
moving on to page five again I will
emphasize that the uh the operating
budget was established collaboratively
we try to communicate as much as
possible with agencies we're not perfect
at it and sometimes we have misses and
we'll be I'm sure we'll be talking to
the governor's budget director about you
know those areas where we we have to
work on as we go forward but it is our
intent to be fully transparent to you
and to the agencies as we develop the
process
uh moving to the bottom half of page
five these these what I call Cost
drivers are really important I'm going
to go through each one really quickly
agencies are increasing their technology
density they they were before covet it's
accelerated and you'll you see that in
reflected in the APNs
um these resource needs in the second
major bullet
are increasing for a couple reasons one
is there's new skills required to to
implement a lot of these new
technologies and and additionally
um the uh the types of skills are ones
that were less effective at of
recruiting into state government because
the wage inflation in those spaces has
accelerated faster than the overall I.T
wage inflation
in the in the General market
there's always some shift of from
one-time expense to operating expense
you'll see that reflected in the APNs
the hardware and software vendors are
now shifting away from the old school uh
Capital intensive way of funding
projects to a more operating expensive
tense intensive that that's good for
them in the sense that they have a
they're able to be predictable on their
financials as a company it's it's good
for us in the long run because it makes
us more transparent I.E we're reflecting
what the actual spend is on an annual
basis versus not but there's an
adjustment period during that and we're
in that adjustment period so you see you
know instead of seeing the big Capital
expense bump and then a you know a
relatively low operating expense you
might see a higher operating expense for
some of these items over time
um we're seeing pretty large
inflation in the technology space for
acquisition and life cycle of products
is shortening going back to the cyber
security threats
um the fact that the threat landscape is
changing more quickly our vendors have
to change more quickly to protect data
and and that is driving uh shortened
life cycles
Page Six
the very top of the page we we look at
additional prioritized needs in three
different areas the first is what we
call the you know one-time funding that
is now generating
um operating expense and in the future
we'll probably add arpa funding to that
although we're trying to be really
careful not to you know do too much arpa
funding that's generating that's going
to generate long-term operating expense
after the period of the the grant
um the second type is structural or uh
changes and we're seeing a lot of those
because the inflation's driving you know
contracts up
um and then in the third category those
are the initiatives that are truly new
uh that they didn't have any previous
impact on budgets
um our accounting units are reflected in
that table I'm going to go through them
quickly there's more detail in the
presentation that we'll get to
now the first one is a bunch of
different accounting units that are rep
represent our direct agency budget
that's for things that are agency
specific
and so an agency's
um direct budget is stuff for just them
and them only
um Central I.T Services is for stuff
that's shared across the executive
branch and those costs are allocated out
to the agencies based on a formula
yeah you usually the formula is is
aligned to something that we think is
common sense like uh usages if it's an
application it's usage of that
application by the by agencies one
example is licensing where oplc has the
Lion's Share of the licensing so for
that that shared application they use
they are actually build the Lion's Share
of the cost for that application
I.T salaries and benefits this is
actually the staff the state workers who
support executive branch agencies
roughly half of them are dedicated
directly to an agency and actually in
most cases sit inside that agency and
then the other half is shared resources
like myself and and the folks here today
we are our cost to the shared costs are
allocated via a formula for that as well
and then finally Statewide
telecommunications which is a dedicated
fund a non-lapsing fund which does
telecommunications functions for the for
the executive branch
without going into too much detail it's
really around on connectivity of all of
our remote sites we have over 400 remote
sites that we connect to what I call the
mothership which is the central data
center in Concord and additionally for
uh the phones that might be on your desk
and though that that funds is designed
around the the premise of keeping a flat
expense rate year over year and
accumulating enough to not go back to
the agencies during you know the every
fifth or sixth year when we have to buy
stuff so we over collect just enough
to make sure that we're buying that
centralized equipment that we need so so
that we're not
um you know having a bumpy expense curve
is what I call it
um
so when you look at the um the totals
there um you can see that there's a very
significant amount of additional
prioritized needs uh relative compared
to previous budgets and we'll take you
through those details as we go
um let's move on to page seven if we
could
um without going into any detail here um
that the main point of this is you can
see the breakdowns by class line there's
no no drama there at all it's pretty
straightforward and the efficiency
targets have essentially been met
page eight
um top of the page that table
goes over additional prioritized needs
by category
um and and it it shows the percent
contribution from the various categories
fairly small on Telecom
the I.T salaries and benefits has an
impact there Central Services relates
back to that efficiency of or
effectiveness of employees and we'll
talk more about that and then the agency
direct is the Lion's Share of the
additional prioritized needs and there
is a appendix that's that goes with this
presentation attachment a has a full
detail of all the agency additional
prioritized needs it describes so I
encourage you to read every line of that
the um moving down to
the second table on page eight that
really details out these additional
prioritized needs by classline so you
can really see where the impacts are
software and Consultants so that's
really the big the big item there and
again
you can see the total um
let's go on to page nine now and we'll
start to get a little more detail on
these accounting units on the direct
accounting units as I described before
those are agency specific
um you see that there's almost 18
million dollars of additional
prioritized needs there out of a total
of 20 about 24 so pretty significant
contribution there and that's stuff that
the agencies themselves prioritized for
for consideration in the in the budget
process
we like to do a little bit of analysis
of on on things and when we look at the
direct budget you can see on the the
second table that
um you know over 92 percent of the
agency efficiency budget is represented
by six agencies so you can kind of get a
sense for the impact there and then then
there's a whole bunch of other agencies
that that are the remaining eight
percent and then moving on to page 10
we can see that there are five agencies
that are accounting for the Lion's Share
of 90 of the agency additional
prioritized needs
moving on to page 11 we will look at
Central Services and operations again
the efficiency budget hit targets a
little under actually uh there were some
structural things there you you would
notice that in the in the agency budget
it was a little the efficiency looked a
little higher
this one looks a little lower because we
actually moved
um some money from one category to the
other so the net was really this there's
no impact that's why we're stating even
though you might have seen in the agency
direct us a little high in the shared
services a little low from a from agency
efficiency perspective but really if you
net that out it's it's right there and
you can see that in the total
um
so the agency additional prioritized
needs again are significant relative to
the efficiency requests and we'll we'll
talk a little bit more about those on
page 12.
um I want to call attention to the first
four items on there there's there's
quite a few items as you can see
um the first four really focused on
those the areas I was talking about
earlier which is the what we found is a
you know the implementation of new
software during covet and now in an
ongoing basis has really had an impact
on effectiveness of existing employees
that were able to recruit and retain and
there's the fact that agencies are
seeing this has created a real strong
desire to keep going on that to continue
to invest in that space so I would look
at those Investments as investments in
continuing to make help the existing
employees
in the executive branch more effective
in their jobs as we go forward
the others there's a whole bunch of
detail there I could go through each one
of them but I'm not going to because I
know I'm between you and lunch but if
anybody has any questions you know after
we terminate the presentation I'd be
happy to answer details on any one of
those I actually have a pretty good idea
of what they all are
moving on to page 13 salaries and
benefits again pretty straightforward
there's some there's some
notable additional prioritized needs
there which I'm going to take you
through but I want to call attention to
the bottom proposed House Bill 2
language
in 21r today my four appointed directors
are kind of generic in there and so
we're addressing that by we are
requesting that we specifically name
those those functions it puts having
them generic gives us more flexibility
and but having them named is easier to
administer because when if we're asking
to nominate somebody for example the
administrative services and the
executive Council and and anybody can
kind of see where that's pointed so
we'll basically should we change the
name or function of these divisions in
the future we would have to come back on
a biennial budget cycle and change them
or even on an annual legislative cycle
through through
proposed legislation
moving on to page 14
um talking about the what drove the
additional prioritized needs related to
salaries and benefits and there's a
there's a few areas there I'll go
through really quickly
there's two what I call Strategic 7D
positions that is the chief what I'm
calling the Chief privacy officer
function kind of a big deal for New
Hampshire what we're seeing is at this
date I believe there are seven states
that have Chief priority uh privacy
officers it's growing number and
um and the reason is uh you know privacy
uh is becoming an issue internationally
and nationally
as well as in the state of New Hampshire
and we don't have a function that
manages that in a coordinated way so
when when something comes up for example
from a cyber security perspective
whether it's in the legislature or an
inquiry we have a function we have a
strategic plan we have policies all of
that in place that people can look at
and they can evaluate whether it's good
or not we don't have that for New
Hampshire so it's always a a question
when we're talking about privacy whether
it's it's in legislation proposed
legislation or whether it's in inquiry
so I think that's important for New
Hampshire to do this now it's in as a
shared proposal here in shared budget
but from a purity perspective I would I
would prefer that it show up as a a
general funded non-aligned I.E not paid
for by agencies because what we would
want to do is should these two positions
get funded we would also want companion
legislation that gets added in to 21r
that establishes the uh the duties and
authority of the Chief privacy officer
function
looking at the some of these other I'll
just jump to liquor those are two 7ds
that were um that liquor asked for to
help out with their um their new finance
and point of sale system and there's a
number of others you heard Monica talk
about the treasury part-time
safety Revenue both have some
requirements there that they want and
the details in the additional
prioritized needs list and um HHS is
kind of self-explanatory the the
ones on the bottom the three positions
on the bottom were really focused on
there's a LBA audit finding that was
around the kind of the fairness of the
I.T lead function or the distribution of
it leads we've been slowly uh biennium
after biennium trying to chip away at
that to make you know the allocation of
resources more more fair and Equitable
across the way we you know if we either
try to fix it all at once it would have
been too big of an impact so we're
asking for consideration on that
um and then finally at the bottom of
this page we have uh House Bill 2
language this language was in is in this
biennium
um it's really helpful for our
Effectiveness because what what
basically what it says is where you know
we can't over expend our our
appropriation obviously but what we
could do is of those I believe it's
seven unfunded positions say somebody
leaves and we see an unfunded position
that's more appropriate for what the
challenges are of the state at that time
we could fund that one and unfund the
other one and and not and not as long as
we don't go over the appropriation
um
we're not likely to go over the
appropriation given the vacancy rate
we're running so it's it's not a
challenge there
um and and I think we're at uh was it
12.7 right now I think percent yeah so
we were relatively no low compared to
some but still higher than historical
for us
um so moving on to page 15 this is just
not going to say anything other than
these are adjustments that were
requested since we've initially
submitted the budget
page 16 is an org chart where you can
see how the the author uh proposed
authorized positions would be
distributed in our organization and
you'll see the the bottom
um we didn't want to be presumptuous so
the bottom um boxes are the appointed
appointed individuals that we mentioned
earlier but we're keeping the old names
that they currently have now and that we
would change the org chart if the if the
house bill 2 language were to be signed
into law
and then finally on page 17 Statewide
telecommunications again this is this is
um primarily we over collect
to fund the purchase of core Network
equipment every five to six years
we we over collect a little bit to fund
the staff that supports those 400 plus
remote locations connectivity back to
the Mothership and other network
functions inside the state and the last
time we went before the Joint Committee
for dedicated funds we were able to show
that we were almost exactly collecting
what we needed to keep that running so
we're doing a d I think we're doing a
decent job of not over collecting which
is always a concern with a dedicated
fund that concludes my formal testimony
and I'm ready for questions
thank you very much
I know
um recruiting new employees has been
been difficult uh I don't know if you
could if you have it off the top of your
head what your vacancy rate is
12.7 right now
how difficult has it been to find
Consultants
Consultants or state employees okay
Consultants Consultants um well when we
talk about wages
given an unlimited budget it's probably
easy but given the constraints you have
so Consultants well it's really an
interesting phenomenon because all
entities
in in the country or having trouble
recruiting technical Talent so every all
states all private sector are competing
for the same set of Consulting resources
so what has that done it's driven the
cost up very significantly it's also
driven in the availability down of
certain particularly high demand
resources most particularly cyber
security and some of the major platforms
that are that are expanding quickly in
around the world like salesforce.com and
Microsoft Dynamics 365 and we have both
those platforms in our state
okay
uh most change with state government
moves sort of at glacial speeds I mean
change does not come quickly to state
government I think that really changed
dramatically with with the covet
pandemic
and now we we don't do business the way
we used to I think from a budgetary
standpoint what I would hope would be
that was a blip that we had expenses
coming in for the fear you know for a
few years and now we can go more to the
the old Baseline that doesn't seem to be
the case it seems that that the current
for a variety of reasons including
people liking working at home for both
recruiting of of employees and other
reasons uh that that's that's the case
um do you agree with that that we now
had a new Baseline and
do you have sort of a back of the
envelope
projection is what covet cost us because
most people think working from home is
is a cost saving measure and that's true
for many years but not I.T because you
have to provide not only the the laptops
but the cameras the microphones the
security to
secure all those and that seems to be
like it's that's going forward well yeah
really good really good question
um so the so the impacts of the telework
uh or I call the DS diaspora of uh I was
just State offices and then back into it
to a great extent that that's reflected
in the budget we're now in so you don't
see any of that in the uh you know
that's sitting in the efficiency budget
now for this this efficiency budget what
what you're seeing is I believe is this
you know a couple of things one from an
agency perspective there's a lot of
pretty old applications out there that
need to be modernized and so that's
driving things and then there's that
need to get things done with fewer
employees and so you're seeing that both
in this budget as well as you know some
of the requests the Harper requests that
have been that have been funded in in
the state that we're that we're
operationalizing now so I think the big
thing really is
the impacts we're seeing on from a large
perspective are the impacts of of that
shifting to an operating expense model
from a capital model for just about
everything we buy and
um and also the the huge demand for
technology to help survive the fact that
every agency has fewer people but the
job they need to get done is the same
job from a citizen service perspective
and just one one last question for me is
uh through the The Sweep
program and uh given the
uh lack of resources we have on the the
employee side not being able to recruit
sufficient number of employees
it's often thought that technology can
help supplement that uh
how do you think New Hampshire does as
far as utilizing technology to uh
supplement the lack of Workforce that we
currently are experiencing and what can
we do better
to make sure that happens well well it
it really varies by agency
um and it goes to I think it goes
largely to agency culture and their
ability to understand what I call the
business value of I.T because technology
is not worth anything unless unless you
understand how to leverage it for
business value so
um and I'm seeing you know overall I've
been here I'm thinking around seven and
a half years I've seen a huge
Improvement overall in in every agency
there's always room to improve and I
think what we continue to do is
um keep working on our agency
um so our we talked about our overall
strategic plan we have Agency
information technology plans which are
really the agency strategic plans those
should align with their their business
values and then we should focus on it
and on proper execution
um you know so there's some really good
examples of projects where that was done
over the past three to five years and
that have have generated those
efficiencies and that Effectiveness that
that we've needed and one of them is is
right there is reflected in this
efficiency budget which is the move over
to the Microsoft 365 platform which
created some pretty large Effectiveness
increases
um
we're continuing to look at that and
that's where the blind share of the APNs
are for for doit the non-personnel-based
APNs are for to continue that
um so I'd say we're getting better but
we've still got a ways to go and one of
my our focuses has been lately is to
look at and I think the sweet project
did a great job of helping people think
of that is you know can you legitimately
improve productivity or or even you know
in some cases survive right and we were
looking at a couple of those they were
about okay how can we keep this running
and using technology and I think we did
made the governors uh made some smart
decisions on what got funded there so
and and now we're we're focused on
operationalizing all of those with the
the same staff we had before those were
approved so a little challenge there but
we'll make it happen
hey hi
um I have a couple of I want to I want
to play off of that and I
from a technology standpoint it seems to
me the biggest thing is that
in your five-year replacement plan for
laptops let's say or for for desktops
for PCs
um you buy laptops instead of desktops
and that seems to me like that's ninety
percent of the uh
ninety percent of the cost of telework
right is just making sure everybody's
got a laptop
um and I say that as an agency where we
didn't have a lot of laptops and which
kind of heard us during covet a little
bit I'm like can I take a monitor home
yes you can during covet and then people
are now like how come I can't take our
monitor home I'm like it's not a state
of emergency anymore
that's not how we're doing things
anymore
you can take a laptop home to some of
that
um
their efficiency gains and losses I
think maybe
um I wonder if you could talk about this
I from this couple standpoints right and
let me use two points of reference one
is this hearing
um
so I'm old enough to remember when these
were kind of a big deal
like people actually came to these
hearings and I look around the room and
there's like you know there's perhaps
one reporter and one lobbyist in the
room not not singling anybody out
there you go and and you know the
governor talked uh at the opening
session and you know back in the day
this room wouldn't fit this would be a
ridiculous room to have this hearing in
because there'd be 80 90 people filling
the room and uh you know and I'm you
know I'm remembering like the when there
were two right the outgoing governor and
the incoming Governor which always a
little bit different too but uh nowadays
you know I ran into somebody and who I
thought was showing up to listen to me
give my presentation
um which annoyed me and I'm like look
you're only coming for mine he goes no
I'm not even coming for yours I'm
grabbing a handout and I'm watching the
whole thing online and I get occasional
texts from somebody who said did he just
say and that kind of thing and so I
think that's probably a productivity
game where I don't have to go find
parking get to the state house and
figure out how to get there I can just
tune in to like oh I'm gonna listen to
doit because I'm really interested in
that and I'm gonna not pay any attention
to you know Das let's say
um and then the team's phenomenon and I
you may notice about me that I the test
more than life itself uh teams meetings
um and like I literally I don't respond
to teams chat because I I don't think
that's a real communication and I don't
um and I try and have to have teams
meetings because I because you're not
listening to me when I'm talking to you
on teams I can tell that you're
completely distracted by the by the
puppy are you looking at me when you say
that I'm not but
um on the other hand for some people
they're very efficient right people who
are who are
um
less luggite let's say than I am and and
so those meanings are both
kind of okay except nobody feels any
you know I if I accepted every meeting
invite I'd be booked for 72 hours a week
and uh because they're like well it's
just a teams meeting I'm gonna invite
him and you don't know what to do
anymore was if I was going to make you
drive across town I'd be like well I'm
not don't know if we really need to have
a meeting so how do you balance so I
think it efficiency well I'll start with
the I'll I'll start like kind of in the
ease and work my way out on layers of
abstraction on that but you know when
you talk about your laptop versus
desktop thing it's really interesting
because
um you know I think this is would be
probably more impactful for
non-classified employees but I was
surprised many many years ago in the
private sector when you know they most
of the companies I worked for we didn't
buy desktops you know we there was this
transition in the private sector the
laptops and the reason they did that is
because
figured out you're going to get a lot
more work out of people
by virtue of that because there's so
many different places where they're able
to provide to do work and this thing
comes with me everywhere and I do work
everywhere just about and
so there's that but you know there is a
cost thing and and again it's about you
know who are the people what's the job
functions you know is it is it conducive
to having productivity
actually
happen in a telework context and I think
the industry is a little different too
so for doit and now I'm going to blow up
a layer of abstraction
the you know there's a trade-off between
you know what you what you call
efficiency so if I I get my all doit
meetings on teams they are I don't have
to drag people across the city and bring
them into an auditorium and you know
waste that you know 30 minutes on either
end of of doing that that's a that's a
huge huge Improvement for the state
um and and actually because I T people
are Geeks they like it better because
they can they get you know those
difficult questions you always want to
ask the commissioner but you might not
dare to well they actually dare to on
chat sometimes when they wouldn't stand
up in the middle of a crowd and do it so
I think there's a an improvement there
but but what I feel with telework and is
is that there's a loss of culture
potentially if you're not careful right
because you're not getting together with
each other
you're not spending time you know
talking at the water cooler hopefully
good things
um you know that kind of stuff so and I
I personally believe that you know human
nature is
sway swings right so we swung
particularly in the tech sector over to
you know all telework and then that was
the employee's expectation coming out of
covid the state of emergency and
um and it's you know for for people in
the in the tech sector
um they they hold the cards right now
the employees hold the cards so they're
able to say look you know I expect to be
able to do a lot of telework and that's
going to be a term of employment for me
as an individual
um that's over time that'll probably
swing slowly back although you know my
last couple of jobs we we worked
wherever we were and it didn't matter so
we never really talked about telework
it's just I think more in the uh but you
can even see that the thrash like the in
in the private sector there with um you
know some of these large companies
saying everybody needs to come back
right now because I want you in the
office and and what the impact of that
is on on turnover
um and things like that so I personally
think we're you know over time we'll
swing back
um and it's really important I think for
leaders who are using technology
to you know when we're all in the office
for example a lot of us are in the
office every day we're still using those
these tools particularly the stuff
that's moving out now which is actually
going to be another Quantum Leap like
using a TL having a team chat going on
where you know a particular project is
focused on that that's super efficient
everybody in the project knows what's
going on at all times people can comment
on things we can react more quickly to
one bumps in the night occur so
balancing that against the culture and
the and creating organizations that
people want to work in and feel like
they're part of I think that's the
challenge for us leaders in in this
space now
let me um go into my lesson I'm aware of
what time it is let me go to my last
thought page 14. your proposed House
Bill 2 language notwithstanding you can
fill positions unfunded positions
so historically Governors and
legislatures have looked a scans at this
sort of a request dramatically so and
and the the number of departments in
which was allowed were always zero or
one
um or typically one I think
um and uh
because it's a little too much
flexibility on the other hand we seem to
be entering into a different
climate where
you know every commissioner has talked
about you know if if we if we get some
help on wages I might be able to hire a
few more people and the the dollar
figure of the kind of help they want is
probably
um beyond what they're expecting it's
probably not going to reach their
expectation but I think there's some
some thought I I'm noting to myself and
trying to predict the future that James
keeps asking people what their vacancy
rate is
um and it makes me think
um I I don't know but in a you seem to
be trying to provide some certainty to
policy makers that what I'm asking for
is flexibility within reason and and how
do we you know just thoughtfully balance
that I mean I I really do think that we
could we could um Pitch legislators and
governors on on sensible ideas
presuming they felt that we were
sufficiently restrained and um can you
talk a little bit about
how this both provides you flexibility
and restraint at the same time well we
we we're operating under this language
now in this budget so it was passed
um in and for for this budget that we're
running in now and it was theoretical
when we asked for it we found it very
helpful in in if I'd say what a half a
dozen maybe cases in the you know in the
last year and a half
um where and what's happening is we
always like to look at we're not into
big reorgs in what we always want to be
self-adjusting so if somebody leaves
it's not knee-jerk
that that we would automatically replace
that position we'd look at the overall
needs of the organization and say what's
our highest need
and then and
focus on that and this has really helped
on that because I might you know does
somebody retires or leaves I I and I
look at the total picture of doit and
our priorities I might say oh you know
we really need that kind of person more
than this kind of person when you say
let's unfund that position and let's
fund this one that's unfunded position
and then
in in reality it often requires a
reclass of the vacant position
and we haven't found it oh I'm going to
use this to pay people more that hasn't
been at all what we've been doing what
we've been doing is let's hire this I'll
say oh developer left and I need a
business analyst or something like that
so I will not fund a developer but I
will hire a business analyst and we're
seeing that kind of thing go on so I I
think it's really smart for the state
and to do that because we're not we're
not going to spend more money it's the
intent is to not spend more money the
intent is to be more effective with the
money that were appropriated and be
better better stewards of that money how
do you assure policy makers that you're
not going to substitute your priorities
for theirs I mean it's it's winded in
departments on some level that gets at
that a little bit but I think in in some
you know you you know let's just say an
agency of like 23 people versus an
agency of 300 people they're sometimes
uh lawmakers will fund certain things
and not others and well
the um
we involve uh the legislature there's uh
in the development of our strategic plan
through the I.T Council which has
representation on the I.T Council and
you know we look at that strategic plan
that's not just a theoretical document
for us so so I would say that that
if I don't do that you should get rid of
me
I should be a good Steward I should
understand what the legislative
priorities are and and follow them and
and and I'm assuming from uh from uh if
I haven't approved
um and well thought of strategic plan
and that's what we're using as our
guidance then then
um
then that's pretty good long-term check
and balance
do you think I should ask for this too
pardon me you think I should ask for
this too yes thank you
foreign
I guess now it's good afternoon
[Laughter]
this is in regards to prioritized needs
and I like the the buckets that you have
they're the categories in terms of your
one two and three
um what I'm curious on is with
prioritized needs and this is just a
I'll say agency direct area I was
looking at it's around 17 18 million
is do you have any sense and it can just
be an estimate of how much of that is
I'll say your priority APN one category
which is you know Capital budgets Grant
you know things that were more I'll say
Capital related building infrastructure
that's now become operations yeah so so
in that from an agency perspective of
the total there's 9.4 million is it's
APN one
3.7 million APN 2 and 4.5 million I'll
give you this so you don't have to
um and then
um in from a doit apn's perspective it's
it's flipped it's it's almost a million
in one
4 million and two and a half a million
in three and overall we're at about
you know when you put those all together
it averages out to like 33 and 42
percent yeah for one and then this is
for each fiscal of year 32 and 31 and 2
and 35 and 26 and 3.
you know new initiatives or or
expanding a little bit you know of
existing the isn't goals but not
saying that they're not important but I
feel like the the critical is if we
spent the money already in the capital
or other from other funding sources to
not fund the now ongoing operating seems
to me a definitely a higher priority
than something new even though I know
the new is is important and I just
that's what I learned to get a sense for
yeah and I we did that very consciously
because we wanted people to understand
what they were looking at
um and and know that you know in some
cases if you say if it's an APN you know
if it's an APN two or one and you say no
I'm not going to fund that that may have
implications on ongoing operations okay
all right thank you
thank you very much thank you
enjoy your luncheon thank you
the hearing will be in recess until 1pm
foreign
good afternoon if I could get everyone
to take their seats so we can begin
I'd like to reconvene the governor's
budget hearing and invite the public
employees labor relation board up to
give their testimony
could I could I ask you to turn on the
microphone which is we're being that
this helps with the uh so now it's red
is that on now it's on it's on now yeah
I'm going to start over uh you're you're
good
um
so the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board currently has uh six board members
uh three vacancies all alternate
positions and they're supported by four
full-time authorized positions myself
included the board is an administrative
tribunal charged with administering the
state's
public sector collective bargaining law
which touches upon public employers at
the state
City municipal and county level there
are currently
approximately 649 bargaining units which
translates to about 610 collective
bargaining agreements because a number
of State bargaining units are covered by
one master contract
um I did provide a handout which is a
high level overview of the various
activities of the Public Employee Labor
Relations Board and I'm not going to go
through each one in any detail but if
you have any questions about them
I'm happy to respond after I touch upon
some of the numbers
as to the numbers
um
our budget requests year to year tend to
be very consistent
uh this year the overall request for
fiscal year 24 is approximately 539 000
most of which is General funds and in
fiscal year 25 532 thousand dollars
about 89 percent of our budget is class
10 personnel class 60 benefits and class
rents and leases and we are in year one
of our most recent five-year lease in
the same building that we've been in
since 2012.
um as to the efficiency budget I just
wanted to highlight a couple of things
and again I understand these are small
numbers compared to some of the things
that are being discussed here the last
two days
um
our our class 22 rent is increasing by 9
700 a year which
translates over the five-year terminal
leads to about 19 a square foot we have
about 2 300 square feet of space
we have a one-time item in class 30 7
500 for equipment mainly for replacing
the tables we use in the hearing room uh
and in aging and somewhat dangerous
partition we use in one of our office
spaces
uh for transfers to other agencies we
have a new item uh we are enrolled in
the Human Resources support unit program
uh this is our second quarter we've been
uh very happy with the services they've
provided and the responses that we get
to our questions uh so there is a new
item of thirty eight hundred dollars
per year more or less for each fiscal
year
doit class 27 increases forty seven
hundred dollars and five thousand
dollars years one and two
um those are figures that doit provides
I really can't break down those figures
so the total increases for year one is
about 28 000 year to about 21
000.
um the more interesting uh part of the
budget and something that we're excited
about is in the additional prioritized
needs we've been looking on and off with
doit and coming up with some sort of
economically feasible case management
system we reviewed the options again
this past spring and we identified legal
files which has been in use at the board
of tax and land appeals for probably
close to 20 years
uh they're in in fiscal year one there
was a one-time uh startup cost of about
eleven thousand dollars and the
licensing of the software in year one is
about six thousand uh in year two uh the
consultant fees to help maintain the
system is five thousand I'm not sure if
that's those are additional services
that doit will provide or if that's
outside Consultants probably provided
through legal files and the licenses for
year two are in that uh seven thousand
dollar plus or minus range this would be
a a a huge step forward for uh our board
in terms of modernizing uh our case
management systems currently uh we rely
on a cobble together system consisting
of excel sheets
folders
using the Outlook calendars uh in
theoretically I'm the only one who who
is familiar with all the moving parts
and that's not always true so we do have
system breakdowns we do have concerns
about data management and and data loss
based on the experience of the board and
tax of land appeals and the um
preview of the software that we had with
legal files we feel that would be an
excellent fit and I think the costs make
a lot of sense and should be included as
part of our budget
a couple of additional items and the
additional prioritized needs there's an
entry for cabling fiber capital S
capital W defined Network Dash e n h
hands
uh year one seven thousand dollars only
I can't break that item uh down for you
but periodically uh doit does uh as it
does throughout the state have to make
certain upward adjustments and Equipment
replacement uh and this is obviously a
one-time cost to do that
um not clear to me if it's a cost that's
uh required because of legal files or if
it's a cost that we would incur
otherwise
um and then in this cycle uh I think
laptops are being listed in as APNs I
think in the past they were included in
the maintenance budget but there is a in
year two two thousand dollars for
laptops and software year one and year
two about fourteen hundred dollars in
each year
so that is the quick overview and
highlights and I'm happy to answer any
questions and sure thank you
other than technological uh changes or
technical additions to to your to your
agency what are the major challenges
you're facing if they're any beyond that
well no challenges that are unique I
mean the challenges are driven by the
types of cases that we get filed so
obviously as as was the case in many
workplaces private and public sector
throughout the state we saw a lot of
covert related cases come in dealing
with various issues
um there are cases driven by
technological things so for example we
had a case come in recently where a
question has been raised about the state
telework policy and and there's language
I think in the policy that addresses
the availability of that program for
employees who reside out of state so
there are novel issues that come up that
are driven by circumstances that none of
us ever anticipated and then there are
more routine issues that come up that
are generated by bargaining friction and
issues
the bargaining unit formation
representation of unions
things like that without going into the
detail of cases but otherwise I I feel
we're well positioned uh to do the job
that we're charged with under the
statute I feel like we're getting the
support we need uh from the oit side of
the state services and from the
Personnel side of the state Services
through the hrsu group
and the the laptops you're requesting
are they additional or replacement
laptops are they are they new for for
somebody or just see replacement and
they're typically scheduled by doit as
part of our budget because if it's not
in there and it turns out a laptop has
reached its end life then there's a
scramble we don't have a lot of extra
money that we can shift
from one class to another to cover in
unanticipated expenses like that so it's
not an unusual item I'm not sure why it
was entered as an APN but that's how it
was presented
um from doit so that's how it appears in
our budget okay thank you
hi sorry I was late I apologize for that
um
I have a good excuse but I can't explain
it in public
kidding um the um how much do your board
members make how much do they make so
our board members are paid a 50 per diem
fifty dollars per diem
um do they write their own decisions
do they write do they write the
decisions or do you write them yes
okay
um I just in a just so it doesn't seem
cryptic I'm uh compiling a list of how
much
the way the state pays adjudicative
boards is enormously inconsistent
and and I'm trying to find Rhyme or
Reason in it and there doesn't so far
seem to be any understood
thank you very much thank you very much
you'd like to invite the governor's
Commission on disabilities do you give
their testimony
yeah good afternoon good afternoon uh
commissioner Allen house and other
members of this panel I am Chuck Sayer
the executive director of the governor's
Commission on disability and to my left
is that business administrator Ms Stacy
dubia who put all the figures together
for this honorable panel today so again
thank you so much uh for this
opportunity
um we do have handouts and which really
go over at a very high level what we
refer to as what the gcd does
um on a regular basis on a daily basis
so when we look at the governance
Commission on disability there is one
driving federal law that we adhere to
which is embedded within our mission
that's the Americans with Disabilities
Act
um at a very high level an instrumental
piece of federal legislation which
ensures that individuals with
disabilities cannot be discriminated
against because of their disability
we are the office itself the agency is
located at 54 Regional drive with some
tenants of division of personnel so we
were originally a couple of years ago
over at the Philbrook building when
Philbrook was repurposed commissioner
Allen House off in a space and the rent
was right and we and we decided to uh
move in and it's actually been a very
very good relationship because there is
a there is an intersection when we look
at individuals with disabilities and
employment and obviously division of
personnel which which I will talk again
later as a results to the uh additional
prioritized needs request so again when
we look at the gcd and within the
confines of the Ada we're primarily
focused on employment of individuals
with disabilities and necessary
accommodations that an individual may
need either obtaining employment or when
they're employed we have a position that
also looks at the physical accessibility
of what we refer to as the built
environment so for example if a state
agency is going to enter into a third
party lease
and that lease obviously is negotiated
in order for it to proceed before
governor and Council there has to be a
letter of opinion that emanates from our
statutory committee known as the
architecture barrier-free design
committee which is supported by the gcd
and that's the accessibility specialist
and we also look at what's referred to
as title III issues under the Ada which
deals with private businesses that are
open to the public who again have to um
abide by the mandates of the Ada
um some of the other issues we deal with
on a regular basis deal with housing as
it pertains individuals with
disabilities service animals and what is
a service animal
um and just general
um information regarding
um the Ada
from an administrative standpoint we
have six full-time employees including
myself one part-time employee there is
currently one vacancy at the gcd for for
a full-time employee that is the
accessibility specialist that's been
vacant since September we expect to post
that sjd
um soon we have to make some changes to
it and where it we're working with
personnel there are three major
organizational units at the gcd or au's
accounting units one zero zero four one
zero zero six and one zero zero seven so
one zero zero four is the commission on
disability which is a mixture of other
funds and also General funds the other
fun other funds being predominantly from
the New Hampshire
Department of Employment excuse me
Department of Education excuse me
um who who supports a the part-time
individual who was at the G CD
1006 is 100 federal funds and one zero
zero seven are other funds that come
from the Public Utilities Commission so
um if we were to focus on one zero zero
four
um our efficiency budget did come in
well within the target as was requested
by the governor I believe when we built
the efficiency budget we looked at an
increase of about sixteen thousand
dollars from the actuals of 22 and about
twelve thousand more
um in FY 25
within the um there are a couple of
addition prioritized needs
we are on a regular basis what we try to
do is obviously look at our our
operating software as in in laptops so
we've um we've requested doit for the
replacement of one laptop laptop in each
year of the biennium in one printer and
we typically do that Mr Gary
um every two years so that we ensure
that we're up to date on our needs uh
within the it we've um we're almost
there with as a result of covid we're
switching over to everyone having a
laptop and in case uh you know we need
that accessibility and ability to move
around we we do have that prior to that
we didn't there was a we didn't have too
many laptops we were taking the monitors
and the hard drives out and we learned
our lesson which is a good thing
um to learn
um other than that if it's it's subject
to your approval I can go on to the
additional prioritized needs request
again so we do have um there is an
audition prioritized needs as it deals
with doit as a result of the numbers
that were originally given to us that we
had to build into our existing budget
and there is also a request for a
part-time position at the gcd what we
are looking at Mr Gary is a request for
a what we we have termed undubbed in Ada
coordinated position
a few years back the gcd organized
itself into a work group known as the
workforce focus group and what we did
was working very closely with personnel
and working closely with other
stakeholders from state government and
from the community we wanted to look at
the um the ability of an individual with
a disability to apply for a job in the
state and to obtain and retain what is
known in the industry or in the
community as competitive integrated
employment one of the findings was in
and this is not endemic to New Hampshire
alone is there are many individuals that
service and within HR responsibilities
or HR positions when an individual from
another agency is dealing with a
question as it pertains to the Ada they
may not have that background that that a
more robust person may have so one of
the concepts that came out of the work
group was it was to have a position
house at the gcd
hope and I've been in constant
communication with the division of
personnel perhaps enter into an
agreement with dop
to work together to act as a resource
for the entire State of New Hampshire
when an individual is attempting with an
individual with a disability is
attempting to gain employment or is or
is already employed so again to have
those Ada resources um available
um a part-time position would uh in the
first year of the biennium would come to
31 427 in in the second year of the
biennium it's right in there at that
right in that amount coupled with that
as a as the benefits of class 60 as well
as a laptop for that individual so that
is probably and again thankfully when we
look at because we came well within the
target I'm looking over at our business
supervisor Steve McLaughlin thankfully
um and and I do agree it should be in
the prioritized needs request so that we
can really vet this out and see how this
is going to work in state government but
thankfully
um if if this were in the efficiency
budget we would be over but not by now
much money we talk in you know not a
great amount
so with that you know respectfully i i a
request for us to you know I'm more than
happy to speak about the position or
have further Communications about it but
I do think you know there's a concept in
the country known as uh same the state
as the model employer and I have to tell
you the uh the state of New Hampshire is
is truly Stellar when it comes to its
division of personnel and the
collaboration among all agencies to
ensure that we're hiring
um all individuals and to really make it
in in an inviting environment
um to have an ADA coordinated position
at the gcd to work closely and to be a
resource for other states excuse me for
other state agencies
um I think as they step in the right
direction we've seen that with the
governor's recovery friendly workplace
initiative which again I have tipped my
hats many times to the governor because
it is it's Innovative and it's really
looking at individuals with a disability
in the workforce and and giving
employers the tools they need to ensure
that that individual
um who is regarded is having a
disability when you're in recovery to to
have that competitive integrated
employment
um I look at EAP again another
incredible program
um in the state of New Hampshire as
another collaborator when we're looking
at Ada coordination when we're looking
at recovery friendly
um just across the Spectrum either if
it's a physical disability or mental
health
um disability uh the Ada has come so far
in in the 32 years since uh it's been
enacted
um so that's the additional prioritized
needs requests and then moving on
um there although not written within the
handout respectfully I would also ask
that we consider or that you consider
the hrsu for the gcd the human resources
support unit
um I think that again in I think just
another Innovative concept that
obviously the uh division of personnel
has come up with and I um we do have
figures from the division of personnel
that would run to the um in the amount
of
5292 for FY 24 and
5502 for FY 25.
um we are a small agency but I but I
have to tell you from what I see about
HR SEO it really benefits both lodgy and
small
um from what I can speak to is and you
know Stacy does an incredible job when
it comes to the finances
um and she really does what she can to
get up to speed on the HR protocols as
it applies to
um payroll and any other human resource
but again what we see with the business
administrators their Forte are the
numbers they sit in and they can work
through on the human resources
um but again to have that support of the
hrsu who then will deal with Stacy
directly in my opinion would be an
advantage not only to the gcd but even
to the state as a whole so with that I
will I can keep going but I will keep it
limited because I know you have a busy
schedule so thank you for your time
thank you and this was a a wonderful
presentation to dovetail off of your
presentation to the executive Council
well thank you which uh it was widely
well received and thank you very much we
don't usually get they don't usually let
me attend the breakfast meetings but
because it was a home court advantage I
got to go to that we lucked up with the
location it was very very worth my time
so thank you so much just a a question
on how the pandemic has impacted you
especially I mean we we've heard we hear
so many stories from other agencies
about procurement and being able to find
contractors and materials and everything
I imagine that would be especially true
when you're talking about trying to make
a home ADA Compliant home or a business
ADA Compliant is that something you've
run into and if you could just uh maybe
enlighten me a little bit about the
challenges that that's remain now
sure it's a um it's a great question you
know obviously the pandemic was uh you
know new to all of us and there were
there were many many issues that in
calls and emails that were coming into
the Ada excuse me into the gcd
um and we were learning as we go
um essentially
um do I uh there issues were there
issues with supply chain issues and
whether or not contract is could make
what we see even a residential home
um uh ADA Compliant or even just to put
in a ramp for an individual because
technically when you're looking at a
single family residence it's not under
the same building code requirements per
se as a commercial building would be
because it's your own residence but if
an individual needed a ramp to get it to
get a contractor in there was difficult
and and we were Fielding those calls
doing the best we could working with
various um agencies you know the nice
thing about the gcd you know sitting
what right within the state government
in the governor's office I've always
looked at that from the day I started my
tenure is an incredible
um
Advantage for the gcd we're not an
enforcement agency and and I say that
openly but what we are we're an agency
that's willing to collaborate so at the
end of the day when when I'm dealing
with a with a constituent are as
importantly someone who is working with
a constituent who feels agreed for us to
have the governor's office behind us we
work very closely with governance
constituent services on times
um ends up being you know a definite
Advantage for the GCT so again we were
filled in many calls as it related to
um compliance I'm getting contract as
I'm into a building and and truthfully
it it just comes down to it and you know
we have a great website it's it we're
undergoing um changes now to bring it up
to the most current
it's one thing to tell a person to fill
out an ADA assistance form and that's
great they should fill out the form get
back to us but what I owe what's most
important for our office is to speak to
the person because that's what the
person wants to hear
um and I know some agencies it it varies
but we we do the best we can to have
that one-on-one and to collaborate and
to mediate to bring the parties together
and truthfully I think that that even
you know pans out in state government I
there are times when I may call
commissioner Allen house or even any it
might be commissioner still it was in
the role model or uh you know direct the
Mason just to you know to really just
collaborate to resolve an issue
thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you
really appreciate your time okay
I'd like to invite the New Hampshire
Retirement System
nothing give their testimony
are you going to talk about the highway
from the doll
I'll leave that to commissioner tax
good afternoon
good afternoon my name is Jan Goodwin
and I am the executive director of nhrs
and with me to my left is Marie Mullen
our Director of Finance and Marty Carlin
our director of communications and
legislative affairs
although today's presenters are new in
this capacity
and hrs's message is the same we still
have some challenges in front of us and
we are pleased with a positive progress
we have made and the significant
operational improvements which have been
implemented over the past decade
Our member level has remained steady and
the number of our retirees and
beneficiaries continues to increase as
expected
let me go over some brief highlights
our statutory administrative budget
before you today encompasses all the
internal non-investment related
Administration costs including projected
I.T costs at full value
nhrs's Board of Trustees reviews and
approves the statutory administrative
budget biennially
the budget for fiscal year 23 is 12.1
million and our proposed budgets for the
next two years are slightly higher at 13
million for a fiscal of year 24 and 13.7
million for fiscal year 25. and that's
based on fully Staffing all authorized
positions and completion of our pension
system administrative software upgrade
as you well know nhrs is not an
executive agency and does not rely on
General funds for its funding
and caught our contributions come from
employers and members and investment
returns
and I'd like to review some key facts
about nhrs with you and HRS provides a
modest pension benefit the average
annual pension benefit is just over 21
800 dollars
the nhrs benefits that are paid help
support the New Hampshire economy in the
last fiscal year and HRS paid out more
than 900 million in pensions and 45
million in medical subsidy benefits
almost 80 percent of retirees live here
in New Hampshire and spend their money
here supporting many jobs Statewide
and fortunately we have a plan in place
to pay down the nhrs unfunded liability
and we continue to execute on this plan
There are 16 years remaining on the
payoff of the original unfunded
liability which existed back in 2007.
the employer contribution rates for the
four membership classifications employee
teacher police and fire will decrease in
fiscal years 24-25 from
3.75 percent to eight percent depending
upon the member group and setting these
employer contribution rates is one of
the key responsibilities for our
13-member board
our 13 trustees continue to strengthen
the plan by adopting sound and realistic
Actuarial assumptions recommended by our
actuaries
because of its strong constitutional and
statutory Foundation nhrs is on the path
to full funding the retirement system is
making good progress on paying down its
unfunded liability
and our unfunded liability I'm sorry our
funded ratio increased to 65.6 points
0.6 percent in fiscal year 22 up from
64.2 percent in fiscal year 21.
now I'll review some of the highlights
which are on pages four and five
we remain on schedule with our
multi-year project to upgrade our core
pension
application from the 22 year old version
to the new
version version three and that project
is now at 67 percent complete
we've implemented the statutory changes
enacted in 2022 these seven bills as a
group were the most sweeping statutory
changes that affected nhrs since 2011.
you can see on page four the chart that
illustrates how our funded ratio has
been improving over the past few years
although we realize the negative six
point a negative 6.1 percent return on
investments in the fiscal year ended
June 30 2022.
however we did over the longer term have
returns that exceeded our assumed rate
of return
in addition our return exceeded our
Benchmark and nhrs did perform better
than two-thirds of its peers in fiscal
year 22 and we were in the top 20
percent over the past decade compared to
other pension public pension plans of
our size
we continue to look for ways to improve
efficiency at nhrs
we maintained and expanded various cyber
security enhancements designed to
protect the security of our system and
our members
personal information
we stopped accepting unencrypted email
attachments sent to the general
information mailbox which has been a
huge help for us for securing our system
however we do have significant
challenges and opportunities we continue
to review and adjust as needed the
Investment Portfolio to meet or exceed
the system's assumed rate of return of
6.75 percent over the long term while
managing risk return and liquidity
an Actuarial experience will be
conducted for the four-year period
ending June 30 2023 the study will
further the process of assuring that the
funding of the system is in alignment
with anticipated costs for providing
benefits
and now I will turn the table over to
Marie Mullen to review and detail our
agency budget
hi good afternoon
uh so the Retirement Systems uh
administrative budget for fiscal year
2024 we are proposing a 7.1 percent
increase over fiscal year 23's budget
and for fiscal year 2025 it fi it's a
five percent increase and that's that
five percent is compared to the fiscal
year 2024 budget
um the the primary increases in our
budget
um first and foremost are salaries and
benefits uh the retirement system has um
already negotiated a three-year contract
with employees so we already know what
our 24 and 25 salary projections are so
benefits are in there as well
we have increases in our technology
software and Hardware Hardware related
to cyber security and a significant
server replacement that will occur
during that time frame as well
and then the the other major area of
increases are related to the our pension
gold software implementation
um so we have the that software upgrade
and so we have increases related to that
during that time frame as we move into
completion of that over this time over
that over the next biennium
[Music]
um
any ques we're open to any questions and
if you have any questions on the budget
or
sure just uh question about the unfunded
pension liability
how does New Hampshire's unfunded
pension liability compare with other
states both regionally say New England
and then in the country as a whole
anyway has typically been I'm not sure I
might be out of date but it's always or
at least recently Wisconsin has always
been the model of having the lowest
unfunded pension liability and I think
maybe like New Jersey is always
typically one of the worst but Illinois
is another one yeah
where do where do we stand well it's
hard to State it in terms of the
unfunded liability because that is also
such a function of the size of the state
and the size of the total
employment of public employees and the
different investment portfolios uh maybe
a better way to compare them is in terms
of funded ratio
so in terms of funded ratio we are a bit
below our peers but we are solidly on a
trajectory of getting to 100 funding
we're very fortunate
um that a number of years ago the
legislature took important steps to
ensure that we will be
that we will continue to direct
trajectory to 100 funding and as I noted
earlier we did increase our funded ratio
from last year to this year one
interesting thing to compare it us with
is the state of Maine
they were basically in the same
situation we were but 10 years ago
before we started our Improvement they
started their own set of improvements
and right now their funded ratio is in
the 80s and in the next few years they
will be fully funded so we are hoping
that
um consistent with them that we continue
to stay on this good path that we are on
and we have turned the corner as far as
our unfunded liability is it is now
starting to decrease rather than
increase and that's because the
legislature made the commitment to
ensuring that nhrs gets its full
employer contributions every year
because it's having the contributions
received so they can earn investment
income that's the key to getting to 100
funding yeah how does your investment
guidelines differ from those of the
state as a whole then the treasury is
very limited in what they can invest in
it's basically U.S treasuries or some
derivative thereof uh I would imagine
yours vary from that
yes hours are very different from that
because unlike the state which is
typically a very short-term investor and
liquidity is the primary concern
nhrs has the luxury of being a long-term
investor so we are always looking for
the best risk adjusted return that we
can get
and because of that we are looking at
and invest in very different types of
investments in the state does which is a
short-term investor as a long-term
investor it's appropriate for us to
purchase stocks and bonds as well as
alternative Investments such as real
estate and private equity
okay
do you have any uh exposure to
cryptocurrency
we have been reviewing our portfolio and
it found minimal if no investments in
cryptocurrency okay great thank you
hi
um
I have a couple questions one I
appreciate the the comparison to your
performance of the to the peer group and
and just note that we're doing
uh in the top two-thirds I think it said
compared to a peer group on investments
which is terrific
um you mentioned the collective
bargaining agreement
um I presume your numbers are relatively
public and I ask what they settled at
what kind of race did you give for
fiscal year 23 it was 4.75 and fiscal
year 24 it was 4.5 percent
um thanks I just I suspect that will
inform the pressure that we have
um I have a question on the unfunded
liability
um 80 of it 80 of our employer
contribution is going toward paying
off the original
no 80 is going to have to pay the whole
uaal
um and it it sounds like
um the bulk of that has 16 years
remaining uh but there are portions of
that that have more than 16 years
remaining is that right how does that
rate ratio breakdown okay
the majority of the unfunded liability
at this point was attributable to
pre-2017 so it's been paid off now the
future amounts of
liability that are incurred after 2017
will be amortized over a new 20-year
periods
and you have a sense of how much that is
like are we are we keeping up are we
following
we keep not quite keeping up no we are
keeping up um the the amount since then
are much smaller
um I can see
thank you that's exactly what I was
asking that's very helpful
um my next question is about
so the four subgroups my understanding
is have different different ratios of
funding and are we paying them
differently yes each subgroup has its
own employer and member contribution
rates and do we feel like we're
um with each of the four different
subgroups
um is the current structure so I'm going
to think of the current structure as
um are we taking enough out absence of
money we're amortizing are we taking
enough out between the employee
contribution the employer contribution
and investment income to keep up to be
solvent
um and then then there's an extra that
we're paying on top of that
um so the extras you know 16 years 20
years whatever is being paid in the 5.6
but for each of those four subgroups
there's a question about whether we're
charging the right number or we're
falling further behind further behind
and accruing new liabilities and are
they are they different because I I
think they're probably
varying levels of
solvency
all of our funds are solvent
um our actuaries every year check to see
that
we have sufficient funds
that are currently on hand and who
expected to come in in the future to
ensure that we can pay all the benefits
in the future that's part of the the gas
b68 country
um reporting that has to be done and
they because we have sufficient Assets
Now we do not
have to use the Blended rate for
calculating our net pension liability so
we do not have a solvency issue
and every two years the actuaries review
what the contribution rates need to be
to ensure that we stay on this
trajectory to 100 funding so we are not
falling behind for any on any of the
groups because they set each group rate
independently of each other
and is it fair to say there's no
cross-subsidization
that we're not overcharging teachers to
fund employees or Etc
the actuaries look at each group as a
separate entity to arrive at their
contribution rates great thank you
foreign
and how much square footage do you have
I
it runs through 2035 I'm not sure on the
Square never mind 2020.
everything else is going to ask is
irrelevant after that I'm sorry
everything else I was going to ask is
irrelevant after that
yeah just be honest
yes I we extend every five years so we
have we have the ability to extend out
to 2035 that's why okay that's right it
goes through this biennium yes okay
thank you
great thank you very much appreciate
your testimony
I'd like to invite the Department of
Natural and cultural resources for their
testimony
Could you um support us in the spirit
could you maybe sing for us
this is being broadcast throughout the
world on the internet so please
um this is just to inspire
uh you with some of our new products we
like partnering with New Hampshire
businesses our coffee is new this year
um next year it will be branded with our
Park State Park logo it's a company out
of Manchester and as always we we
showcase some of our parks and historic
sites with our Christmas ornaments so
get them while we still have them
um with that
good afternoon and please begin
good afternoon
I'm Sarah Stewart the commissioner of
the Department of Natural and cultural
resources and with me is Chris Marino
who oversees the office of
administration we have our division
directors here as well in case you have
questions
the dncr is home to five divisions the
divisions of Parks and Recreation the
division of forests and lands the
division of historical resources the
State library and the New Hampshire
State Council on the Arts our Collective
mission is to protect preserve promote
and manage the state's natural and
cultural resources supporting New
Hampshire's high quality of life and
strengthening the experiences of our
residents and our guests
the dncr employs nearly 1 000 people
each year
we manage over 220 000 Acres of public
land and maintain approximately 870
buildings of various types with the
total value reaching nearly 50 million
dollars
we also manage 22 Bridges 15 fire Towers
26 dams 149 septic systems 91 waterways
and over 300 miles of roads and parking
lots
we are headed into another busy winter
season where we will oversee the
management of 7 000 miles of snowmobile
trails an important part of the state's
booming outdoor recreation economy and
I'm very excited to report that our
Cannon Mountain ski resort is ranked
number eight in the east in ski
magazines 2022 reader Resort survey
which is the highest ranking New
Hampshire Resort
our agency's broad scope of services is
also Illustrated in how we touch the
daily lives of our citizens in every
community of the state our programs
grants and services have only expanded
as a result of the covid pandemic for
example the division of historical
resources required project review and
compliance program experienced a 30
percent increase
growth is the key word in this budget
request our state parks have seen
significant growth in attendance online
reservations camping and retail sales
to respond to this growth our State Park
season has grown to 36 weeks opening
earlier in the spring and staying open
beyond Columbus Day
similarly the division of forest and
lands is also experiencing growth we've
helped to conserve several thousand more
Acres available for public access and
our forest rangers are seeing a lot more
activity consistent with the growth in
outdoor recreation
for the fifth season running seedling
sales in the new at the New Hampshire
State Forest Nursery in boscoin continue
to outpace the previous year's marks
sales income increased 52 percent from
2021's record-breaking season and
reflected of
146.7 increase since 2018.
the year I started
the total number of orders was up 37.6
from last year which is just about
double 96.5 percent compared to five
years ago
the number of seedlings lifted sorted
for Quality packaged and sold increased
50.8 percent from 2021 a 135.2 jump
from 2018. in order to respond to this
overall growth we have evaluated our
staffing needs and are requesting
permission to convert an 890 positions
into permanent full-time positions
within parks and 192 permanent full-time
within the division of historical
resources
we would also like to add an additional
four stranger and an additional Forester
to assist us in monitoring over 270 000
Acres of private land under conservation
easements
I'm also seeking your support for three
positions in the office of the
commissioner
this agency relies on the legal advice
of the Attorney General's office and
over the past several years it has
become increasingly clear that with the
number of contracts lease agreements
rule making and day-to-day interactions
with the public there is enough work to
support a full-time agency attorney
I have discussed this need with the doj
attorneys assigned to us and they
wholeheartedly agree
another full-time position I wish to
fill with your support is a dncr
financial analyst specializing in
Federal grant Administration from the
land and water conservation fund to the
National Endowment for the Arts and the
U.S forest Service are five divisions
administer millions of Federal grant
funds annually
rather than continue to oversee a very
siled attempt to pull this off each
Grant season each Grant round our staff
would benefit from the support of a
centralized service position and I
suspect the team at Das would also
appreciate the efficiency of working
with a central point person rather than
many individual Grant administrators
sprinkled throughout our agency
finally a position I have advocated for
in the past and truly believe will be a
game changer for us is to have a dncr
curator
as part of our mission we are to provide
access to the many Treasures that we
manage this includes artwork historic
items archaeological finds collections
that have been donated to us and much
more
my vision is to hire someone who can
help us organize our treasures and then
help to develop public-facing exhibits
and programs at our State library at our
parks and historic sites and even
traveling exhibits to schools local
public libraries and other community
centers
we are currently seeking a consultant
through the RFQ process to assess the
state library's current space and
provide us with a plan to store much of
the stacks in a climate-controlled
storage facility freeing a valuable
space for exciting and endless
opportunities to engage the public
other considerations in this budget
request include accounting for dramatic
increases in our utility expenses and
inter-agency transfers
something I would like to point out for
discussion is the fact that since 2007
when the Bureau of historic sites was
created it was generally fund General
funded
this was done on purpose in order to
dedicate funds to the stewardship and
management of our designated historic
sites separating them from Parks funding
which has ebbed and flowed over the
years
historic sites also have a separate
Mission from Parks which is telling the
stories of who we are through our
buildings Landscapes Collections and
Exhibits
two years ago when we were asked to cut
our overall general fund budget we did
so without compromising our commitment
to the Bureau of historic sites instead
we shifted part Revenue over which you
will see is what we did again this year
shifting back to General funds is
something that we would like to discuss
further
looking at our prioritized needs we are
making these requests consistent with
our theme of growth and demand
New Hampshire's artists cultural
organizations and for-profit venues were
hit very hard during the pandemic and
have not fully recovered a recent survey
of 53 non-profit grantees
most of which receive Arts Council
operating support showed 2022 earned
Revenue to date at 78 of at only 78 of
pre-pandemic levels and this is
consistent with national Trends and is
troubling
additional state of assistance will be
needed in the fiscal year 24 25 biennium
as they reoriented their business models
to what may be the new normal
we are also seeing an opportunity to
push Beyond critical needs to support
the state's cultural Assets in a way
that fulfills The increased demand from
the public throughout the sector
specifically requests for operating
support have increased significantly as
organizations mature and become eligible
for Grants applications to this two-year
program increase 30 percent in FY 22 23
more than fiscal year 2021.
requests to the Arts and health grant
program have also increased a 33 percent
increase in fiscal year 23 over 22 we
project continued growth in this program
as pandemic recovery continues
particularly in the area of behavioral
health and substance misuse services and
due to this growth we are requesting a
new grants coordinator position to lead
this program
I did speak with commissioner shibanet
recently about this and she will be
willing to um share her thoughts and
support for this idea as well
uh the artist entrepreneurial grant
program continues to grow as artists
build and diversify their careers in
small businesses and there's a need for
capacity building support for emerging
Arts organizations particularly in the
areas of financial management and fund
development
so much as the state allocated funds to
boost outdoor recreation to meet the
needs of the public we see similar
demand and opportunity with the Arts
you will also see a request to support
New Hampshire public television
historically nhpbs was supported by the
state through UNH 2.7 million annually
but funding was eliminated in 2011.
New Hampshire PBS will utilize the
requested funds to provide the state and
the country with engaging local content
that showcases the state's Rich natural
cultural historical and environmental
resources
some of the programming nhpbs will
produce include our Music Arts Heritage
and how it impacts the New Hampshire
economy documentaries about New
Hampshire's hidden history our diverse
new populations the vibrant Farm to
Table movement and much more
the amount requested will simply pass
through our agency to New Hampshire
public television
but by allocating it to the Arts Council
we can count this money toward our
federal match and this is a strategic
way to make sure that every dollar works
hard for New Hampshire
in conclusion the dncr has sustained
substantial growth over the past few
years and in order to move ahead on this
trajectory we have identified specific
opportunities to put the pedal to the
metal while staying within the three
percent general fund growth limitation
and by offsetting new positions we need
with several vacant positions that we
can abolish
we are here to answer your questions
thank you commissioner
uh sort of the the question of of the
the this this three days revolves around
challenges and Workforce challenges and
I know from my old job at the dra uh
that that at least at one point you were
having Workforce challenges especially
in the forest ranger area uh has that
subsided have you had any success in
that and overall what's your vacancy
rate and what your work for what's your
Workforce looking like now
okay over overall with the agency I feel
knock on wood pretty good about
um fulfilling the jobs we need to um to
adequately maintain our mission uh of
course we have a lot of seasonal
employees and so we get very nervous
heading into a summer season to make
sure we have enough lifeguards heading
into the ski season to make sure we have
have enough folks at Cannon Mountain but
we've managed to uh to really be
creative we're investing in social media
advertising and um and we have a lot of
folks that are seasonal that come back
year after year because they just love
working for the park system specific to
the division of forests and lands I've
I've been making this presentation now
three times I think and we're always
including for a stranger position in our
request because we are not at the at the
level we we really should be to cover
the state and with the increased outdoor
recreation
um you know our forest rangers are
pulled in many directions uh
coordinating with fish and game who also
need a lot of people outside at this
time so with that I'm turning to our
director of force and lands to see if he
wants to best specify any other talking
point
all right how are you very well thank
you good to see you
um so we have a requests for one Ranger
in this budget but to your point we have
10 Rangers right now the entire State
and that includes the machine and two
benefits who are largely administrative
so we don't accept the field makers
full of men and bigger but we still need
to replenish the banks we're looking at
one more into this hearing much great
thank you
um as far as other positions
um you know we're being as creative as
possible with Parks we went through the
the Contracting and approval process to
make sure that
um we could contract out bathroom
cleaning for example at Hampton Beach so
that we could hire people
um to do other things and and make sure
we weren't slipping in that area
um we we have moved one of our
lifeguards into a full-time position
over the past year so that he can help
recruiting earlier so we're very aware
of the challenges with hiring
um but we're determined not to have to
shut something down we're very public
facing so
um we're trying to be as creative and
Nimble as possible to to make sure we
have at least the minimum amount to keep
things moving okay uh you you mentioned
increased fuel costs and I know that uh
at least I've heard that making snow is
not cheap it's not and uh with with this
lovely warm whether we've been having it
seems that you'll be making a lot of
snow and is that are those assuming this
continues you know for a significant
time uh are those increased costs
reflected in this budget
yes
um uh going back a few years uh Canon
well the state invested in Canon doing a
lot of Energy Efficiency work
um Canon has received Awards through
from the state on their Energy
Efficiency so that was great it doesn't
get us all the way when we're faced with
warm weather and electricity costs up so
we are always strategic with our snow
blowing or even more so this this year
but we have accounted for that in our in
our projections and um and we'll
we'll make it happen
um just to clarify uh yeah absolutely
it's been built in
um even in this fiscal year we actually
just recently uh drafted a budget and
expend request
for about eight hundred thousand dollars
in anticipation of this fiscal year
um you know these prices for electricity
went from seven cents a kilowatt to 21
about 20 cents a kilowatt so it's a
significant increase so
through a combination of management of
snow making which nojd is very keen on
um and the hope of of Mother Nature
working we can hopefully come in
somewhere at a level that we can cover
with that draw going into 24 25 we've
built an approximately we've essentially
doubled our our budget for for energy
costs
um particularly at Cannon Mountain for
24 and 25 so we anticipate a significant
increase and we have accounted for that
do you think you have the ability to
increase rates and what you charge so we
went well I know and the first time we
presented our fee package it was tabled
we went back with a just a couple
adjustments um and it did pass so there
are some ticket prices that we'll see a
five dollar increase which is not a lot
um it we have a very good relationship
with
um our colleagues around the state in
the ski industry we part are active
participants at ski and H and so we
um
we're in the same boat as everybody else
um tickets will reflect that across the
board I'm proud that you know we can
maintain
um still a for you know affordable we
didn't have to Sky you know
jump really high with our prices this
year
um the luxury of being Cannon Mountain
is that uh we're not making money to
make money we're making enough to
provide wonderful skiing experience and
so keeping ticket prices manageable is
is a priority great thank you good
question hey
um I noticed a lot of stuff is up since
2018.
is anything down down
in terms of Revenue and so with oh this
was uh this was uh I was treating you
along and you could say unhappiness is
down
unhappiness is down Charlie of course
um I I think we're we're in a position
that
um that all of our Enterprise systems
are doing very very well
um my fear is that we don't have the
staff
um critical needs staff support to take
advantage of this moment and to make
sure that we're on setting a cell
ourselves up for sustainability going in
that direction it'll let it levels off a
little bit but I don't want to go back
backwards when we don't have to
um so a couple of these positions we've
collaborated as a group saying what can
the department as a whole benefit from
and these are the positions we chose
great
um you're it looks like you're to Me
Maybe I'm Wrong about this you're
projecting a fairly substantial increase
in Parks Revenue
I think you're budgeting something like
36 million becomes 41 and it's not just
a
um continuation of what's going on or is
something big happening
um
predicting the
continuing along we we are benefiting
from some arpa funds that we're going to
invest in some expansion of campgrounds
for example that's where our Revenue can
grow we're investing a lot more in our
creative online opportunity shopping
opportunities and our stores at
um at sites when that's where you know
The Flume our sales are going up that
Mount Washington our sales are going up
so we see where we can continue to to
buff some of those numbers
um and I think it's a combination of
where where our revenue is hitting 100
new capacity for parts at camping on
weekends is 100 so we have room to grow
so we're on to miss cautiously
optimistic that those projections are
accurate in terms of anything like big
um
when we do a ribbon cutting for a new
tram that will give everyone a jolt of
Pride and excitement and everyone will
want to go up the tram again
yes
why it makes me nervous I'm just saying
um
just just to clarify that increase
um one thing I did want to point out the
overall increase is in that five million
dollar range um just a couple of things
Financial items um that's a cumulative
figure for the entire division which is
not just service Parks includes the
trails Bureau for example okay we
actually increased the budget in the
trails Bureau by almost a little over
two million dollars and it wasn't
because we're anticipating more Revenue
because we're changing the model by
which we budget we used to budget very
conservatively and typically the fee
Revenue that would come in ultimately
would get transferred to us because we'd
have to go to fiscal at the end of the
fiscal year work with Fish and Game to
have that transferred to us in this
budget we've decided let's just build
that total amount into the budget from
the outset it is consistent at this
point to be somewhere in the six million
dollar range
so we've laid that out so that that is a
substantial chunk of that increase right
there
um and same thing with uh one of the um
Rector Trail programs uh that's those
are figures coming from New Hampshire
D.O.T that went up about a half a
million dollars
um and then the only other significant
increases of course we'd have to
accommodate the expected increases
energy costs but we are also very
optimistic as the Commissioners
explained we've posted million dollar
balances to the Canon on two years in a
row and our Revenue has gone from
15 million dollars in 2019 to 17 million
dollars in the last two years so the
trajectory has gone up very steep um and
we're hoping that that is going to
continue
as long as we continue to cultivate the
system that we have and leverage the
value that we have along those lines I
feel like with Parks there's um I mean
that's obviously some things that that
are
for lack of a better word net profit
centers I know we don't think of parks
that way but and some things that are
not right that you're not charging for
it doesn't make sense or that
um and I think some of that's location
right you know Canada or Hampton Beach
or whatever is some of it also activity
like our to what extent so coupling what
are your biggest
uh Revenue producing locations and that
were your biggest Revenue producing
activities I'm hearing campgrounds
like net I want to make sure that we
produce our new parks director Brian
Wilson in here I was hoping it would yes
um so um
I know Brian has been doing some
studying and stuff like that but I don't
I hate to put them on the spot because
he really is about a week into this job
um so I'm making testify what
um so The Flume at Franconia state park
for example really supports
much of the state park system there's
nine there's 93 state parks
um which includes some you know very
small ones but as director Phil Bryce
would explain of the pie of 93 half we
charge at and at a quarter of that a
quarter of the pie half of the half is
where we make Revenue so you're right
there are very strategic places where we
can
um we can try to try to sustain our
Revenue Hampton Beach is another one
where we are reinvesting in our meters
so we're taking out all the old ones
putting in new ones
um which I think is going to help us a
lot there's a the old ones are a little
bit getting clunky and weren't speaking
directly to the credit card machine so
this is another area where I think we're
going to pick up a little bit of Revenue
because of the ease of using it you can
stay on your on your towel on the beach
and just use your phone to add some more
money to your meter for example so
Campground expansion where we can use
the arpa funding um so little places
where we you know talk about where we
can make investments uh to yield more I
would say uh we're doing that another
activity uh is boat rentals so our Fleet
of paddle boats for example and kayaks
um have increased and uh you'll see them
driving through the notch on at Echo
Lake and a lot of our Inland beaches now
you can rent boats which has become a
very lucrative business
yeah that's kind of exciting and in
terms of campgrounds
um you know we're full and all that
um is there and you're going to expand
campgrounds but is there
you're limited right capital investment
and all that
um
are you building as many
uh I don't know what's right from his
beds as you could fill
no the honest answer I think I think
that we could
turn a lot of our state land into
back-to-back campsites and keep them
full but that's not well the experience
we're going for
um so we have using the arpa funds we
have hired a Consulting Group SE group
um there this is their business and they
did a full assessment of sort of our top
priority Parts
um and we can't hit them all at once
with this Arbor funds but now we have a
portfolio of plans that over the next
couple years we can pull out a map of
you know Bear Brook and see oh they did
the same we can do 15 a pot of 15 new
campsites here let's go for it so not
only is the arpa money actually allowing
us to in real time build more
campgrounds but it's also given us this
portfolio of of site plans so that we
can tackle them over the next couple
years to to try to continue expanding
not just capacity but experience so
we'll have some campgrounds where there
is no bathroom building or shower and
you bring a tent and we have campgrounds
where or we need to invest more now in
the amphiage of you know the the really
expensive RVs that go from I'm speaking
that way out of my language I know 30
amps sure to to accommodate a different
type of camper with their air
conditioning
um so we want we have Yurts we have
cabins
um
Yurts oh Yurts I've heard that word yes
and Kevin some of them so part of the
the goal here is to also offer an array
of unique experiences throughout our
campsite and not just pack them in like
sardines
no I don't I I love I mean sardines are
lovely but we don't write back then like
them has there ever been an unconscious
of getting the evil eye I'm going to
shut up after this
um
has there ever been any ex um looking at
funding capital investment and campsites
out of Revenue where's the revenue not
big enough to sustain Revenue well like
um you know occasionally a project is
funded because it's going to generate
revenue and the revenue will pay for The
Debt Service
or do we not have that kind of Revenue
speak yeah I mean that that mechanism is
built into to the to the funds the setup
that we have so the park uh the park
system there's a state park account
there's a park account well you do that
and so your investment other than the
airport
the balance currently stands around
seven million dollars
um in past bienniums we have invested
you know we're going to commit a million
dollars a year to that kind of
investment growth but it's measured
because we do have situations for
example when the pandemic hit that fund
helped sustain us for a little tune of a
couple million dollars as well
right we want to push in there so we
manage it but there is that opportunity
and we do a lot of Patchwork funding
um lwcf fund is available to us to a
certain extent
um moose plate fund for some of our
historic sites is available
um for us as well as our own Revenue so
yeah we are willing to sort of figure
out where we can make the dollar market
thank you how much is the coffee
um I believe
[Music]
you really don't have a career on QVC
set out for you
would you like to be the taste tester
I'm good
so I just had two quick ones one is um
you mentioned your some of the projects
with the arpa
um the answers are pull out a portfolio
and say hey bear broker
et cetera um does your the funding that
you get through arpa for that type of
work expire at the same time as other
Opera which I think is December of 24
yes okay so you're on that same timeline
that you would need to spend time you
must be encumbered by 20.
um and so one of the challenges I would
say in that sense is finding the right
people find people to do the work right
I was going to ask that too okay
okay the conception of let's see if we
can expand campgrounds with arpa funds
started a year and a half ago to now
things have tripled in price and it's
hard to find people we're working our
way through the process and prioritizing
things but that that would also be a
challenge that's not unique to our
agency no that's true
um resources are tight all around
including inflationary constraints
um my other question completely
different um I like your fact sheets I
was looking that out
um and you talked about a few different
positions one being sort of Legal
Financial Analyst curator et cetera but
on the score sheet or a fact sheet it
looks like you're only adding one
position so are you repurposing existing
positions and it's really just a net
gain of one position okay uh that's
that's correct um in the where we are
increasing the forests and lands by two
um but the commissioner's office is
going up by three we're also abolishing
three positions two thoughts at that so
it is a net that's why you don't see uh
substantial difference there yep
thank you very much
like to invite Fish and Game
to give your testimony
things
good afternoon
my name is Scott Mason I'm the executive
director at New Hampshire Fish and Game
and I've brought with me Kathy Labonte
chief of our business office I've also
brought with me two of our division
Chiefs uh Nicola Whitley uh in charge of
our public
um public relations and conservation
education as well as Colonel Jordan uh
chief of our law enforcement division
well good afternoon and thank you for
allowing us the time to present the fish
and game Department's budget requests
for the 24-25 fiennium New Hampshire
fishing game is home to the New
Hampshire Fish and Game Commission
Office of the executive director and
seven divisions business division the
public info and education division
wildlife
Inland Fisheries law enforcement Marine
Division and facilities and lions our
mission statement as guardians of New
Hampshire's Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources the New Hampshire Fish and
Game department works in partnership
with the public to conserve manage and
protect those resources and their
habitats inform and educate the public
about those resources and provide the
public with opportunities to use and
appreciate those these resources
um
missing from our mission statement is
the added missions that the legislature
has given to fish and game over the
years
as part of the work we do monitoring
Wildlife diseases we also work with
multiple state and federal agencies to
help protect New Hampshire citizens from
Zoological diseases
we work with Des to Monitor and control
invasive species our department offers
multiple types of information to help
keep outdoor recreation a safe while
enjoying New Hampshire's wildlife and
and wild habitats
we try we we try to use multiple media
approaches from a simple Facebook post
to a sit-down safety class uh to reach
people
we cover many different outdoor
recreational activities when a mishap
does take place our people are available
to lead the way with search and rescue
underwater recovery first aid our
conservation office is currently Patrol
over ten thousand miles of off off-road
motorized trails
according to the U.S Bureau of economic
analysis outdoor recreation added 2.6
billion to the New Hampshire economy in
2021 and employed slightly over 28 000
people
New Hampshire ranked 10th in the nation
for outdoor recreation as a percentage
of the gross domestic products we are
one of the state agencies that support
this industry in New Hampshire we
currently do it with 192 employees
working across the state at raising and
stalking fish managing our Wildlife and
Fish populations and their habitats we
run six hatcheries have four Regional
Offices 124 Wildlife Management areas
covering over sixty Thousand Acres 135
boat Landings educational Outreach
centers and headquarters and a givener
uh reach thousands of New Hampshire
residents throughout through our
conservation education classes and
opportunities
over the next biennium our goal is to
one of our goals is to upgrade our
database systems we received a go for
Grant in in
um to to do this goal so it's not
necessarily showing up in our budget
because of the the go for funding on it
um
our our database system had aged out and
we needed to make a major investment
um by the end of this year or else we
would have lost the serviceability of
these systems
uh we're moving more we're trying to
move more of our paper systems
computer-based systems a good example of
this is a new fish stocking page that
you can find on our web on our website
um my Inland Inland Fisheries Chief
Diane Timmons came up with this
site that allows the what the citizen
see is it allows it allows citizens to
see where we've stocked fish in a in a
time delayed fashion so they're not
necessarily following the truck but
within a few weeks they actually know
where the fish went in uh the first 60
days that this site was up we had over
three million hits now I can't guarantee
you that that three million different
New Hampshire residents and tourists
coming to New Hampshire it might just be
six 12 year old boys that know the New
Hampshire stocking program a lot better
than anyone else
um but also what the citizens don't see
are gone are this the old paper stocking
tickets that our Hatchery folks would
fill out and would end up on the
dashboards of the trucks and eventually
the trucks would have a slow day they
would get uh picked up and sent and then
inputted into the system
this allows our staff to have a much
more
current uh
status of where we've been stalking or
exactly where we've been stocking what
fish are out what fish aren't which
helps us to answer a lot of questions
um we're also working on expanding our
our online licensing programs to include
online deer registration and online ohrv
registrations both of these were
requested by the legislature this year
we are working to give the right staff
the right access to data to improve
internal efficiencies as part of the
prioritized needs from doit
we're asking for for
as as part of this prioritized needs we
are asking our D.O.T is working with us
to create a halftime position at Fish
and Game the other half will be with a
different agency
and this is a full-time I.T lead
position
um and some of you are well aware we are
working on another major gopher project
which is a hatchery rebuild project we
are finishing up the study that we've
been working on uh this year
uh we hopefully will have some answers
on exactly where where and what we'll be
building
um this project is a very difficult task
uh and um EPA set a 12 Bar per billion
uh discharge permit for us at New Durham
uh one of the things we discovered as
we're going through the process the
technique that we are required by EPA to
use to determine the phosphorus level of
the water
doesn't read until it's 10 parts per
billion
which means if we're running at three
parts per billion we don't and it's
gradually going up we won't know that
Until It Breaks 10 and then we only have
two more parts per billion before we
have a violation so uh there's a lot of
technical issues that that we're working
through and hopefully
um we'll have some answers
by the end of the year beginning of next
year
we got our efficiency Target included
and that included an increased cost
associated with fuel and electricity
we've asked the governor to retain our
general funding to return our general
funding back to the 2021 level of
funding we've had
this year I'm asking to add a senior
accounting technician to improve our
business office efficiency
this will be funded through the fish and
game fund I'm looking to replace our
part-time bow coordinator uh bo is an
acronym for becoming an outdoor woman
with a temporary full-time position with
a and this is with a goal of expanding
our outdoor women's program
I would also like to fund two unfunded
conservation offices positions with ohrv
registration money and fund the other
two and then fund the other two unfunded
conservation officers positions
uh with general fund money this would
bring our total number of offices to 48.
we have four headquarters and
uh right now we have 44 funded positions
for those who are at headquarters 40 are
in the field this would give us uh 44 in
the field
this is still lower than the number of
offices we had back in the 70s when the
department had 50 offices
I've also asked the government to
restore the department General funding
to pre-covered levels without this
increase our fish and game fund would be
depleted within two more budget Cycles
are there any questions
okay that was you actually in the last
Point answered my question I was
wondering if you could expand that a
little bit as far as what's been
happening with the fish and game fund
and uh the impact that moving away from
General funds has had on it and if we
don't do anything it will be depleted I
think you said deplete in the next two
years no uh sorry two budget Cycles two
budget Cycles okay
um prior to covert uh and I apologize I
don't have the exact numbers but I
believe we were getting about uh one and
a half million 1.6 million a year of
General funds this has been going on for
a few years
um when we did the budget two years ago
as all you remember those were very
uncertain time
um and we and we met with Governor's
budget Target but that hit us very hard
I believe we lost over 70 percent of our
general funding at that point
um
ESU comes in
if we don't receive that money back we
can get through this budget cycle but by
the end of the next budget cycle
I apologize we can get through the 24 25
budget cycle but by the time we get
finished up with 26 and 27 the fish and
game fund would be
if not negative close to it
we did see an uptick in license uh sales
during covid some of that has started to
drop off
as you're well aware
um you know
when everything's shut down people are
looking for things to do with their kids
and all of a sudden you didn't have the
ball games to go to you didn't have
school plays bands that kind of stuff so
there was an uptick in people buying
fishing licenses and hunting licenses to
get their kids outdoors
um
we and we also saw an uptick in ohrv
registration I think the ohrv
registrations will stay with us a little
bit longer than the light than the
increase in license sales
if you just think through it you know a
brand new ATV is fifteen thousand to
twenty thousand dollars
um it's it's too big of an investment to
just leave in your garage unregistered
and unused most people will either
register it and use it or probably will
decide to sell it to somebody else
that'll register it and use it
um whereas you know hunting or fishing
equipment it's a little easier to leave
in the back of the closet somewhere
okay
I know and unfortunately no that
recently you've had a a very well
publicized search and rescue mission
um I was wondering though with with the
the Back To Nature movement and and with
the a lot of uh towns and cities up
north uh really investing in ATV trails
and in the ATV industry
uh how much of an expenditure have you
seen in the search and rescue in basic
uh need for attention to that area over
the last few years as it has it grown
exponentially it has been fairly
constant it has not grown exponentially
um the other thing that we have is
um the height Safeguard program it's a
donation and that program has ex has
expanded quite well over the last few
years
um we're at the point now where we're
paying kind of the variable cost side of
it we're not paying the fixed cost of
having a CO there but any levels
overtime any of his special equipment
that where that we're able to pick up
with the pipesafecard program
um where
one of the issues that's come up and
that's the reason why I'm pushing for
some more CEOs and the kernel could
probably give you better examples than I
can a couple things like for example
this last
um search that obviously was a front
page search all across the nation
um the other part that didn't come out
was is while that was going on we had a
second search for a lost boy in the
woods in another part of the state and
then we also ended up being asked by a
local police department a murderer had
or a
apologize a suspected murderer had fled
into the woods and asked our cos to
assist in in trying to find that person
I know the the search for the little boy
included some of our dog teams that we
had to you know move down into that one
of the things that's starting to happen
is is that on the weekends we've had
multiple weekends where every law
enforcement officer that we have is
totally engaged in either you know
search search and rescue issues or
accident details on ATVs and we're just
to be honest with you we're just you
know running out of
um the ability to cover all of these
cases all at the same time thank you
I remember when the um when fishing game
first hit the general fund for money it
was a few years back and it was thought
to be at the time temporary yeah and
made at some point went away from
general fund funding for a while too is
it your expectation that this is a
permanent change we this isn't to get
you through something but that well part
of what's going on and let me give an
example of some search and rescue work
that we do Under New Hampshire law if
you get lost in the woods or in the
water it's fish and games responsibility
to come look for you
um
you know when my father was a CEO uh it
was mostly lost Hunters we were looking
for today it's lost hikers we've
developed programs for that but a group
that we end up getting called out very
often for are Alzheimer's patients if an
Alzheimer's patient walks out of the
back door into the woods where the
agency that gets called they walk out
the front door onto the road than at
State Police the local PD
um these are things that you're asking
the New Hampshire Sportsmen and or other
user groups of fish and game that pay
into the system to pick up the bill for
I personally don't think to do this
right and I do believe that for some of
the work that we're doing as an agency
using that as an example I believe that
you know we shouldn't I mean access the
general funds in order to
balance the books between Sportsmen and
citizens how much is search and rescue
going up over the last um like how much
you spend a year on search and rescue
I can give you the numbers from the
search and rescue account but I don't
believe that that really incorporates
everything Kevin you might speak to that
so we spend any sense
foreign
and so the argument can be made the
Sportsman's pain
almost a type statement helps with that
the displacement paying on Sportsman 100
office conceding at the children the
devastating of 14 cents
so it's it's time
for 20 years of disability to get
General funds I just think it's the
state's responsibility and we want these
folks to come up with me to demonstrate
that they bring a lot of money to money
we have a responsibility to make sure
that they're in compensation
it has gone up it is going to continue I
hope it boosted that tremendously
opposite Mr many puppets to keep on that
that literally brought people out of the
city because hiking was the same
activity and a lot of that sustaining
you're staying on
my own concerned to find out
if you're in the middle of this extended
Church
where I've got everything available on
reviews
of short staff we call these losses back
opportunities
and it also meets these guys up
and then you get a call
what I'm sure
she had to replace
constrained would not accomplish her
chief of judgment falling off the street
so that propose enough
that's why I would repeatedly asked to
get the numbers
and you think it's more than that those
costs have uh I think I heard you say
more than doubled yes over over a year
over 20 or 30 years
um that's helpful thank you
in absolutely treacherous terrain and
weather conditions I offered on your
knees crawling at some points during
this Rescue Mission and the expired
England who was saved them up family
ministry Memphis resource
across the state of Connecticut a little
bit
no no question
um my next question is do you know the
balance of the fish and game fund is at
the end of fiscal 22 ballpark at the end
of 22 it was about
right here 11 and a half eleven and a
half million and and what do we what are
we going down a year like two-ish or is
it up and down a bit my projection for
our efficiency budget
based on our estimated revenues and
Appropriations in our efficiency budget
at the end of the biennium June 30th of
25 will be 3.68 million
oh at the end of 25 it's down eight over
two over two years or is that over
that's over three over three years
that's 22 to the end of 25.
23 24 25. okay
so that would be at a level of about
four to five hundred thousand of General
funding
foreign
budget requests for prioritized needs
using the same beginning balance and the
same end date in the same estimated
revenue is 2.3231
and how much is the fish and game annual
revenue declining
is it flat our expenses are going up
exponentially
so the fishing game is increasing but
expenses are increasing faster correct
are you seeing fairly steady increase or
is it just in the fishing game fund
itself or is it
um you know you hear talk all the time
about the ups and downs of people buying
fishing licenses for example the um
the general funds that have been coming
into Fish and Game have helped stabilize
the fun we also saw a major uptick in
register I'm sorry in license sales from
covet as I say that's now on a
trajectory back back down but we you
know we know we won't necessarily I mean
you think there was a an anomalous
uptick yes okay as I say it really is
simple you know people trying to do
stuff for their kids and they went out
fishing or they you know go back to
hunting or they had a little bit more
time to go do that so we think uh do you
think 20 fiscal 23 revenues are going to
be more typical
of the future or are we still coming out
of it
um I think we're still coming out of it
any pandemic levels
they are going to be at this point in
time it's similar to fiscal year 22. and
the other part of our income or major
part of the income is registrations for
snow machines and oh hrvs we get a cut
of that before we turn money over the
answer
and um as I said
those numbers will probably you know
those went up as well during covid and
because of the nature of the usage of
them I think those those figures will
stay with us a little longer into the
future and that that money doesn't
technically go on the fish and game fund
that's just agency income no that well
the less than that goes into our rohrv
fund which is what I'm asking to take
out you know take money out of that to
pay for two of those four offices I'm
asking for
um thank you
I have a sort of a follow-up to where uh
Charlie was heading so if I look at
um your overall budget and then your
Revenue that's projected in their agency
phase it looks like the draw against the
fishing game I happen to be on page six
and eight
um but the draw against the fish are
fish and game fund is about 16 million
23 24 25 give or take 16 million and the
revenues projected are around 13 million
right so you're going to be sort of
drawing against your fund balance of 3
million a year right every year so at
that rate I think by the end of 25 you
know you're down to maybe three or four
million in total correct okay okay
okay I thought you were saying that your
balance would be at 8 million and I was
like no I think it's going down by 8
million I just wanted to clarify that
okay
okay so that that that Gap is around 3
million each year all right
okay thank you
thank you very much greatly appreciate
it
okay
we're gonna take about a three minute
recess and then be back with the
developmental disabilities Council for
their testimony thank you
foreign
I can't feel
an update for anyone who cares about
these things USA one Iran zero
45 minutes in
um
Iran can tie and still move on
the U.S has to wait
yeah
I think it depends what happens in the
whether Iran can tie depends on what
happened with England Wales
yeah
foreign
expectations
like to invite the commissioner to take
a seat
foreign
for you
good afternoon yes if you just hit the
button turn off the red lights on you're
good to go
how is everybody doing my name is
idadora Rodriguez legandre I'm the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
um thanks for allowing us to present our
budget here today
um so I like to just walk you a little
bit through about the council who we are
what we do some of our projects
um and then talk you through a little
bit about how our funding works because
we are 100 federally funded and um then
answer any questions about our current
budget that you might have so at the New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities or the DD Council as we
refer to it as we're dedicated to
dignity full rights and citizenship
cultural diversity equal opportunities
and full participation for all of our
New Hampshire citizens with
developmental disabilities
so we accomplish this Mission primarily
through education advocacy and through
funding Innovative projects that reduce
barriers and create opportunities for
people with developmental disabilities
in New Hampshire to really have full
access and Community participation in
what we call Community integration
most of our work is accomplished through
collaboration with other organizations
and entities that have similar missions
and Visions for the full inclusion of
people with developmental disabilities
in New Hampshire and so
that allows our small amount of funding
to really go a long way because we're
collaborating on a number of projects
and activities that really have a big
impact on people's lives so
um much like the governor's Commission
on disability is Guided by the Ada we
are also Guided by a federal law known
as the GD act it stands for the
developmental disabilities and Bill of
Rights Act most recently reauthorized in
2000 and that Act created a DD Council
in every state and territory of the
United States and so at such we are
federally funded through Congress
um
and we are what's known as a minimum
allotment state so it's their formula is
based on per capita incidence of
developmental disabilities in a
particular state so we got just over
half a million dollars a year
um so our full Federal allotment in FY
fiscal year 21 and fiscal 22 was
570 each year and that's after Congress
has approved their budget so from one
year to the next you know we may run
into things like continuing resolutions
or government shutdowns that really
influence or uh you know shifts in
priorities so we never know if we're
going to be funded at the same amount or
going to increase or going to decrease
but typically it's been around half a
million for the last 10 years
um our Council membership our council is
made up of uh at least 21 members uh the
membership is guided in federal law and
so uh 30 percent typically are citizens
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities 30 typically are parents
are guardians of individuals with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities that may not be able to
advocate for themselves and then uh the
other council members are what we call
our agency seats and these are our
Community Partners our collaborators so
we have entities like Voc Rehab
Vocational Rehabilitation special
education we have the disability rights
Center of New Hampshire we have the
institute on disability at UNH we have
the private provider Network
represented to ensure that the people
who support people with developmental
disabilities are also providing impact
on our work input on our work
um there are other state agencies like
the Bureau of elderly and Adult Services
that are also represented as well as New
Hampshire family voices which is the
maternal and child health program
that is also a mandated seat as well as
of course the Bureau of Developmental
Services who who is in charge of
providing funding for services to our
individuals with intellectual and
developmental disabilities in New
Hampshire so our members are volunteers
we have a we have a working Council so
our members participate on different
committees that are in charge of things
like you know monitoring our projects
and programs building our membership
and identify what our policy priorities
might be any given year because a lot
lot of what we do again is advocate for
capacity building for New Hampshire to
be able to serve its citizens with
disabilities as well as systemic change
that eliminates those barriers that I
talked about
so part of our charge is to identify the
needs of the people we serve and we do
that primarily through things like
surveys and
interviews and listening sessions and
then we we create a Five-Year Plan
taking all of that information into
account we develop a five-year state
plan that helps address students those
needs and potentially would identify uh
what we call demonstration activities
that we can use our grants and
scholarship funding to be able to
support So a big part of what we do
is we provide
um grants and
um
project funds to support things like
pilot projects
um and uh innovative ideas again that
support people on the ground because we
don't provide Direct Services ourselves
we support other organizations that are
really working on improving quality of
services or improving quality of life
for Citizens on the ground so there's a
little bit about what we do one of our
handouts in the finder today it talks a
little bit about some of the specific
projects that included a publication at
least the poor annually that is a
resource guide for families
um and a lot of what we also support are
things like training activities
leadership development for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities in their families and so we
have a number of Grants and scholarship
programs that help support that that
people can apply to and then we have a
committee that discuss is the applicants
this actually was super helpful during
covid because we had the flexibility to
create a new Grant we called it the
emerging needs Grant to help address
some of the needs that agency is
providing Direct Services were finding
before federal funds came into New
Hampshire and they were able to get
things like you know
iPads or or
smart TVs so that their individuals
could participate in things like
Telehealth and community activities that
were now being offered online
um so that's just an example of what we
do now our federal allotment as I
mentioned comes from the federal
government it's through the
administration on community living on
our annual Grant award we and I
mentioned that our word has been 285
000 I'm sorry 520 seven thousand for the
last couple of years but we have a
two-year project period in order to
spend those funds so essentially what
that allows us to do is carry forward
funds
right
um so that when we do experience things
like continuing resolutions government
shutdowns or shifts or changes that are
just in beyond our control we still have
a pool of resources from which to draw
down from and so
um our carry forward last fiscal year
was 285
000 and so we've kind of put that into
our total budget as funds that are
available to us that we can draw fund
from um but we don't typically budget
um for spending all of it because we
need to have that you know emergency
fund so to be
um so
I would like to move into our budget
which is pretty straightforward I think
um we have some new class codes that are
really just
um in order to better and more
accurately capture the expenditures that
we're making
um such as you know interpreter Services
that's part of how we create information
access for people with intellectual and
developmental disabilities is being able
to provide not only
ASL interpretation Services any language
interpretation services or
um
also uh creating information that is
more accessible through
um like closed captioning
so
um
we also again there's not really a lot
we we've had similar challenges as other
agencies with Staffing and so
um in the interest of trying to become
more creative we're actually proposing
to move from three full-time positions
to two full-time positions and then have
two additional part-time positions that
could potentially be filled by a family
member of a person with a developmental
disability who is available during the
day to help us with our project work or
our policy work and so we're decreasing
full-time and increasing part-time
um salary and then
um the only other increase which is
always exciting for me is the funds that
are available in our grants and projects
because that's really where our bread
and butter is it's being able to put the
money into the community Unity into
projects
and activities that really have an
impact on people's lives so one of the
bigger projects that we funded last year
and are looking to extend this year
actually it should be going to governor
and Council soon
is to provide Education and Training
around a new law that New Hampshire has
to related to supported decision making
which is an alternative to guardianship
so it's very exciting and and as a new
new possibility for people you can
imagine the amount of people that need
to be trained and educated on this new
approach because anyone who has a child
in school for example who is you know 16
or 17 the school is informing them that
they need to apply for guardianship
immediately and so this law now requires
that schools also inform families that
supported decision making is available
as an alternative to guardianship which
really puts the um self-directedness
back
um you know into individuals whereas
guardianship sometimes removes some
rights that people might still be able
to have if there was another system in
place
so that's pretty much all I have about
our budget as other agencies has
indicated do doit is experiencing
increases so we've added that as well
okay great thank you and thank you for
your testimony and thank you for all the
great work you do uh just I want to be
sure I understand the revenue
um
the I know you said you were on a
minimal allotment yeah
um and it looks like in 2022 you got 528
331 yeah but then it shows going up to
662 2023 and 765
000 and 24 that would seem to be like a
50 increase almost in in federal funds
and do I read that correct is that
what's happening so what's interesting
is before
23 we were only uh or up to yeah we were
only
putting into our budget what our Council
approved
anticipated expenditures were going to
be
and now we've received additional
guidance that we should be including our
carry for our anticipated carry forward
and that's why you see that big increase
okay whoever gave you that guidance I
would agree with it yeah thank you yeah
thank you
hi hi thank you for everything you do
um
you currently have a vacancy is that
what I'm hearing do we have two
vacancies I mean it's just you no no we
have two full-time Phil
and then we took one the the vacant
full-time that exists currently and we
split it into two part-time positions so
we have a big we have two part-time
vacancies that we're prioritizing
currently we have other smaller
positions so we we try to employ people
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities so we have a clerk one a
clerk two we have a clerk one filled but
we also have a clerk two and a clerk
three that potentially could be filled
by people with intellectual and
developmental disability I know in the
past you have um employed people
um with uh with disabilities is it is it
common or are they mostly interns
um so interestingly the young men who
currently Works was an intern through a
vocational rehabilitation program
originally that was about four
it was over
five years ago so he's been with us uh
almost four years now oh geez okay yeah
and that's probably when you used to be
over next to him yes yes over at um
South Fruit Street that's our
Walkerville now and then we moved um I
have a just a question about sort of
covet and people
um with disabilities and is it your
sense that
um you know during covert a lot of
people's World got a lot smaller
um a lot smaller and and that was
problematic for a lot of us and some of
us who have an inner hermit didn't mind
it so much but uh some of us did and I
uh for people with disabilities
um
it was dramatic and do you do you sense
the sort of
um in in coming back to normal if that's
even a thing right
um do you sense that's changing or do
you do you think there was permanent
um um I don't know regression is the
wrong word but a permanent difficulty
that's going to be hard to overcome
that's a really great question
um our community experience
unprecedented social isolation during
this time both because of increased
health challenges that made them more
susceptible during the pandemic which
increased you know their inability to
really participate in anything in the
community hence the need for technology
and
building ways and strategies that they
could make connections with people not
well not being in person that would put
them at risk
I would answer your question by saying
that
unfortunately the pandemic has created
huge gaps in how the service system can
support people with disabilities in the
community programs have closed
everybody's understaffed
dsps or direct support professionals are
wildly underpaid and undervalued and so
it it makes it more attractive for
someone to get a job at Dunkin Donuts
than to work in a day program supporting
people who are looking for employment
and happen to have a disability so I I
see this as a longer term challenge than
some other organizations or groups are
facing because of those additional
Workforce challenges in our community I
mean I think the challenges to the dsps
existed probably before coven it's just
gotten exacerbated do you think that
turns when the economy turns a little
bit or is it sort of so I'm I'm hopeful
I'm an optimist that's good nature that
um some of the systems change work
that's happening at the Bureau of
Developmental Services it's going to
really help improve uh or attract people
to the direct support Workforce
um in a way that kind of wasn't possible
before I I'm hopeful that you know
um through our in our rate development
system and that's a question for the
Department of Health and Human Services
not for me
um but I I think
reimagining our how dsps are paid
for and valued for the work that they do
would really help attract people to
um to our Workforce and again without
support some people can't get out of bed
some people can't drive to work right
they don't have transportation to work
um and so they want to be contributing
in participatory members of our society
but because they need a support person
to help them through some of their
personal challenges they can't be all
that they can be and I and I think that
this issue is going to again it's going
to be a little longer term than some of
the other Workforce challenges that
exist
good thank you thank you for what you do
and for your kindness
great thank you very much
thank you we appreciate it
I'd like to invite the department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
up next
good afternoon good afternoon uh good
afternoon community members uh public
record I'm David michaelitis the adjunct
general department of military urgent
Veterans Services the New Hampshire
National Guard who with me is a deputy
adjunct General Warren Perry
first and foremost I want to thank you
and your support for the 3 000 men and
women and federal civilians within our
New Hampshire National Guard both Army
and air and to our support of the three
divisions within our veteran service
portfolio supporting the 95 95 000
veterans from the state of New Hampshire
bottom line up front we have met the
governor's three percent efficiency
budget
we look at our proposed annual budget
for the next two years it's
approximately 40 million dollars just
like 39 and change of which 18 above 7.2
million Estate General funds
we break down those numbers about 88 of
our budget goes to Personnel costs
utilities contracted services to
maintain our infrastructure
when you look at page three of Our
Testimony you'll see the significant
differences from our past operating
budget to the current operating budget
there's six uh six items I'd like to
highlight first and foremost funding
efficiency budget is um we abolished 35
State positions we are we manned the
peace fire department and we converted
those positions to Title Five Federal
civilians because of a change in
admission so that reduced our state
Personnel from 163 to 128 positions
let me look at item number two you will
see what we have forecasted for
anticipated incremental increases in our
utility costs
for the significant amount of inventory
we have both on the Army International
Guard
you look items three through five they
are all 100 fairly reimbursed where we
have changes of purpose or mission for
example over time additional overtime
costs by having a personal State
maintenance Personnel on call for
overtime to maintain our infrastructure
and a new program we're standing up
called Starbase which is a fifth grade
youth-based stem program which will be
housing in Pembroke
item number five talks about contracted
Services where we had an exception to
policy to use 100 federal funds uh
sustaining some of our infrastructure
and ultimately number six is workers
compensation
of the questions that all I have
thank you
um
nationally the military and National
Guards throughout the country have been
suffering significant shortfalls in
recruiting I wonder if you could expand
upon that and how that's affected New
Hampshire and your operations here and
where you are as far as your need to
recruit
New National Guardsmen so the number one
strategic challenge for the New
Hampshire Army National Guard not the
heir is the ability for us to fulfill
our formations
um last fiscal year Federal fiscal year
22 was the worst recruiting year on
records at the end of the draft in 1972
for the Army both active National Guard
and the reserve component the active
duty Mr and strength by over 20 000
personnel which equates to an army
division
for the New Hampshire Army National
Guard it's a double-edged sword we're
trying to grow our formations from
approximately 16 to 1700 unit Personnel
to 1800 and we currently have over 200
vacancies
um we failed at our recruiting Mission
uh by about 35 so in any given month we
need to assess approximately 20 service
members until the Army National Guard to
replace our losses
and uh October of the last fiscal year
we assessed three
now we improved so we assessed about 150
ish when we needed about 240. so we
missed our Mark by almost 100 percent
off of the army side so we're barely
we're not even covering our losses on
the International Guard it's a different
Trend it's a it's a it's a different
Market our Air National Guard is fourth
in a nation in their entry they're 101
percent filled uh the Army were at 92
percent
it is a significant significant uh issue
because only 23 percent of today's youth
are eligible to serve in the military
the number one reason is childhood
obesity followed by the lack of
propensity to serve uh prescription
medications a lack of a high school
they're great
um the market is not good
is there anything the state can do to
help alleviate that problem or is this
more of a a national problem I mean
maybe even marginally to the state could
help
as far as as far as when I'm talking
about specifically Financial Resources I
think the financial resources that could
be beneficial to us is help with
International State marketing campaign
um we've had exceptional partners with
the Community College systems of New
Hampshire and the university system of
New Hampshire so for example last year
you know one of the biggest benefits uh
Beyond just service to your state in
your nation is the education benefits
with the National Guard have to offer
and that benefit is a 100 tuition waiver
and any State University so we can't get
people in the door we want to retain
them from leaving service and so if a
soldier or service member re-enlists
Beyond his initial six-year obligation
he can now transfer that tuition waiver
benefit to his spouse
so we want to entertain that family
member so she she he or she can
encourage that service member to
continue to serve
um the University of Simpson Community
College systems have been exceptional in
their support of us
um I think it's just the ability to for
us to get into schools
tell this next Generation the values in
virtue of military service and what it
can mean and how they can make a
difference for this generation Z and uh
it's just getting that word out
so if I could if I could add uh we also
instituted in the last legislative
session a program called the enlistment
incentive program whereby we give
currents currently serving members or
former members of the National Guard a
500 uh incentive payment if they refer
somebody who ships or who actually
departs to go to basic training uh basic
combat training this year's legislative
session we've asked uh uh some
representative to sponsor legislation to
increase that from a 500 payment to a
one thousand dollar payment and we've
increased the budget line from that from
twenty five thousand dollars to fifty
thousand dollars in this particular
budget so that gets us 50 incentive
payments which is about a third of what
we want to go we would certainly
favorably accept you know if you wanted
to increase that above what we could do
in our Target
uh thank you
um typically with military and being
former Army reservists
um I I even get this sometimes but you
know I want to thank you and everyone on
your command for your service I could
like remind people that there are many
different ways you can thank military
for the service and the budget is one of
them
thank you well thank you
thanks for being short
um in time did you um
that's a little harsh
um I was going to tell you what a great
job I think Warren does but since he's
here I don't want him to get a big head
so I'll tell you later
laughs
thank you very much
Department of energy
you know ready for your testimony
foreign
there we go Bingo got it
good afternoon for the record Jared
jacoyn I'm the commissioner of the New
Hampshire Department of energy joining
me today is Lenny rowdio our business
office manager Lenny also provides
support to the administratively attached
agencies at the department
um
we've provided you with a handout and
overview I'm going to my remarks are
going to track with that but not exactly
so bear with me
um
happy to join you today thanks for the
opportunity to present
um our budget proposal
um I thought I'd give a little bit of an
overview as a new agency as of what we
do and talk a little bit about that the
department of energy was created in the
last budget and was established
effective July 1st 2021 the prosperity
and security of New Hampshire and its
citizens require an affordable
Innovative reliable and sustainable
energy economy the department of energy
is committed to achieving that goal and
will provide a unified direction of
energy policies responsible and
practical programs principled regulation
and skilled representation in energy
related proceedings
at New Hampshire's public of New
Hampshire's public interest the
department of energy will serve the
people of New Hampshire in an honest
transparent and effective manner
the Public Utilities Commission the site
evaluation committee and the Office of
Consumer Advocate are administratively
attached to the department the
department maintains a diverse set of
responsibilities in the field of energy
and is comprised of four divisions
the division of regulatory support who
helps build the record in and advocate
for the Department's position in
proceedings before the puc the division
of policy and programs who administers a
number of state and federal programs
and helps inform and improve our state's
energy policy through our state energy
strategy and sustainable energy teams
this division also oversees our consumer
affairs group who assists citizens who
may be in need of assistance
the division of administration who is
our business who has our business office
manage and manage the utility assessment
Federal and other funds and manage the
budget of the department the puc and the
OCA the division also oversees
our attorneys who support our regulatory
team and other groups within the agency
as legal needs arise
finally our enforcement division
oversees utility safety and includes our
Dig Safe program our gas pipeline safety
program
our utility cyber security
responsibilities and our audit team
the department has very little in the
way of General funds about 50 percent is
federal funds with utility assessment
and other funds comprising the other 50
percent
of that about 83 percent of the agency's
budget are passed through grants
examples would be Reggie
um and the renewable energy fund
since the creation of the department
we've worked hard to find operational
and administrative efficiencies
the department of energy is proposing a
1.3 percent decrease in FY 24.
overall for fiscal year 23 the
department of energy has 78 positions
and this proposal
including priority prioritized needs our
position count would be 73. this is the
result of the reduction of seven
positions the conversion of a full-time
temporary position in the department and
the transfer of one position from the
puc to the doe and as you'll notice one
of our prioritized needs
uh is indeed that conversion of a
full-time temporary position I'd like to
just go into a little bit of detail on
that
um this position is a program specialist
for our weatherization assistance
program
um for many years the program is
operated with only one employee a
situation that is unique as far as we
are aware
we have intended to request this
position even before passage of the
infrastructure investment and jobs act
necessity necessitated it the the
problem is not simply that we have more
money to manage the passage of federal
legislation has made a number of changes
that have significantly significantly
increased requirements for compliance
reporting and administration the new
funding in this legislation is temporary
but the programmatic changes are
permanent
the changes have made what was already a
burden program impossible to administer
with only one person we have added a
federally funded full-time temporary
position uh and we propose to make that
a permanent position
so with that we'd be happy to take any
questions you might have
sure I'm gonna Begin by asking you to
answer probably an impossible question
but with the spike in energy rates
yeah I realized that they're
caused by many different in factors but
uh what what are your projections as far
as how long the spike is going to last
and when we receive relief
absence Russia pulling out of Ukraine
I don't know
um the the it's it's hard to make that
prediction
um you know I think everyone expects the
global market for liquefied natural gas
to remain High
um
you know there are other factors beyond
the war in Ukraine we are constrained
when it comes to uh natural gas pipeline
capacity into the region so there's
there's a whole number of factors and it
would be hard for me to uh I wouldn't
feel comfortable making a projection of
what it might look like a year from now
um
our hope is that we're in a different
situation
um and and prices are lower but
Ukraine does play a very uh large part
in this right because why why that's
obviously important I agree that I I
don't have an answer and I'm not sure I
haven't seen anyone else who does but
most every agency that comes in one of
the things that they're concerned about
are the their energy costs when you're
driving it so if there was any answer or
any relief in sight before the end of
fiscal year 25 that would be wonderful
to see it would be amen what are the
major uh challenges I mean I realize
you're a new agency and you came on at
the exact wrong time or maybe the exact
right time given the uh the turmoil
we're in but obviously prices have
spiked what are the challenge for you as
an agency for that and how can the state
help you meet those challenges
well
um I
we've seen a number on the Staffing side
we've seen a number of retirements in in
the last year
um it's difficult to recruit in this
environment and I think
um an agency such as ours and the
important work that we do
um
having experienced staff being able to
recruit
um individuals with the experience
needed to be fully staffed with the
expertise that we need
would be very helpful but that challenge
is we've had a number of positions that
we just continue to post and repost
those openings and very little success
in in filling those positions so as a
new agency with everything that's
happening in um in the world of energy
um having a full team would be very
helpful and beneficial to the state
um
what type of uh individual you're
recruiting for right so utility analysts
um
attorneys
um those are two that come to mind as
critical
and it's difficult to compete with the
private sector
um and even with utilities
um
for those for those individuals
having worked at the dra and trying to
recruit a utility analyst for for them
even though it was more of an appraiser
but just we would take anyone who could
analyze a balance sheet on utility it
was impossible to fund no it's difficult
if you find a pool of those people
please let me know
thank you do that
on on labor challenges um
its salary
or it's the works it's a salary I think
is I mean I I understand that to compete
with utilities who you know like defense
contractors and whoever else don't pay
by the normal human standards
um they're not constrained by the laws
of Economics but
um
it is salary I mean we as you know
agencies we can offer
um
a quality of life that may not be
available in the private sector
um but uh beyond that it really is the
challenge with with salaries
do you um how far off are we
wouldn't want to commit to an exact uh
number but it's a bit of a crap shoot
anyway but I said like is it like five
percent ten percent or like 50. yeah
I wouldn't say 50 but but it would be
probably in the range of you know 25 to
35 and I'm there's others on my team who
could probably answer that question
better than I but I would say it's it's
probably in that range
do you find that um you had a lot of
retirements I mean and a lot of people
did so I'm not
no aspersions cast of any sort but um
anything related to the turmoil is the
wrong word but
um
people don't like change
um I haven't we lost an employee at some
point because um
person was worried that we might
renovate
and in fact we're going to the building
that we're in and you know God forbid we
should get rid of some of the Asbestos
and um but it was it sounds silly right
but it was it was like I I'm nervous
about that so I'm gonna leave
and you're a new agency and you know the
the
you know the old the old PNC if you will
which is I know that's not exactly what
happens you're not just the new puc but
um there were people who that was a way
of life almost and uh and that's turmoil
did you have a is some of it
attributable to that or do you think not
really
maybe a very small part of it uh you
know we've really the leadership at the
agency we really strive to make uh what
can be a difficult transition
um as smooth as possible we try to
create a very positive environment
um and you have a lot of continuity yes
we do and we we still have a number of
employees that have been at the
department for many years we're at the
Public Utilities Commission for many
years and they they remain
um so we've had some of that um
continuity and just trying to build an
environment that um
they left before Lenny came right
yes no
thank you
great thank you very much thank you
and next up we'd like to invite the
Public Utilities Commission
foreign
Public Utilities Commission I'm joined
Again by uh Lenny ratio from the
business office
um oh thank you for the opportunity to
present the public utility commission's
2024 and 2025 fiscal year budget
the Public Utilities Commission has
vested with the with General
jurisdiction over electric uh natural
gas water and sewer utilities for issues
such as rates quality of service finance
accounting and safety with limited
jurisdiction over Telecommunications
it's the PC's mission to ensure the
customers are regulated utilities
receive safe adequate reliable service
adjust and reasonable rates
um
the only thing I'll add I might be the
briefest one that I've heard so far in
the last hour is that if you look at our
total headcount as commissioner chicoine
highlighted
we're currently at 17 people going to 16
with a transfer to the Department of
energy we currently have two vacancies
one for a senior advisor which is um
which can be either an attorney or an
analyst and then we have an
administrative position as well and um
so I'll just pause there and see if
there's any questions
yeah if you could talk about what your
source of income is in
we got it from and the
um going forward so we're yeah we're
collecting correct me if I get this
wrong but we're funded by the utilities
directly so with no General funds right
but but how is that is it what's that
based off of
you want me yes please
um the department of energy we um
we manage the assessment process that we
assess the utilities and it's uh in part
with um the money that we spent in the
previous fiscal year which was FY 22 and
then uh the projection for what we'll
spend in FY 23 and then any credits of
what we over collected for 22 compared
to actual expenses and then there's
um the law breaks it down on there's
some some utilities get that get charged
a flat rate of say ten thousand dollars
and there's some utilities that get a
percentage based off their their total
revenues and some like with only we only
take into account 33 percent of the
revenues that's all calculated and then
uh
um based on all four or three of the
agencies budgets and then um we collect
the money in and then we transfer the
revenue to those the other two agencies
that use that um use a utility
assessment okay then we also have um
special assessments for um uh for both
the OCA and for the Department of energy
that's um usually just one time things
where there's a certain rate case or
something that comes up um that we need
Specialists for that we have authority
to enter into contracts and just uh
create the appropriation that's directly
charged to the specific utility
okay can they appeal those
um
if you give them a special assessment
can they say we disagree and
they have said that but um then they
paid yeah I I haven't seen anything
where there's um I'd have to review the
the statute specifically but I don't
think there's anything that
oh here we have we have um the lawyer
back there
hello
um
yeah
great thank you thank you very much
and that's so like in a case like
Northern Pass and and or do we not say
that anymore
um is everyone trying to forget
um
it's an enormous amount of work that
like destroyed everybody practically
right
um
most of our costs are recovered by
assessing the parties
for the most part I'm going to look to
Laurie
um
yes
you see those would be directly assess
towards the utility that's involved
okay
you're not seeing any uh thank you very
much for your testimony appreciate it
I'm not sure if I know the opposite of
the consumer advocate foreign
I have served as the consumer Advocate
since early 2016 and thus I lead the
small and Scrappy state agency of five
people that is looking through the
current budget process to grow to six
and a half people uh as you just heard
about the attached agencies we too were
paid for by rate payers via the utility
assessment process and not the general
fund and I can say is the person tasked
with representing the interests of
residential utility customers that I'm
keenly aware that we're paid for
directly by the people that we serve and
thus we try to spend our or use our
resources very wisely so you can look
behind me at chairman goldner's face
when I say this I would respectfully
suggest that our role is to make the
puc's job easier and the reason I say
that is that by Statute the POC is the
Arbiter between the shareholders of
investor and utilities and their
customers and we put some weight on the
scale on the side of the customers
because the utilities I can assure you
are very well represented and we do that
by litigating very actively at the puc
including providing expert testimony we
also have a public education function
that has become extremely critical given
the current crisis people often ask why
doesn't the puc simply reject those big
rate increases that we've all been
living with and I'm in a position to
explain why the puc simply is unable to
do that
and ever increasing aspect of our work
involves Regional and federal matters
and and that really is because it's the
same reason that Willie Sutton robbed
banks because that's where the money is
wholesale electricity and transmission
are growing ever more expensive and
consequential we belong to Nepal which
is the stakeholder advisory body to ISO
New England which runs the regional
electricity grade grid and our work
complements that of the state which
participates by the New England states
committee on electricity every one of my
counterparts in New England has at least
one person who is dedicated full time to
ISO New England Nepal and ferc which
oversees all of this and so that is the
reason I've asked the governor to
include in his budget a full-time person
that I can add to my staff to do that
work we've also asked to create a
halftime position that would allow us to
hire someone with some accounting
expertise that we've noticed as a whole
in our capabilities when we do rate
cases my dream would be to fire find a
retired CPA who would kind of sort of
like to get back into the action with a
part-time gig and to be frank I'm not
optimistic that I'll be able to pull
that off but I would like the authority
to do that if I managed to find such a
person
I'm comparing our current fiscal 23
budget to what we're seeking for fiscal
24 we are seeking an increase of about
20 percent and I I don't make that
request lightly uh it's the first time
since I took office in early 2016 that I
sought an expansion of our budget for
reasons other than inflation we think
rate payers are well served by the
proposed expansion to the scope of what
we do I would like to thank the governor
and his team for being supportive of our
office since I took office uh the
department of energy in particular we
have an excellent relationship with them
Mr radeo sitting next to us provides us
with invaluable assistance uh before you
ask me I have to confess that right now
three of our five positions are vacant
we have the same Staffing challenges
that everybody else has and I would like
commissioner onlyhouse to know that
Laurie rudis and her team over at the
division of personnel have been
extremely helpful cooperative and flex
flexible with us and I'm very grateful
for that I do a unique perhaps among
anybody in the room have a crystal ball
in my office and so I will be cheeky
enough to actually offer up my
prognostication to the question you ask
commissioner shacoin I actually and and
we are very dependent on natural gas in
New England to produce electricity and
I've looked at Natural Gas futures for
the next couple of years and and based
on that my expectation is that there
will be some modest amount of relief and
electricity prices but the 10 years that
we enjoyed of cheap electricity I think
that's over permanently unfortunately
and with respect to our ability to
compete with other employers
for new hires my staff attorney just
left for a job with the utility
regulator in Massachusetts they offered
her thirty thousand dollars more than I
could so based on that one date and
admittedly you know we're probably
something like 30 or 35 or even forty
percent off of what even comparable uh
state agencies in the neighboring states
are offering to the people I want to
hire and retain uh with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions thank you
you did you mention that three of the
five positions you have are currently
vacant correct how long have they been
vacant uh well they the first one to go
vacant that happened back in September
and the two other vacancies are very
recent
yeah and I just actually I was but for a
brief time without any staff I just
hired a new legal assistant and we're
very happy to have her
I know they're fairly recent but what's
your
uh prognostication about being able to
fill those positions in a fairly timely
fashion uh I guess it depends a little
bit about fairly timely uh you know much
depends on how much flexibility it can
squeeze out of the division of personnel
I have trouble finding people who meet
the supplemental job description
qualifications
assuming that the division of personnel
is willing to work with me and be a bit
flexible I'm cautiously optimistic that
I don't know three months from now
roughly I'll be back to full strength
okay I've certainly been interviewing
some promising candidates but I know I
just spoke to one today and she was
quite forthright with me that she is
talking to other employers here's what I
offer that I think might be unique and I
brag about this all the time I the
office of the consumer Advocate is the
ultimate white hat employer everybody at
my little agency goes to work every day
doing nothing but what we think is good
for resident rate payers and we really
confront no competing imperatives and
it's very rare anywhere in the economy
that people get paid to do the right
thing exclusively and
how do you measure when when a citizen
or a company or someone calls up with
with a complaint are they are they cases
are they just you log them in as
complaints or how do you what's the
terminology for that well the department
of energy has a team of caseworkers
whose job it is to deal with individual
customers who are having issues with
their utility so we typically refer
those complaints over to them but we do
take note of the complaints that we
receive we get a steady stream of them
and my Legal Assistant is good at
knowing when something comes up that
might be indicative of some kind of
trend that I'll want to take up as the
person whose job it is to represent
residential customers as one big group
right and and that's sort of what I'm
getting at is is I'm I just want if
there are some numbers behind it because
I'm guessing that over the last
certainly a year that that number has
gone automatically up and I just wonder
if you had some numbers behind that to
illustrate the point I'd be making up
numbers but I can tell you that my phone
has been ringing off the hook in the
last six months uh and you know it began
about a little more than a year ago now
and and I I'm worried about what's going
to happen in the near term okay thank
you
I'm sure the division of personnel will
be flexible I'm sure too they really
have been very that's my understanding
um
um we wear white hats too our job is to
make the roof leak less and to make the
spreadsheet add up in all of its columns
and I don't do either one of those
things but I have people who do
um but uh would you say your job is to
make sure I pay less for electricity or
to make sure that there's electricity
when I turn on the switch I would say
it's both of those things and it's not
too much to ask that your prices be just
as reasonable and that your service is
reasonably reliable do you think the
state do you think the state government
and in your world has the capacity
to make a difference on prices are we at
the mercy of the Giant Eagle utility
companies
um
in the near term and it it isn't ever
Source Liberty or Unitil or the Electric
Co-op that I think are responsible it's
the it's it's the companies that produce
electricity it's the worldwide market
for natural gas and the fact that
natural gas sets the clearing price for
electricity almost all the time and in
the near term there's nothing we can do
about that in the longer term I think
the key is uh diversifying so that we
aren't overly reliant on natural gas and
it's not because there are those who
think we have to stop using natural gas
for reasons of climate change I let
other people serve as The Lorax my
concern is the rate payers and we all of
us repairs are too dependent on natural
gas generation
well kudos for the first reference to
The Lorax I've heard in 10 years
um
is it fair to say we don't
we don't do enough of anything in
electric
um you mean is there some kind of
electricity there's a Magic Bullet right
there are there is no magic bullet but
there is more that we can do across a
pretty broad range of initiatives I mean
you know the governor has been talking
about offshore wind that's an important
part of our future we have to decide how
willing we are to pay for that to get
that started but there are lots of
things at the local level that we can do
that are less Capital intensive than
building giant wind turbines in the Gulf
of me
okay thank you
thank you very much
now to end the day's festivities site
evaluation committee please
good afternoon
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to present the fiscal year
24 and fiscal year 25 operating budget
request from the Department of Revenue
Administration
the mission of the site evaluation
committee is the review approval
monitoring and enforcement of compliance
in the planning citing construction and
operation of energy facilities in the
state
ideally our budget is funded through
fees paid during the permitting of new
energy facilities
funding mechanism however can prove
unreliable as it is inextricably tied to
the number size and scope of applicants
currently there are zero applicants
accordingly additional funding is often
needed to supplement the enforcement and
adjudication component of the
committee's purview
with me today is Leonard radio director
of the business office in the department
of energy together we will endeavor to
answer any questions fully into the best
of our ability
thank you
okay what are your currently what are
your sources of revenue
currently our sources of revenue are
well currently they're virtually nothing
because they're application fees okay we
have no applicants
foreign
historical
um information so 21 I think the site
evaluation committee
um collected 3 600 22 collected 7 200
um that's kind of why we wanted to
um with the way the law was the RSA was
previously written is to
um budget in this budget
um truthfully that it's gonna we're
gonna need General funds however just
recently
um
chapter law 176.
change that wording to allow for the
administrator and administrative costs
to be budgeted with General funds and it
took that out and just added that what
we used to have as a footnote saying
that we could go back to the governor
and the fiscal committee for um for a
general fund warrant now it now would
put it in the iris the statute itself so
we no longer need a footnote but it does
say that the site evaluation committee
administrative functions should be
um
should be funded by the fees collected
which are at this time zero so
um that decision needs to be made
whether or not right now in this budget
for 24.25 it is
um General funds
um but whether or not that needs to be
changed would would have to be uh
additional conversations
okay so do you need something in hp2
to happen well um I don't um
commissioner can you can you talk on
some of the discussions that are going
on with the site evaluation committee
foreign
what
what that looks like and ultimately the
legislature
okay do you have a timeline of when the
legislature is going to finish their
work
okay thank you
that's why we're not we're not proposing
an hb2 language at this time just to see
where the legislation goes
um but with the change in the law that
came into effect July 1st which when
this was built when most of the work
that was put into building this budget
it wasn't known that the general fund
terminology was taken out and it was
just put um replaced by the the ability
to go to the governor and the fiscal
committee for
um if the um if expenses exceeded the
fees brought in which which it will
um but it's just you know what we've
done in the past I try to get away from
what we've done in the past because it
wasn't you know realistic but they
changed the law so now I think we're
stuck with what we have to do
okay thank you if I if I understand that
right current law when you're short
you're just going to fiscal and say hey
we actually have employees
um we're going to spend more than three
grand this year and uh we're going to be
short 86 under 82 Grand and can you give
us that from South that was appropriated
right so that was a footnote in uh the
22-23 budget but they just
um
codified of that in the in the uh RSA so
that's in the RSA now that we can go to
and our anticipation is it based on the
study committee they'll probably say
something along the lines of this should
be budgeted as general funds
is what we think
I would just note for people's
edification I think people know this who
have followed the site evaluation
committee from inside and outside is
that fair to say true
um that um
it's been a problem for a long time when
you have really controversial cases you
get a lot of money coming in and that's
infrequent and not desirable and so you
either have a site evaluation committee
or you don't but if we're going to have
one you got to pay for it and part of
the problem with the fees previously is
you do as much work for a very small
case
tip usually than you do with a very
large case and you get less you know you
get less fees for the the smaller cases
and the the enforcement aspect of what
and you can correct me if I'm wrong but
what what is the constant work that's
being done is not funded by anything
there's been there's been anger in the
past among some policy makers I remember
a council meeting which went very badly
um two or three years ago where there
was a site evaluation committee and
um somebody was mad that they that they
hadn't met and the person tasked with
the question said well
we don't have any staff and they and we
don't have any money to hire any staff
and they didn't think that was a good
excuse
which seemed a little odd
okay
great thank you very much thank you
and the hearing will be in recess until
tomorrow morning at
8 30 A.M
thank you